drop off
i would like to welcome those who have
just joined we will be starting with day
two of the symposium in 10 more minutes
let's wait for others to join as well
and meanwhile we began maybe those who
did not join yesterday or could not
introduce themselves can let us know
about their background and their
research interests in the chat box
thank you
[Music]
yes i can see some more participants
have joined those who have just joined
can uh put about themselves in the chat
box and let us know about their
educational background their research
interests we'll be starting with the day
two of resource symposium in couple of
minutes
and also those who missed out on some of
the sessions yesterday we will be uh
soon posting
each and every speaker talk
on our symposium page the same schedule
page where the zoom link was given you
will be able to look at each speaker
videos over there so if you missed out
on any of these sessions please refer to
the page we'll be sending out the mail
soon and you can go through the talk
and if you have any questions you can
get back to us we'll get your answers
hello everyone we'll be starting in uh
two more minutes
i can see and the participants are
joining as well let them all join
okay so i have an announcement to make
meanwhile we begin with uh today's uh
day two of the symposium
the participants who had registered
themselves for the symposium it's
important for them to sign up on the
omnislogic learn portal i'll share the
link in the chat box why is it important
because
as a part of your registration for the
symposium you have an access to the
online portal which includes all the
courses that we discussed about and also
people discussing today and this access
is for a month so you can go and learn
from each and every coursework sorry and
also have an access to demo account on
the tbi info server platform yeah so uh
that is why it's important for you to
have an account on the portal and once
you have an account please let me know
so that i can grant you the access
hi dr lewis
hello everyone it's nice to be back
good evening doctor
yes excited to begin with the two day
research symposium
yeah so i think you're good to start sir
yes so after the huge success
yes sir
so welcoming you all to day two of um
symposium
yesterday was a nice successful day of
uh day one where we had amazing sessions
and talks by seekers from india africa
us south america and today we are here
to begin with day two
and uh today we will be having again
different researchers and academic
experts from usa and india
and we listen to our great panelists who
are industry professionals from
federation of asian biotech association
baba prima's life sciences private
limited google and pistol alliance so to
begin with today's
symposium i think it will be a good
start if we could quickly review what we
went through yesterday and then we can
go forward with today's talk so first of
all i would like to invite dr mohamed to
please give us a quick review about all
the talks that we had yesterday and then
you may begin over to user
thank you sonalika
and
let me share my screen
all right thank you uh sunalika and
hello everyone a warm welcome to all of
you joining the second day of the mixed
research symposium
and uh we are really happy and excited
to have you all with us
and in this presentation i will take you
through day one where we learn from the
experts from india
africa us and latin america
about the changing role of
bioinformatics in academia and industry
so let's recap day one in case any of
you missed out yesterday so
yesterday when we started our day one
uh we started with our uh
journey to uh our journey in asia
and uh how we have been doing these
different programs helping students
addressing the needs of the students and
faculty as well as industry
incorporating and collaborating with
industry who are offering cutting-edge
technological solutions and helping
students learn from experts
so uh in this collaboration we are
trying to work to in involve and
incorporate pharma industry so we join
hand with farm industry and
organizations for training job
opportunities
and uh internships as well
so yesterday uh the first panel of this
discussion we started with uh different
regions as i was telling you that it
started with india
and we had a academic panel discussing
about biomedical education research and
application in india so the emphasis of
uh dr puniti's talk was about
bioeconomic growth which is which is
between india between years 2015 to 2020
and the projections by the government of
india
and that and to meet growing demands of
skilled by
biologists and bioinformaticians
the courses that are offered by amity
university so involvement of students in
research through term papers summer
internship major projects and
dissertations so we learned about a
little bit about the structure
of
of the bioinformatics and other courses
so we are the i mean there was also
discussion about how industry is playing
a role in this by involving industry
into you know student internships like
uh from serum institute of india knows
time uh biocon and all of those blame
others life sciences so uh also we
learned about learn from dr reed sharma
it was an amazing talk where she talked
about you know shrinking boundaries
between biology
computational biology data science and
all these applied fields she's about
she's a botanist who
transitions transition to computational
biology highlighting several bio uh
computational biology and bioinformatics
initiatives in india uh for example dbt
initiative to upskill students through
skill vign uh and then she talked about
the with one database for identifying
collaborators in bioinformatics and
computational biology that can be
searched through domains universities so
a lot of resources were discussed uh
during that presentation and uh the
data-driven approach for precision
agriculture technology for improving
crop for india was also one of the key
topic that she discussed so after that
we had a wonderful presentation by dr
ahuja
assistant professor department of
computational biology triple iii delhi
india so he was talking about the
evolving role of bioinformatics in
universities and research labs in india
and uh taking example from the triple
iit
uh delhi as a case study and he gave a
glimpse into triple iit uh computational
biology department uh facilities and the
vision and the various courses offered
from the foundation of biology to
statistical computation from a
perspective of
of curriculums and from a perspective of
uh
training and from a perspective of
anyone learning actually so it was a
great example learning through these
different academicians uh discussing
about technology transfer discussing
about
liquid biopsy techniques and
different
patents and all of those
[Music]
opportunities that are available
so it was a great session uh all of
those panelists uh
there were a lot of questions for them
throughout uh the
towards the end it was interactive and
then uh after learning and getting
clarifying
to all the participants getting
clarified for the questions they've been
asking
we move to the next session which is
more focused on working on research
projects so we discussed before that a
lot of application where these
experts discussed about their research
and uh what is possible so then we
discussed uh as a team by here in omixla
that how we are helping the community by
working with students and mentors and
experts combining all of them bringing
this omixlogic community together to
work on opportunities uh specialization
areas research areas and uh also we
discussed uh about how we have created
pipelines for universities to benefit
from such a program
so after that we had an amazing amazing
session where students
from all around the globe
came and presented their work after
getting selected through a rigorous
evaluation uh through uh
through the process that we have put
together and
i would request team members to maybe
share the link to the
to the poster competition or the poster
presentations that uh
that many students presented during the
session and uh all the judges were
impressed by the participants post a
presentation so i'll even ask
many faculty and mentor who are joining
to take a look at some of those research
um the research that has been done
via the research fellows and also from
participants around the globe as well as
for students who are starting the
journey to take an exam to look at these
examples
from different students who were able to
achieve this and we're able to present
and complete
so after that
we moved
to our
panel in africa and the programs in
africa it was a very exciting
discussion that led to different kind of
work that has been going on in africa so
we discussed starting with discuss the
considerable growth of bioinformatics in
africa talked about the omics logic
programs in africa and then the
university partnership and shared view
uh
by our team in africa mr uh adi kunle
and uh mr ryan fay and then we moved to
bioinformatics research in africa
through uh the lenses of these experts
working in very renowned universities
and uh companies and network
representing a lot of
specialized people and groups so in
these sessions when we are discussing
about the education and bioinformatics
and data science and application and
then how we are utilizing all of this
for healthcare and very specialized kind
of problems
related to the demographics so we
discussed about the various innovative
bioinformatics research happening in
africa and in fact
it has on the world and talked about um
the by how bioinformatics has become an
independent indispensable tool uh in
tackling various serious threats
faced by the whole world including food
security climate change health care
challenges
so highlighting the significance of
transdisciplinary approach in in
bioinformatics by
professor charles
who is a distinguished professor of
microbiology uh and has a experience of
over 30 years and uh over 300
publications so it was followed by
another amazing session
from uh dr verenad ross representing h3a
bionet and their entire project this
huge project that we discussed uh during
that session uh where the major goal is
to increase the number of qualified
graduates in bioinformatics and then
on-site workshops train the trainer
opportunities internships and the live
online training hackathons all of that
and then we she discussed about
developing multiple delivery model uh
delivery mode training models uh
foundation of local classroom across
africa providing
training coordinators adapting orders
for advanced training virtual classrooms
uh all of that com
that what uh h3a bionite is planning and
implementing uh by
collaborating and also by
by utilizing the expertise
from these uh trained experts such as dr
virena ross
so it was followed by a panel discussion
i mean all of this uh connecting the
dots like bioinformatics education and
training and then the role of industry
and the future opportunities and then
what are the different ways to evolve
and uh
evolve and also integrate some of these
elements and keep on doing this because
it's such an evolving field that it is
difficult to you know
keep up with the advancements and also
train people to do these new
technologies which are relevant for the
industry which are relevant for
healthcare and the need for
for the trainer and the need for the
faculty to adopt
and uh this was about all about india
asia africa and then we moved to our uh
to us where our u.s team and mysteria
broadski presented and talked about
current challenges in bioinformatics
training in terms of dynamic technology
lack of processing power what are the
different things that we have been uh we
have been uh
facing as challenges where this is like
it could be for you know curating data
um creating these pipelines and
workflows and lack of practical
knowledge so how do we address those uh
challenges we discussed about um
bioinformatics sos so standardization
organization and systematization
and then we also discussed about the
incorporation of bloom's taxonomy uh in
bloom's taxonomy if we looked at factual
knowledge conceptual knowledge
apply analyze and then understand and
remember so we discussed and looked at
the pyramid resources and then we
discussed about different omics logic
resources like training modules curated
data sets and tools and uh the t by info
platform and the coding no coding
bioinformatics paths and then it was
also about the hybrid approach where we
are incorporating asynchronous and then
uh different learning models to make
sure that uh everyone is equipped and
have the resources to do this so we
discussed also about uh collaborations
and partnered uh partnerships with uh
nappy network puerto rico louisiana and
also um we have had uh um
laura with us uh taking us through this
session with an enormous logic mentor uh
representing our usd
so uh after that we have this
opportunity so in the beginning we are
learning about the different education
system uh systems in bioinformatics
biotechnology and different allied
disciplines understanding that how they
work for students and what are the
challenges that these uh these
experienced uh professors mentors have
faced and their suggestions and their uh
those valuable um insights that could
help us you know bring this community
together and integrate those elements so
dr sona vasudevan from professor sunam
asudevan from georgetown university
medical center discussed about system
medicine
as an aspect of precision medicine and
the rapid explosion of omics data and
these new educational programs introduce
the system medicine master's degree
program that is taught at the university
about their you know different
core courses elective courses research
exposure and then how they include
analysis of big data ngs single cell
machine learning so briefly discussed
about the career opportunities uh after
the course uh is in academia and also
encouraging student to reach out and
learn more about it
so after that we had this great
opportunity to learn about strategic
projects and
programs by google cloud
us
so the main focus focus on uh on google
cloud for research purpose and uh
mentioned about the opportunity she
mentioned about uh ls she mentioned
about the opportunities for learning
google cloud skill uh skills uh boost
for students and uh
id admins google computing and free
modules and then the credit courses and
all of that so two types of community at
google cloud uh so research community
and the research innovator community and
shared about the stories of google cloud
research innovators from 2021 cohort so
there's a lot of things to learn from
the session that uh that you can take a
look later
so uh then we had enough had the
opportunity to discuss and learn by dr
adelaide rhodes who had 20 years of
experience
focusing on uh the
the fact that she haven't had a good
experience in bioinformatics or she had
like any experience in bioinformatics uh
recently and then she learned about
bioinformatics through mixed logic
programs and now she is
mentoring and helping a lot of students
through to learn about bioinformatics
and to apply bioinformatics uh
through
the program that she's teaching
so uh then we moved uh to the latin
america group uh panel and we wanted to
discuss and know about the situations
comparing different models as i was
telling you before that it is very
important to understand that what is
going on so we have people from
different areas geographies where
challenges are different for students
the challenges are different from
faculty so addressing and understanding
that is a key part of this entire
symposium so uh here we had the
opportunity to know this by
uh george
papas so he shared his insights on the
topics of big data analysis data which
is always
only useful if we turn them into
knowledge and then the deep knowledge
about
the background in biology and theory to
practice how do we do uh understand
about this computational tools and
programming languages and uh how he
himself learned and become uh
and learn through formal without any
formal training and uh
been able to teach this as a
computational biology and also to be
able to do research and also he
discussed about the limited
opportunities in brazil due to which
students usually go abroad to find
careers in this field and how things can
change in in a very short period of time
uh based on the data that we are
generating and the information that we
are knowing and the value that is it is
it is creating
so this was followed by another talk so
if there were many talks uh that
happened after the regular time in many
time zones such as in asia and africa
and india
and other places so um
here are some of the discussions i
wanted to summarize all of this in like
little depth because i thought that it
would be useful if you have an
opportunity to know about the specific
areas and what we discussed and also to
understand like you know what uh what to
look for if you want to go back and see
what was covered so in in this session
dr gabriel talked about the
identification and mechanism and he was
talking about the circulating femur
cells for studying metastasis and then
uh discussed about the identification
and mechanism of how um nra4
nr4a1 regulates expression for uh
immediately
immediate early genes suppressing
replication stress in cancer and then he
shared his experience working as a lead
bioinformatician for a project in a in a
pharma setting so i think it's a it's a
great session to know about how things
work in a former setting when you're
leading a group
and
then we had an opportunity to
get
to know about rosland innovation that
aims to promote science in youth through
experimental stem programs and uh
challenges of bioinformatics education
in costa rica bioinformatics uh and uh
understanding like uh the the session in
the context of the
the syllabus and how it is uh divided
like databases management managing
biological information genetics and
evolution and phylogenetics and
and how these different topics have been
taught and
how they are helping in education and
learning approaches which has been seen
as a very satisfactory for uh amongst
students
who have gone through this
learning
so
after that we started uh discussing uh
about you know wet lab student
investigating the role of s
stk38 in a signaling pathway so this uh
here mr p
piero discussed about the
situation with the pandemic and he had
to work from home transition to study
the topic using computational tools so
how one can transition how one had to
transition from you know wet lab
knowledge to uh to dry lab because of
the situation because of the lack of
resources and further like once uh
once because of this uh difficult
situation uh you you tend to you know
you have to do it there's no no
alternative you tend to you know find uh
really
the interest that was lacking so he
found his interest in this field and
then he did a second internship in
cleveland clinic studying protein
engineering currently he's currently
working as an astrobiology bio engineer
at a project at irma and he took his
taking classes on synthetic biology and
computational biology um
in
spanish as uh not much people speak or
read english in peru so yeah many
challenges and uh i mean inspiring
stories uh that led to this group long
group discussion that was the end of our
our first day uh that this uh this
entire
group discussion was was amazing because
it shed lights on different aspects like
umbrella programming initiative for
creating equality in stem and then
the purpose of how do we pool new
talents and how do we use
python and research
and you know art and research in
computational biology there are
scientific internship programs and
global sphere network and then dr
pogliano chavez discussed about the
computational biology programs to
understand human diseases highlighted
the problems of access of bioinformatics
education and briefly talked about the
promising field of liquid biopsies as
biomarkers here after that miss uh
victoria maria um talked about uh the
use of um
synthetic biology to solve the pressing
issue of leaching in brazil and there
were a few panel and there were many
panel uh question and answer so
discussing about where is this gap
between uh between academy and students
wishing to join research and then uh
raja
dr uh
expressed his views that it is tempting
to think that journey towards research
is linear however it is
misconception anyone can plug in
basically so this was a lot of uh help
this was a lot of help for anyone who
started their journey or were even
thinking about
just to getting on board and getting
started or do something and then build
on it so if if you were to focus on a
single job what would we what would it
be so this is these are some of the
things that we discussed in this session
a wonderful session and this is how we
concluded day one and i'm really really
excited to start another day the second
day and the last day perhaps of this uh
amazing opportunity to discuss and meet
people and to talk
so we are back and with yet another day
today we will hear about the perspective
of different researchers and academic
experts from the us from india also we
will listen to great panelists who are
industry professionals from faba
from premise life sciences google and
pistol alliance
so today we will start our uh our first
talk with our keynote speaker dr rudy
saxena who is currently a co-founder and
co-founder of the startup
biotech company region innovation is
helping students at faba and uh pine
biotech as a mentor so um with this i
will uh like to possibly pass the podium
to sunalika to introduce dr saxena and
take you to the first session and
another amazing day at this mix research
symposium another warm welcome and uh i
hope that you will get an opportunity to
write your questions in the chat box so
that we can address them as we get time
thank you so much
thank you so much dr mohamed
and i'm pleased to invite dr uda saksana
for his talk on on his technology in
target selection and drug discovery
process
i would like to take the pleasure of
introducing him
dr uda saksana is currently a co-founder
of the startup biotech company reagent
innovations he has held executive and
leadership positions at pakistan and
arbor atherogenics in atlanta as vp drug
discovery dr reddy's laboratory as chief
scientific officer us and india and
cario's therapeutic ceo
he has a phd in biochemistry from
memorial university and post doctoral
training at columbus university he was
associated with the team at park davis
pfizer that discovered lipter
and atol rastatin the largest selling
peak sales of dollar 17 billion dollars
drugs in the pharma business
he led teams that brought several drug
candidates from an idea into the clinic
and we are glad to hear from you sir
over to you
thank you very much analika and
thank you mohit um
it's pleasure to be here let me now try
to
uh
play the slides myself i have a 50 50
track record sometimes i'm able to do it
sometimes i'm not i still haven't quite
figured that out but
let me try it can you guys see my uh
screen
oh no i have to do a screen share is it
awesome
yes uh how do i oh okay one second
you'll have to let me do it uh it's not
letting me do it right now so
it says one participation
okay
can you see it now
uh no sir we can't see it if you click
on the share screen icon it will ask you
this window or a specific slide check
that you would like to share you can
click on it
okay thank you
you know you learn uh something new
every day so
it's always a good thing let me now play
all right so now you can see it right
yes
okay thank you yeah once again thank you
pam pine bio for a
very kind invitation and introduction
as mohit said i'm going to tell you
about omix technologies and
specifically their applications in
target selection and really all of the
drug discovery process so
i will speak for about 25 minutes or so
and uh if there are questions i don't
know what the the what the format is but
if there are questions i'll be happy to
take that so
so briefly i'll talk about i i think i
should introduce drug discovery to this
audience because i'm not so sure what
your backgrounds are so i think i'll go
ahead and do a brief introduction on
what it takes to discover a new medicine
then i will plug into that the role of
omics and clearly omics have a huge role
in discovery of new medicines or drugs
and specifically i want to focus on
proteomics and
their its role in drug discovery
right off the bat i can tell you that 90
of the drugs that we have today have a
protein target in other words if we did
not have proteins
we would not have had a drug so that's
how important proteins are in drug
discovery and as a result of that
proteomics has certainly assumed a very
important role in discovery of new
medicines
so this is uh to those of you who may
not be aware but discovery of a new drug
is a very long process and when i say
very long it takes anywhere from 12 to
15 years the reason is as follows if you
look at the bottom you will see that
in the purple color starting there's
three phases to it the first phase is
what we call
in vitro and in vivo testing
in that basically you start with identic
suppose you want to go after alzheimer's
what you have to do is figure out what
is your target so for example in
alzheimer's
there is something called tau tau is a
protein that gets deposited in the brain
as a result of which it's neurotoxic
and then that causes
alzheimer's so the target for
alzheimer's drug discovery could be the
tau protein and there's a couple
approaches either you can block its
synthesis or you can block its function
either way you can approach it so that's
how it starts it starts with an idea of
what target you want to
go after
and then
once you do that as i will
tell you in the next slide there's some
additional things you have to do but
from there it moves on to early
discovery in which the chemists
start to make drugs that might actually
uh block the function of tau whichever
way you want and then you have to select
the best compound that becomes what's
called a lead drug or a lead compound
and then you have to move into
pre-clinical testing
up until now what i just talked about is
all in vitro and then as we move into
pre-clinical it's mostly in vivo work
starting with demonstrating that the
drug you have chosen actually works in
an animal model of alzheimer's and
there's many animal models of
alzheimer's that you can do
and if it looks good then you have to
move into toxicity testing remember a
drug should not only just be effective
but it also be safe in fact i would say
more than 50 to 60 percent of the drugs
fail
not because they are not active or
efficacious but they're also toxic so
you want a drug that is safe which is
not toxic as well as efficacious once
you find that gem you then move it into
clinical development this is in humans
you have three phases phase one phase
two phase three uh phase one is
typically in healthy volunteers and then
phase two in a small population of
alzheimer's
phase three is in a very large
population of alzheimer's patients and
oftentimes you also have to compare it
with what what else is out there in the
market so all of this takes about
the preclinical phase up to the
pre-clinical phase it might take about
five to six years and the rest of it
really is clinical development which
means all the clinical trials and
something like alzheimer's which
actually progresses very slowly over a
period of years it might take about five
to ten years to do the clinical
development part but other than
something like covid19 as we'll talk
about it is an infection and that could
you know you could develop a drug there
much faster than alzheimer's
uh once you successfully demonstrate
that the drug is safe in humans as well
as the defecations for the disease then
you have to submit what's called a new
drug application to the fda usfda
they'll take about a year to review all
of the data and this is thousands of
pages of data that you have to submit
and eventually then you get
then you get approval so it's about 10
to 15 years it's generally half a
billion dollars and the success rate is
very very low you might start with 10
000 drugs that you look at but only one
is successful so the probability of
success is extremely low so it's it's
you know as you can see it's a very
complicated process time consuming high
risk and takes a lot of uh money as well
so this is not for you know somebody who
is weak-hearted so drug discovery now
you know why new drugs when they come on
the market might sound expensive and the
reason for that is so much of effort and
money has to go in by the company to
produce a new drug right so this is a
basic format of how new drugs are
discovered you need to know this before
i tell you about how proteomics are
important in this process
so the the number one step that you have
to have as we already talked about in
drug discovery and development is you
have to select a target and i gave the
example you'll see in the green box it's
a strategic research decision you have
to make
so the target could be tau
it could have been you know amyloid also
or there are multiple targets in the
alzheimer's area can go after
so you have to actually choose one
and uh then you have to validate it so
what validation actually means is if you
manipulate the expression of the target
protein
and if it you have to demonstrate its
relationship with the disease so for
example tau
if it goes up it causes alzheimer's so
you might take an animal model or
express tau protein in the brain and
demonstrate that you start to see
alzheimer's like symptoms right so
that's target validation so before you
put any money time and effort you have
to validate the target to the
satisfaction of
the company that you are working at
once that is done then you have to set
up some assays
which are basically in vitro asses to be
able to say that if i add a drug cow
function is inhibited or not
that process at that point chemists come
into play and you generate drug
compounds that are called hits then you
deal lead identification
eventually then you have to test in
animals in which you have to look at add
me pk which is basically once you give
the drug to the animal and eventually to
humans you want to know that it gets to
the brain or not right because that's
where it has to act so that process is
called add me pk
and then in clinical trials you have to
kind of repeat a lot of what you did in
the pre-clinical animal studies you have
to kind of duplicate that there so as
you can see
it's all depends with the target that
you select if you did not select the
right target which is robustly involved
with the disease process you are going
to fail and the longer you the longer it
takes for you to fail the more expensive
it gets clinical trials for example are
about 80 percent of the cost so off of
half a billion if you fail in clinical
trials then you probably lost about 400
million dollars it happens like i said
the odds of success are quite low so the
target selection the protein that you
want to go after and its association
with the disease has to be very robustly
demonstrated and convincing so just
showing something in a petri dish and
saying i think this is going to work is
simply not enough because you will that
you're setting yourself for a failure so
everything starts with selecting the
right target and usually as i'll tell
you
uh targets are 99
of the time they're protein so
so how do omics come into play here
before we had the tools of the omics
like the genomics transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolon metabolonomics
it was a little bit of a hit and miss
but now with these very sophisticated
tools you can actually understand the
disease better so to be able to select
the right target right you should
understand the disease process very well
which step in alzheimer's is tau coming
into play does it come into play before
the disease sets in or after the disease
is already set in right because once the
disease is set in
then there's no point in going after
taos so you want to choose something
that's up front and upstream in the
process
and it takes a lot of
gene expression uh proteomic analysis
and all of that so
not only in target selection uh as i
will tell you does omics come into play
but also now our ability to understand
disease processes with all these
wonderful omics tools that are listed
here has dramatically increased the
likelihood of success of a drug
if you don't have an understanding of
the disease
you will not be successful
it is as simple as that so any tool that
you can use to improve your likelihood
of disease understanding the better off
you are there so not just in drug
discovery in target selection as i'll
say but
this understanding the disease itself
all of the omics tools actually have a
fundamental role to play
uh this is just reiterating what i said
i've broken it down more into the
language of drug discovery at the very
bottom you'll see
uh you know starting from lead discovery
target selection and all of that we just
talked about every step of these have
some form of omics being used sometimes
it's genomics sometimes it's translated
tonomics proteomics or metabonomics so
at every step of drug discovery even in
clinical trials when you are actually
dosing patients with the potential drug
you can get their blood samples and do
an array of omics technologies and try
and better understand if the drug is
working or not so i think in summary for
this slide what i want to say it there
is not one step in the drug discovery
process in which we do not use some form
of comics or not so amics have really
really become very important in our
quest for new medicines and drugs
so of all those that i talked about you
have the genomics proteomics and all of
that i think it's very safe to say that
proteomics probably have the central
role to play in that that's simply
because the target the basis of
designing a drug discovery program
is selecting the right protein and
understanding it in many different ways
it's function it's validation
what happens to it if it drug binds all
of that so proteins to my mind
are the
perhaps and proteomics thereby are
perhaps the most important
tools that we have in drug discovery
today
again i'm trying to tell you where
proteomics plays at all obviously target
identification and validation the targus
is a bri is a protein so it's a
no-brainer you'll need also in lead
discovery and optimization i'll tell you
a little bit more later on
about that and molecular docking becomes
very important as the scientists choose
which is the right drug to move forward
with
right and then the in vitro and in vivo
studies even to understand drugs
toxicity and efficacy you want to look
at the drug might be affecting the
protein that you want which is tau for
example but it may be acting on
something else that's fundamentally
important some other protein that looks
like cow and which is very important in
day-to-day function for example in the
liver for example and the drug might be
acting on that too so that's where
proteomics comes into play in
understanding what else is the drug
doing beside what it is supposed to do
is it doing something harmful or not and
uh bio and in the clinical trials i
already talked the number one thing that
proteomics we use for in the clinical
trials is the biomarkers we use the
biomarkers to select patients to uh
select how much to dose how much dose to
drug with and finally to know whether
they treat they're responding to
the patients are responding to the
treatment or not so within all the omics
tools that are available to us in a drug
discovery program that is targeted
against a protein i would say proteomics
really is the fundamental backbone of
how we move forward in drug discovery
this is just reiterating the theme so
one you might ask why are why is there
so much protein why is there so much
focus on the protein and i'll come to
that one of the things that not all
genes produce the genes produce proteins
right certain genes may never produce
any protein so
it's not that simple to go after a gene
target the way to go after a gene target
would be to go after transcription
factor for example
then you know that there is going to be
some protein expression so
proteins really are fundamentally the
backbone of drug discovery upstream
things like rna and dna transcription
and translation are slowly becoming
important but
to the best of my knowledge 90 plus
percent of the drugs today focus on
protein and that's why protonics become
such an important tool
so what makes a protein a target right a
protein could be an enzyme a lot of the
kinase protein tyrosine kinase xenon
theoretic serine threonine kinases these
are all wonderful targets enzymes
actually make beautiful targets simply
because uh you know they have an active
site and using proteomics you can
understand and
x-ray crystal structure you can
understand what that active site is what
are the amino acids involved and you can
design the drugs so enzymes make
wonderful protein targets
structural proteins sometimes like
dystrophin in duchenne's muscular
disease
dystrophin is a structure of protein
it's very rare but sometimes targets can
structural protein receptor and we'll
talk about sarcoid too where the whole
field will focus on disrupting the uh
as2 binding to the spike protein right
so that's a receptor ligand uh type of
thing and it's very easy to antagonize
and lastly as i said sometimes in this
is happening more in the inflammation
field a transcription factor that might
actually regulate the expression of a
certain protein might become a target so
these are typically some of the
categories of protein targets that the
industry likes to go after
how do we select the target now you know
what a target is it's got a protein with
all the properties at all how do you
select the one you want to go after
ideally you you want
to select a target that is the only
protein in that so
if you select a kinase target for
example right the problem with kinase
although we have been successful is
there are probably 50 plus kinases so
first of all you have to go after the
right one and then show that's highly
specific for that one so because to
avoid all that we like to go after a
single protein for example tau is a
great example there is no other protein
like cow so going after tau is a
no-brainer for that reason
the other and this is the validation i
talked about it has to be directly
associated with causing this disease it
cannot be a phenomenology or it cannot
be anecdotal it has to be directly which
means if i up regulate that the disease
should get worse if i inhibit the
function the disease should should
actually get
much better so that's how it is that you
want a target that is directly related
uh the other thing that you want is that
you want your target only to be
expressed in the disease organ
and that is done to actually limit the
side effects you might get again going
back to the tau example tau is only
expressed in the brain it's never
expressed in the muscle or a kidney or
there so if you manipulate tau it's
unlikely that you're going to affect
other organs so
expression of your target protein only
in the disease organ is a wonderful
wonderful thing to have
uh the other interesting thing when we
select targets which is that we like to
inhibit the function that's why i said
enzymes make beautiful targets because
there's an active site i can design a
drug that'll go bind to it inhibit its
function
on the other side is trying to increase
the activity of an enzyme it's very
difficult it has to be done through an
allosteric mechanism not through the
active site generally and we don't like
that because those are much harder to
design so you pref we prefer to have
things to be inhibited
not to be uh
not to
upregulate their function but down
regularly
the last thing that and this is a really
nice thing to have is we like to have
protein targets that are actually on the
cell surface
so receptor ligands make fantastic
targets also for that reason why is that
the reason is in that case the drug
doesn't have to get into the cell or
into the organ
you know the organ especially for
alzheimer's is something called a
blood-brain barrier and it doesn't let
drugs to get into the brain at all so
oftentimes you don't have drugs that can
get into the cell but if you have a cell
surface target it's a whole lot easier
so that's so these are some of the
simple criteria uh and omix proteomics
specifically comes into
a hugely into deciding uh some of these
target selection as well okay so how do
uh drugs interact with protein targets
so here's an example i'm showing you uh
with the family of enzymes or tanki
raises and uh first of all now with if
the crystal structure of the target is
available it makes our job very much
easier because we know what is the
active site and we can then take that
active site with the all the different
amino acids
uh we'll talk about it moral how it
forms a pocket and all that but
virtually in silico we can actually then
select
uh compounds that are already there that
might fit into that pocket or not so up
front itself we could probably screen
50 000 100 000
in silico pro compounds that can fit
into the pocket of the accent side of
the enzyme and then only work on those
out of those maybe only 100 might
actually fit very well so your job is
now shrunk down from having to deal with
100 000 compounds to about dealing with
100 compounds so having a crystal
structure
is a very important and usually the most
useful thing you can have when you have
selected your target
okay i want to now move on to how we
apply how proteomics has been applied to
a disease that now we are all familiar
with which is sarcoid 2 driven covet so
what are the key features of source cov2
on the very left hand side you will see
everybody has heard of spike protein so
this is the virus and the way it engages
with the host cells human host cells is
through a protein called
spike protein how does it engage with
the host cells how does it get into the
respiratory system how does it get into
the lungs is through a receptor called
h2 that you see so if you look at the
second box there's the sarco v2 with the
spiked protein sticking out and then you
have ace2 receptors this is a counter
receptor protein that's present on a lot
of different cells in the body the
endothelium the lung is pretty much
ubiquitous so therefore you know
although the focus of covid has been on
the lung you will know now that long
covet which is the effects of covet that
come
a few months after the covet infection
can be affecting the kidney the heart
because they all have a stew there so
the virus can enter all of those organs
so the virus binds to the h2 receptor
and as shown in the third box that's how
it gains entry into the cells and it
creates a mayhem from there as you know
the cytokine storm
the inflammation and as well as the
thrombosis that sets in so a key feature
of sars cov2
infection is driven by two proteins one
is spiked protein on the sarsko with two
reset a virus and the other is the human
is2 receptor
so as you can imagine most of the
targets for covet are actually related
to either h2 or the
spike protein on the left hand side you
will see
strategies that target as2 receptors
strategy one could be to create soluble
forms of the spike protein within the
spike protein as you'll see there's a
specific domain called receptor binding
domain that engages with these two so
one strategy that's being attempted is
to design soluble rb2 rbd rbd so this
will bind to as2 so the actual virus
cannot bind uh you can also actually
make soluble a s2 for example so the ace
ii soluble simply means it's floating
around it's not
bound to the virus or not bound to any
um
organ so it's floating around in the
blood it'll see the virus it'll bind it
as a result of which the virus by using
both these strategies as is shown on the
second um figure there uh you can see
that there that the virus cannot engage
with as2 and basically if the virus
cannot enter the human cell it's dead
there's nothing it can do
vice versa you can also have strategies
to attack the rbd and this which is the
domain on the spike protein that's
important in binding uh the virus to
as2 and rbd has become the number one
target protein
or
target protein region for covid19
whether it's vaccines whether it's
diagnostics whether it's new drugs
everybody is focusing on rbd including
the virus the virus is also focusing in
rbd and when i say that what it's doing
is it's mutating the rbd region to gain
superiority so i try and escape from the
host defense mechanism so the whole
world of sarskowi to
is actually focusing on this region
called rbd which lies within spike
protein very interesting portion of that
protein this rbds and i'll tell you why
uh so this is just to show you the
structure of spike protein so spike
protein is actually sits on the surface
of the virus it's a part of it is into
the virus but most of it is outside
um so that it can bind to go and grab
as2
as as you can see here the spiked
protein has actually been broken down
into spike protein s1 spike protein s2
spike protein s1 the s1 is really where
the rbd
you can see that in the green
rbd lies there it's on the outside of
the cells
of the virus particles and
so that it can go and grab on to as2
all right uh the other parts are there's
also an enzyme too
uh which is called tempress i mean it's
a i'm giving you a short form that
allows once the h2 is bound to by rbd of
the spike protein then these rest of the
ancillary proteins come into play and
make sure the virus can successfully get
itself into it
right so rvd is really the star of the
movie if you were somebody where to make
a movie on sarsko we too slash kovad rvd
would be the hero i think
yeah so this is just to reiterate that
uh again in the orange you will see the
virus and then you see
the spikes coming out that's the spike
protein and on the human cell you'll see
ace2 and i just want to reiterate
everything we are doing today to combat
sarcoid ii slash covid is targeting this
protein whether it is vaccines
all of the vaccine either using a
nucleic acid approach or using a protein
subunit approach the antigen that's
going to be used in the vaccines is rbd
there's nothing else some people use
full spike protein but a lot of them use
rbd the idea is if you
either vaccinate with rbd or produce rbd
human body in small amounts you start to
have neutralizing antibodies that come
into play which will stop the binding of
the virus to h2 same with diagnostics
you know the there are many diagnostics
now which is the rapid antigen test or
the rat tests you've heard what are they
detecting they are detecting spike
protein
and the drugs i mean there are many
drugs that some of them we have worked
on and published are also focusing on
that so rbd interaction with as2 is
fundamentally the target for everything
that's going on on sarsko v2
so why is rbd so important or so
interesting well i already said it's
important because that's what makes the
virus enter into the whole cell
beyond that the virus is very smart it
once you have developed a vaccine
against the original strain right what
happens is that
once you have the original strain
once you have the original strain and
you find a vaccine to it uh if the
antibodies were to the original strain
rbd
will actually neutralize it so the virus
has started to mutate itself in the rbd
region
you have originally we had the alpha
then you have beta gamma delta and
omicron
the one big change in all of this are
the mutations are occurring so the
viruses figured out that if i mutate
change some amino acids in this area
then i might be able to escape the
neutralizing antibodies that's being
produced by these humans in response to
vaccines so it's trying to constantly
outsmart the humans by doing that so not
only does it escape the vaccine when it
actually changes or mutates certain
amino acids all of the mutations that
are have a detrimental effect are in the
rbd region to the best of our knowledge
every single one of them delta omicron
gamma they're all in the rbd region and
some of them make the virus bind tighter
to the ace receptor as a result of which
they can enter but they're more
transable
some of the
mutations make them lose the
neutralizing activity and i'll tell you
about that too so just remember the take
home from this slide is rbd mutations
are fundamental to how the virus has
been mutated has been moving forward all
these times
all right so one of the things you will
see is some you may have had the word
called escape mutations there's a big
problem what are escape mutations escape
mutations are nothing but mutations in
the rbd of the virus that actually cause
the mutant mutated virus not to be
neutralized by existing antibodies so
just to show you in the box here
we created vaccine against the
wild type rbd right and that we were
able to neutralize the virus mutated
itself it created something called v1
dot 351
when this happened
the one dot the neutralizing activity
slightly decreased so delta actually
slightly decreased the neutralizing
activity that was generated against the
original wild type didn't fit very well
with the
delta for example and so not all the
neutralizing could happen so the virus
could escape
actually things got even worse with
omega now there is about 39 mutations
plus in the rbd and they seem to be new
they seem to be escaping all antibodies
produced by the vaccines to the wild
type so you can see that having small
changes in the rbd
substitution of certain amino acids
gives a huge upper hand
to the virus in escaping and that's why
they are called escape mutations
escaping the neutralizing antibodies
that we are producing so sometimes what
happens is we are giving ourselves a
booster i mean recently in the hope that
maybe having higher titres of antibodies
might stop the omicron we don't know how
it's going to happen but omicron is
clearly is not being neutralized by most
of the vaccine related uh antibodies
that have been created
so the virus won there so far that has
won you know if with the wild type and
delta we are very happy because the
vaccines work pretty much nicely omicron
we have started to see some issues
so why is the vaccine success depend on
protein antibody interactions so
again having a crystal structure or
structure of these the rbd domain as
well as the antibodies becomes very
important what i'm showing you here in
the green is the rbd
and then i'm showing you breaking that
dot blowing that up a little bit
is that there are different epitopes
epitopes are just regions of
a protein to which antibodies bind and
because of the mutations that have
happened
the epitopes are changing you know when
you mutate a protein the amino acids
change right the structure also changes
inevitable that the structure will
change once the structure changes the
original epitopes to which you designed
your vaccine might be hidden or might be
lost or might not no longer be
recognizable so that's why
you know this interaction between the
antibody and the vaccine pretty much
dictates the success of your vaccine
right so if there is too many mutations
in the antigen and your antibodies
cannot dock very nicely
that vaccine is going to fail
i want to move on and tell you about
how omics and protein drug interactions
are important
in
for and from the basis of small molecule
drugs also i talked a lot about vaccine
but even in designing small molecule
drugs
the interaction of a drug and protein is
very important here's an example so this
is the structure of a drug and what is
important here is how will the drug fit
and bind to the protein in a region of
your interest and usually the
interaction between a drug and a protein
are either hydrophobic which means that
there are hydrophobic amino acids there
and you know your drug might have some
hydrophobicity
so there'll be an interaction there the
other types of interaction hydrophilic
there might be charged amino acids on
the
uh for example an enzyme in in the
active site and the drug will have to
have charged amino acids and interaction
there so there's hydrogen bonding
there's electrostatic hydrophilic
hydrophobic
all of these are important in the
high affinity binding of a drug to
the protein target so a medicinal
chemist once he has a structure of the
amino acid he will try and tweak the
drugs to see if he can fit into that
pocket so not just in vaccines but the
protein structure and proteomics are
playing a very fundamental role in us
designing drugs as well to make sure
that drugs fits very tightly with the
protein target tau for example
i also want to tell you that
omics are helping us understanding so
one in designing vaccine the other is
designing drugs selecting target i mean
all across the value chain of drug
discovery they're playing a big very big
role now the other big role that omix
are playing is trying to better
understand the mechanism by which the
drug will work
why do we need to know that why do i
care about what the mechanism the reason
to understand the mechanism by which a
drug works is then you can predict what
could what kind of side effects it might
have so if there is a kinase inhibition
is the mechanism right we know that
there is 50 plus kinases so it's very
possible that your drug might actually
bind to more than one kinase and might
give you side effects so knowing the
mechanism of action is a good way of
predicting the adverse or the side
effect profile and omics have really
played for example here you can see that
this is a huntington disease cell model
shown on the right hand you throw the
compound in and there are a variety of
proteomic technologies you can see
to see
two sets of experiments can be done one
is what set of genes are being
upregulated or down regulated by the pro
by the compound right so that gives you
some information the other is where
exactly is it binding and what else is
there
so uh there is a lot of uh
exciting things that are coming in
understanding of mechanical action of
drugs since the omics had arrived a lot
of i mean there is a saying now that a
lot of the drugs that were approved in
the 60s and 70s when we didn't have
these beautiful tools would not have
been approved today because they just
have too many side effects
aspirin as an example today if it were
to be launched we know it does so many
other things that you don't need it to
do including things like
gastrointestinal bleeding and all so
it's only today or in the recent past
that we've understood that drugs of the
past have many other things to do and
that has only become possible because of
our ability to use genomics proteomics
and metabolomics i would say i think a
very very safe statement to me
so in summary i think
yeah
this is my last slide
yeah uh omics have rapidly became the
heart of drug discovery there's no
question protein targets are the basis
of 90 per plus percent of the drugs uh
as you can see mutations in the protein
targets can cause dramatic changes
escape mutations
and proteomics is pretty much useful in
target selection drug selection
mechanism action so long story short uh
you know long live omics because of
omics i think the likelihood of success
of drug discovery is going to
dramatically increase so thank you very
much for your time um i don't know if i
exceeded by a couple of minutes or so i
don't know
yeah i did but
don't kill me for that please
i'm done
it was definitely a wonderful talk uh
we have a lot of questions i'll mail you
out sir and then we'll get back to our
participants with those questions
absolutely no problem at all yeah
all right thank you
it was fun being here thank you sonalika
yeah
thank you sir
thank you sign we invite our next party
next speaker sorry
and our next speaker is mr raja vermin
kitu and he'll be highlighting and
telling us about engine technology
infrastructure in india and its
application
to talk about mr raja verman he has
completed his master's in bioinformatics
from shanmug art science technology and
research academy his expertise lies in
bioinformatics computational biology
genomics ngs comparative genomics cancer
genomics and he has also worked as a
senior technical officer our clinical
bioinformatician at kokilab
ambani hospital and we are pleased to
have you with us sir over to you
i'd like to thank the fine brother for
the given
can you chance confirm they can hear me
clearly because you can see me scream
yes so we can hear you clearly and
answer your screen
yeah sure
follow me for the noise
in the provide seek now we are going to
fix the gear
so currently we are going to see what is
the infrastructure generally needed for
the nzs uh so i am just comparing nvss
to c c innocence the sc ac
so since there is so much varieties
there's so much of things to explore
uh we are going to surf in the sea now
right literally the ocean let's see how
it goes forward
so the main thing which you need to know
is ngs size when i say size it means the
file which about which commands of any
given machine is basically different
very different the file format as well
as the individual file sizes
starting from mb to gb
so in that case the size really matters
when it comes in just right second one
is which machine you are going to handle
and what are the applications you do the
third one is the checklist for readiness
when we say we're going to do the ngs
what are the things we need to have in
place
let's go into detail uh as i told before
the smaller organisms usually using mbs
and this
let's say human data you can go still
3.3 for 1x so in that case when we
consider for 3x 1000 x it's going to be
bigger and bigger
so uh this is not just to scare you
rather than to make sure
this is really the the big data which is
a buzzword which is happening in the ip
industry it's literally happening in the
biologist
so it's up to the depth so it's it's up
to us to decide how much that we are
going and how big the data is
uh again the second thing which we need
to know very clearly is
the data flow when i say data flow it
means how frequently we are going to run
the machine in essence what are the
samples we are going to load how many
samples we are going to load how
frequently we are going to operate the
machine right second one is deep
sequencing as i told how much depth we
are going is it like 50 x 100 x or 2 x
500 x so it's more than that even uh
sometimes people go for even ten percent
based on the question which we're asking
the scientific question we are asking
that that can go
uh like probably vary right and the last
one which is very important is what kind
of panel you're going to run this is
just a basic panel with a limited number
of genes probably the targeted genes for
the full exam or the whole genome or
holism
right so these three things has to be
anyway
should be understood
and the next important thing is
what are the things we are going to ask
so when i say r5
basically uh for any given english
dataset we'll be having a raw data
process data and we'll be going for
wrapping apart from the clinical setup
we might even need to do the re-analysis
or we need to review the tape dataset so
what do you mean by the analysis suppose
down the line so there is there are
steps where we will be going for
annotation for the given variance so
that will be changing with respect to
time for certain number of genes right
so those kind of cases where reanalysis
is important based on that even the
therapy recommendation might vary not in
the bigger level but in the slight
slight deviation spending are possible
so in that case we analysis is one of
the key factor so we need to be knowing
what are the things will be permanently
archived and what are the files or
probably whatever the details we need to
have always collecting ready so that we
need to go for re-analysis apart from
when i say review it means say uh five
years you have some analysis
you want to recollect in the five years
what are the variants like very commonly
acquired from the given dataset
and probably you can even find the
trendings in the sense the reason two
years what are the new variants about
what are the knees and findings are from
the given dataset so those kind of
repurpose related analysis
this module the second part has to be
considered so in that case when we
really go for the data management we
need to know what are the regular
accessories and what are the repurposing
concepts
right
and which machine so uh
as we know in the market there are
weapons
in this market there are
very uh huge varieties of machines are
available based on the needs and the
application we need to be sure about
which one we are choosing and whether it
is solving all of the questions
to solve all the questions which we ask
right
the first is purpose as i told uh
whether you asking a basic question or
intermediate or advanced whether the
given technology will help us to answer
this one the second one is sample node
how as i told before how frequently your
operating machine how much load
are you having like the reload which
you're going to
have it or handle it
last one is the capacity whether are we
having high throughput machine or
closure machine right so these are the
key points which has to be checked
beforehand
so uh i was keep on speaking about the
missions so when i say missions it means
as you can see the varieties start from
starting from 1.2 gb to
6000 gb so this is the capacity for the
single run
when we
fully utilize the machine uh
to a full extent right so as i told
before
these are all the uh
let's say low throughput and this is a
mid throughput and this is the high end
right
and
these
where do we use a low throughput machine
for sequencing the smaller organisms
lead bacterial virus fungus in any given
smaller organisms except the human for
the whole genome sequencing it can be
used so particularly for smaller
organism this sequencing machine is
being used right and
apart from this even the sample number
is less
and we need to have like say as i told
before 0.2 1.2 gb right so those kind of
smaller amount of data if you want to
visit let's say generate this kind of
facilities fair enough right
when we are going for bigger projects
say population studies or coherent
related analysis those kind of bigger
studies if you want to do probably we
need to have this kind of hiring even
including the kovid sequencing data set
we need to have these kind of missions
in place
right for example when it comes human
foreign
this kind of sequences right so this is
prone to give high throughput
let's see what are the applications when
we need to get out of this machine
of course these missions can be used in
all kinds of clinical academic and the
research currently what we are saying is
in the clinic and research it's been
widely used academy it's truly coming up
so we would like to see more uh
the missions which we discussed uh in
the in the probably the focus
right application wise if you see
uh as i told before you name it any
given application of genomics it can be
performed
with the machines which we discussed
whole genome sequencing whole existing
mutilation
cbd pgs comprehensive panel targeted
panels rna so you name it any kind of
application everything can be done right
so
okay we know about the background now
can we list out what are the key points
to do that we should be having to
proceed
so
the first one is security why because
there are very sensitive data been
used in the envious probably the medical
data sets
where
we don't reveal much details everywhere
rather every all the patient data will
be converted in the particular id and
that will be processed
in that case even the data access will
not be given to everybody since there is
a hyper-aggregated uh certifications are
given to the informatics tools security
is the first constraint right second one
is user-friendliness
since uh it's not like everyone is
mastering the informatics to do the
analysis and do the reporting so in that
case the friendliness is user
friendliness is very important
third one is basically audit trials of
file access why
uh when it comes to clinical setup
specifically
which file has been accessed by home at
what time that will be traced out
because that's very important thing to
back not only the batteries
even to uh there are multi levels of
screening will be done to release the
report even those kind of places this
audit trial is very important right and
the fourth point is basically manpower
as i told establishing the full facility
starting from scratch to a reporting
solution it's basically needs a
really good number of clan cover who is
very much free
and apart from that
we need to have a good battery backup
for the separate lecture to have
infrastructure and the room temperature
should be monitored for 365 days
and our dedicated network is needed
apart from that good internet speed is
needed why we these other things are
needed since we are speaking about
6000 gb data set from one particular one
you can imagine
how long it takes to transfer the data
set process the analysis and then
archiving it so in this case these all
the basic needs should be in place
right
so uh say i'm very new i'm from academic
uh since i do i can't go for all kind of
thing i have only simple laptop can you
do the ngs analysis yes you can do
probably if you see there is a there are
there are software like galaxy and there
are even some pipelines this is really
made are available which can be used
using even windows but typically if you
want to do in in-house without sharing
data with any of the third party
probably outsiders in that case this is
the computation which is expected like
this is a ramp this thing
processor problem storage is 50 db and
linux voice it's very difficult to get
as a workstation probably as a server
linked with the workstation is good to
go with so in that case you start with
complicated to answer the complicated
question this kind of computationally
right
so
i got the facility now i got the setup
now in place what are all the basic
thing i need to check to make sure my
data is good enough to do the analysis
first thing you need to know is coverage
like whatever the panels are sequence
have i have got all the data set in
place second one is dip
like whatever the depth i estimated have
i reached the definitions how many x uh
depth have you used right reads there
are cases where in rna kind of data set
you have to know how many leads have
been generated
further
and the third one is machine as i told
which machine should i process to get
these kind of datasets and uh sample
number as i said before how many samples
can occupy in one particular batch if i
could just sample this particular batch
how much of coverage and depth will i do
so those kind of recalculation
estimation should be well defined so
that the expected results are in place
and files to preserve as i told before
which other things should be archived
permanently
should be in the front desk so that
anytime you can access that part should
be very much well defining exceptions
and finally the process so before even
process i would say there has to be a
testing phase uh probably the beta
version should be there in place to make
sure yes every individual process is
going well without any disturbance right
when it comes to research set up
probably open source tool if you plan to
use how does it goes this is how the
overall workflow goes
the literature cell will be uh conducted
based on whatever the tools which is
widely being used and the same tools
will be downloaded and then we'll be
standardizing based on the data set and
the question which we asked
so when i say summary which means
fine-tuning the parameters when i say
validate it means same kind of study is
being absorbed
from the pubmed by publications and then
replicating the same work so that to
make sure yes my tool is meeting the
standards which has been already
published so that is the validation and
finally the pipeline again
every individual
application which we discuss have its
own pipeline and the steps every steps
will be validated with the relevant
parameter and then we'll be going for
the final product right so
this is a protocol which has been
followed for in-house development so in
this case the complication is really
very high and player skill
so in that case
there are alternative solutions which is
there in market which is basically
the softwares are already feeding the
parameters are really quick it's very
easy to use in the case cloud solutions
are available which can be used apart
from that there are some
servers
which comes with
fpga card where all the programs
programs are already feeded validated
and standardized the moment you probably
it's been installed from the day one it
can be used so uh i'm not going into
these two topics much why because
we are mostly going to speak about
infrastructure
with that i'm just closing this talk if
you have any if you have any questions
thank you so much mr raj verman for your
presentation
if you have any questions for sir please
put them in the chat box and we will be
able to get a question
and also those participants who are
asking about the recordings yes we'll be
sharing with you the recordings very
soon for that you need to fill out the
registration form so that we have your
email ids at least where we can uh share
the recordings with you all so we just
put the registration from the list in
the chat box and those who have
not registered themselves they can fill
the phone
okay so sir i wanted to ask the question
what are the career opportunities with
prema's life sciences
okay uh currently
since you took the name
for preparing the libraries and loading
the samples plus we
see when we have a specific marketing
team who takes care of uh probably all
the marketing activities and the sales
team so in that case we have opening
almost in all the departments at this
given point
so if you are asking specifically
informatics uh
i don't there might be a junior level
uh
intern opportunity might be available
but not a full-time job but with other
segments there are two things
observed okay thank you so much and the
next question is what could be the
possible online resources for ngs based
identification of microbial variety
okay so uh when you say the database is
already in place for almost all the
model organisms the sequencing data
which the process data as well as the
sequencing data is in place particularly
when i say when you say smaller organism
i can think about two things quickly
which is mtb and kobe kobe data is
anyway it spits out with uh decide
actually uh
at the same time even ncb sra has to
name it any kind of application
everything is already in place so this
is a few resources which i can think
about quickly
right and this linux are masked for
engines by
informatics what are your thoughts on it
is linux uh
yes sir the question is is linux a must
for ngs bioinformatics
okay is linux is important okay so
i would say the linux is even
i think the voice is breaking no
so the linux is important i don't think
so it is important because
as i told the last slide
the cloud computing solutions which is
which are coming up or which are in the
market currently doesn't need any skills
at all so it's based on which solution
you are looking for if you are like say
if we are skilled in the let's say
probably the scripting as well as the
linux commands then probably there are
certain tools which is again the fpga
card related uh tools are probably
developing their own pipeline can be
done if not then there are cloud
solutions which is alternative for
people who are very new to informatics
thank you so much sir for your talk and
answering the questions yes
with this okay
good
thank you sir it's a pleasure having you
with us
now with this let's
move ahead with our next speaker dr
vivektas
dr vivek dallas will be enlightening us
with his knowledge on role of
bioinformatics in the present era of
high throughput biology digital health
and drug discovery
and let me introduce uh dr gravey
he was born and raised in india in the
city of joy kolkata vivek das doctor has
been quite the wanderer having lived in
various parts of the country and the
world from having a bachelor's degree in
biotechnology from bangalore university
masters in biomedics from bit mestra
ranchi iga programmer analyst job he did
in cognizant kolkata he holds a pst and
reports docking cancer computational
biology from ieo milan an industry
postdoc at novo nordisk seattle with dr
vivek's professional career has a global
footprint presently dr pavek's passion
brought him to denmark where he is a
computational biology senior research
scientist at bioinformatics and data
mining department in novonordes he is
involved in biomarker and target
discovery in chronic diseases using in
silico approaches his present work
involves crunching big data from bulk
single cell multi-omics along with
phenotypic measurements that need
careful integration of interdisciplinary
knowledge from biology computer science
mathematics and statistics he also
explores the application of advanced
statistical machine learning and deep
learning models in high dimensional
single cell multi-omics for particular
problems scopes given the data bandwidth
as a part of some of his curiosity
driven research activities
and last but not least his hobbies
include science communication remote
mentoring blogging traveling functional
training hiking and reading
and for more you can follow him on a
premium profile
i'm excited to hear to your talk sir we
all are indeed over to you
thank you thanks for the kind
introduction uh can you hear me
yes we can hear you
yes i'll try to share myself
can you see my slider
yes we can see a slide
okay um thank you everyone and thanks
for having me here uh for the
day two of the olympics recently closing
um data and life science are getting
important impact um today i will speak
about the role of bioinformatics in
present air of high throughput biology
digital health and drug discovery and
what a kind of work i've been doing at
november and some of the gigs that i've
been doing outside as a part of my
creative curiosity driven research
um
so
before going ahead i just want to you
know present uh what's the perspective
of how do people see bioinformaticians a
computational biologist
and there are different aspects a
different perspective how people see us
um
it's sometimes very amazing very funny
uh and i i you know
would encourage everyone to actually
think like how bioinformatics is
perceived in today's world it's a very
exciting field actually
and you must have all seen how how
actually everybody has explained what
its role is so i will i will just put
some flavors of um
how i see it and how i've been using it
i basically am this person who is
basically
doing stuff with data these datas are
generated in-house from different you
know therapy areas different you know
biological scientists or from public
level resources and then i used you know
algorithms or methods that are already
developed or we are developing in-house
to crunch these data in a way that we
can make normal discoveries out of it
that can help us to you know realize uh
early drug targets or even biomarkers
for onset of the disease or even you
know
disease progression but the overall goal
is to actually feed them into these four
cornerstones of
medicine which is prediction prevention
personalization and participation this
is the four corners that i think
uh bioinformatics you know is slowly
emerging as a as a leading into the
disciplinary field
moving ahead i would first like to see
uh to give an overview of uh why what i
i do as a scientist in our department
novel not disc
we are a
big pool of uh 30 plus people now across
three multiple sites at novo notice i
belong to the bioinformatics and data
mining team
and
we stand on four of these four pillars
we serve multiple therapy area rnds we
serve uh different research technologies
where we provide different biofilmic
solution we also serve uh you know
providing solutions to understand
mechanism of actions uh
by using uh the leveraging the potential
of sequencing in clinical trials we are
trying to understand where clinical uh
sequencing can help to uh to get better
understanding of mechanistic studies uh
in clinical trials we have some
new trials that we are using the rule of
sequencing more
singles and sequencing then we also you
know working in translational medicine
but what we do basically in all these
four pillars are early drug target
identification
building analytical workflows for target
evaluation that can be you know a very
fantastic target that comes from
literature from particular chronic
disease areas
or data visualization because
as a part of informatics we also often
try to you know provide solutions where
biologists can you know
figure out
gene names how they are changing across
disease cohorts or or you know in a
single cell maps and what so so on so
forth and then we do a lot of biomarker
identification
yes and doctor vivek i am so sorry to
interrupt it between but
your voice is not that clear can you
please check my mind
sorry um i'll try to increase my volume
uh can you hear me now
yes i can you know
okay
okay i apologize for that
so okay
yeah great thanks
so what we basically do is we use
various public and internal orbics data
example you know bulk transatomics
proteomics metabolomics genetics
epigenomics or single islamics taken all
together
analyze them uh mostly from human and in
and also in vitro in your settings to
derive biological insights i have
highlighted the part human is because we
follow approach in our pipeline which is
more human centric what that does mean
is we start from human data we derive
insights we find you know specific uh
targets or biomarkers and then we try to
understand what setting of different
individual can help us to reach
the
clinical phase so that's why we have we
start with human data and we have a very
uh scalable pipeline across
human-centric language
now i will go more into the details of
the talk the outline is divided in three
parts one is bioinformatics in time of
high throughput biology and digital
health why is bioinformatics important
in drug discovery and what is the future
state and aspirations of modern medicine
now these are all my own personal
perspectives and opinion based on my
experience and so it might not always
align with everyone but this is how i
see the field and how i see the role of
bioinformatics in a pharmaceutical
setting as and beyond
so what is bioinformatics in the time of
high throughput biology
now modern medicine and biology has gone
a tremendous improvement in evolution i
would say it's a revolution
in current
age where we have so much of high
throughput you know technologies where
we can measure
different modalities uh from you know we
can do imaging we can understand tissues
and
composition we can do genotyping we can
actually also leverage the powerful
omics like genomics transcriptomics
proteomics
not only from organs but our tissues or
cells but also in vitro settings or in
vivo settings all these taken together
when we sequence them we can actually
build up a map or network at a cellular
level right and these when put into
sequencing machines can actually build a
huge information complex of multi-omics
in information that can help us to tease
out the different molecular
features which can help which when
integrated properly can help us to
understand the disease progression of
the or the kind of disease drivers
and and what this gives us actually to
help us to understand
how does the central dogma molecular
biology work i consider that as the
hottest science in town basically
because it helps us to understand the
basic foundations of the entire
molecular journey
and this is still the key to understand
any development of disease biology and
sequencing
high throughput sequencing of different
types of uh omics can actually do this
what it does is basically it tries to
accrue all these information from
different
organs or tissues or cells from the
human system
a true or let's say uh you know build uh
or
achieve the information from each type
of different molecules together
stitch them with the information that we
get from the clinical notes or the
imaging
put them together with suitable models
or methods
but in the end it's trying to derive the
relationship between the genotype and
phenotype and once we get this
information we can actually better
understand a diseased footprint
now why is bioinformatics important in
drug discovery
now medicine over the years have been
undergoing some paradigms what does
paradigm shift means here we know that
one-size-fits-all theory in medicine
doesn't work not every every therapy
works with for everyone some have you
know benefits some don't some even have
adverse events so we have been seeing a
change from stratified to a more precise
medicine and what precision medicine is
actually ensuring is trying to say we
can deliver the right intervention
to the right patient at the right time
and how this can be done this can be
done with individual patient level
information that can actually you know
take information from genomics and other
comics
you know club them with the different
information of lifestyles their
preferences their health records and
medical history
all taken together so that we can
deliver a very
tailored therapeutics to each patient
and this is the dream where what where
the medicine is actually going and most
of our you know uh
industry are also trying to understand
how we can actually implement this in
our system when we are trying to
generate new drugs or new therapeutics
and another part is over the years we
have also learned that the drug
development journey is actually
very very slow and expensive
a lot of candidates fail not every drugs
have great effects most of mileage of
marginal so this poses problems right
because it's a huge investment so for us
it's very important now that we need to
have
much more clear and effective solutions
and how can we do that with the help of
sequencing our omics where when we talk
about bioinformatics bioinformatics come
from fact that we are able to sequence
or you know have omics information from
different layers of the molecular
biology right and each of these plates
has its own specific roles to contribute
to any kind of biomarker and drug target
discovery in any kind of disease
understanding or development of biology
understanding as you can see from this
slide taken together with any kind of
clinical information
now when we take together all these
information we have to be also very
efficient of what models and methods we
are using right if we are talking that
we want to develop biomarkers or drug
targets now this whole thing is called
era of omics medicine and i i i find it
very enriching that over the years
due to
how the field has emerged how our you
know scholars in the academic field has
helped us this has become now very
important
component also in the pharmaceutical
industry
and we are now joining this journey as
well
some of the applications of omega driven
medicine where bioinformatics feed into
is population genetics and genomics some
of you might heard about you know single
lingual polymorphism or genomic
association studies that forms into this
then development of biology learning or
disease biology learning using different
kind of multiomics of organs tissues and
cells longitudinal studies or
cross-sectional geomics
and then
early drug discovery and therapeutics i
have highlighted some of the disease
areas that we work in at logo ones that
are bold are the ones where i contribute
and i work and i give my
scientific expertise
however
all these are great
but these are all mostly done in a
population of cells a population that
was not having information of cellular
resolution
these lack that cell level information
uh because we were always looking into
in a more holistic manner where all the
effect of these cells were actually
averaged up
a human body is complex as we know as we
are learning now of some new
technologies that have emerged in the
last few years that our system has
actually trillions of cell and some
share commonly used and some do not and
that's when the era of the singles and
technologies emerged right
and one of the exciting example of this
was this uh new treatment that came out
uh from from the consortium of the human
lung cell atlas where they are able to
for now create and map
uh a big uh human cell atlas
human cell lung atlas around that maps
around over 2 million cells from 444
individual now this is a massive task
that has been done by some brilliant
scientists from the
uh in the field that has
used you know bioinformatics that have
used biology that if you simply display
computer science mathematics and
statistics and machine learning all
together to understand
what are the different you know cell
types that are involved
in in any disease setting
when we are having when we are looking
into the lungs
what are the cell types that are
affected by variants what are the what
are the effects of age smoking and pmi
whatsoever so this is one of the biggest
tasks that was that came out recently
and this is a wonderful example of of
the single cell technology
however this kind of high throughput
work
is also very complex because it builds a
huge
information complex it helps it runs us
into the problem of dimensionality curse
overfitting
any kind of you know linear non-linear
structure and lack of generalizability
why because we are talking about matrix
like big tables where big tables is
composed of multiple dimensions these
dimensions comes from features that can
be your genes proteins metabolites and
across your observations now
observations in the bulk setting is your
patients animal samples but when you
think of single cells it's each cell
coming from all these information right
so that's a huge information complex
and this is often very challenging and
this is where bioinformatics is
challenging right and i have discussed
about it in a in a systematic review
uh in 2020 where i try to stress that
how multiomics field work should be done
what are the you know caveats what are
the pros what are the cons and what we
need when we want to start on embark on
this journey and then in single cell
field also there are amazing uh paper
out there which also
speaks about what are the different
challenges in these pertaining to the
data science because when we talk about
these interdis high dimensional
interdisciplinary field we know that it
comes with its own caveats and these
caveats some of them can be data
sparsity data heterogeneity
non-flexibility of the statistical
frameworks the missingness of the data
and then integration
we we can tackle some of these but they
are not that easy
how we can is if we can build tools that
are well benchmarked or systematically
you know check with other computing
tools we we can solve some of these
problems but there's a lot of work that
needs to be done there there
not every
problems have been tackled some of them
that we have mentioned in these papers
but not everything so there's a lot of
scope of research out there and
bioinformatics has to you know play a
lot of role in this
now here what i'm trying to say is apart
from the work i do as a part of the
scientist
for the company i work for novel artists
i also sometimes you know do work with
certain students back in india
where i you know put my brains in some
curiosity driven projects
and as a part of these prop projects i
think about problems uh in method
development for bulk multiomics
integration as you can see here on the
left then i'm very fascinated by the
concept of single cell technologies and
how by hydraulic biology in forms of
single cell is such a big data in terms
of the dimensionality and and this often
begs me to question
what are the best way to actually
squeeze those high dimensional data in a
small latent representation so that it's
human readable human
can understand and make derived insights
from it and that that's where the you
know the concepts of dimension reduction
methods and you know clustering kicks in
and then when we look into these single
cell
we have to have
have those single cell in specific
clusters and this cluster is to have
certain identity and these are not very
easy tasks because when you're talking
about labeling those clusters identity
where the group of cells comes together
which means that we are trying to say
that that identity belongs to a specific
biology and we call them as cell type
labels and i've been also been uh
thinking around those problems quite uh
for for quite quite some time mostly on
the uh on the
mathematical side like how we can get
better at those cell type labeling so
these are some of the curiosity
different problems that i have been also
working uh as a part of my
site projects uh two of them i have
highlighted and i will share a bit of
those work in the next slides uh one is
how to better integrate multiomics data
by improving future extraction issues
and can we improve singles and notation
using a better embedding method
the first one is uh based on multiomics
here in 2020 i i grew i teamed up with a
few researchers back in india but i try
to understand
can i estimate
a gene expression function
uh from dna methylation which is an
epigenomic information and copy number
variation at protein coding region
and we came up with a you know a method
of feature extraction we thought that
this is an issue of feature extraction
at high dimension
uh we came up with a method that
involves uh deep data using our auto
encoder and multi-layer perceptron and
we tipped together we were able to see
if we integrate this information from
you know genetic collision and copy
number can we estimate uh mrna and if we
can estimate this mrna how good is that
estimate from the real
data and we used uh
you know liver hepatocellular cancer
carcinoma data from the cancer genome
atlas that had
over 400 patients data and it was
exciting to see that when we were able
to actually build a model we were able
to predict uh the the observed rna
values as good as the real ones but that
does not end the story right when you
build the model it's also important how
good your model is uh when it's being
tested with every other existing models
that are out there
and when we did that we benchmarked
systematically a different
regularization hyperparameter
how our model is working we found that
our model was actually working as one of
the top models we did in three different
variants and one of the variants of the
models was working
came out as as one of the top with the
least
error so this was very encouraging uh
for me to think how multiomics
as a feature extraction issue can be
actually improved
next i wanted to stress a bit on my
single cell work that i've been doing
how i'm thinking about the field and
where the problem scopes are same but
before that i want to
say that single cell field is massive
there's a lot of work uh one can do it's
beyond what we did with bulk or mix
makes about multi-omics we can get
information both at cell level and a
gene level which was usually we often
did at gene level when we were looking
into always the multi-omics right we did
you know differential expression gene
search in regular networks but now we
can add another layer of information we
can actually understand what is the
trajectory of a disease what is this
different states of these what cell
states are involved what are the
composition of those and what are the
clusters that we can derive from when we
are actually sequencing these uh cell
populations
i am particularly interested in two uh
problems as at this moment where i'm
trying to think uh single cell problem
scopes based on clustering and cell cell
cluster annotation and uh recently uh
one of the work uh that uh
i have worked with uh
with two researchers back in india got
accepted um
it will be out in the next week in
online uh where i thought of the cell
type annotation uh are using single cell
data as a problem embedding
what i thought was like given we have
these you know huge data matrices of
cell and gene
what if if i think of this uh problem of
you know cell type labeling or
clustering annotation whatever you may
say
more as a problem of cell embedding
or and uh you know clustering so we came
up with an approach where we tried to
use uh
non-negative macro fraction
factorization to diamond to redo to
reduce the dimension of the data of
these you know cell position matrices
across different uh samples and then try
to understand if we can
then additionally use
recursive k-means to cluster the data
and we can actually define the cell
types from limited labels that we
already have from the data and in fact
uh this was this we tested on like
six or seven eight different uh data
sets that are publicly available thanks
to the research community
and when we did any kind of accuracy in
performance we saw that
our method was working very well
interestingly what we also did was we
randomly then you know missed out the
the real labels that were available with
the data to understand
how well there are cluster similarities
and we found that our methods was
actually having a very high cluster
similarity as you can see from the ara
indexes
for each of these datasets now again as
i always say i'm a big fan of you know
systematically benchmarking i always
think that why will someone use my
method if i'm not actually you know
looking at its performance with anyone
any other methods
so i took a step back and then i tried
to understand well now given that we
have seen that it is performing well how
does this perform with you know existing
semi supervised method or uh
unsupervised method and here there are
some representative images where i was
able to see that our method was actually
performing uh very well in
more than
five data sets out of six
when compared to another semi supervised
method that was recently published
called color
as you can see from the accuracy plots
and then i compared uh the cluster
similarity using uh uh against uh an
unsupervised method called zeroth which
is very popular in this uh single cell
field i was able to find that at least
for fifty percent of the data set our
method was as good as jura
and
but it was good across almost all the
data sets apart from one from the other
semi-supervised method
then in
additionally
i actually also we also actually tested
the method
for intra and inter cluster dispersion
with two data sets that were
downloaded from the european
bioinformatics institute server
where there were real missing
annotations when i say real missing
annotation means these data sets had
had a cloud of you know cells
which did not have actually any kind of
cell type information so we wanted to
see whether we can redefine using our
method uh that those data sets and can
we actually define get cell classes out
of it and when we did that we found that
our method was actually outperforming uh
the you know the sierra at that time so
this was very encouraging for us that
looking the of the cell type problem as
a problem of you know embedding and
clustering you're able to come with us
very efficient simple
scalable method
so here i'm now progressing to the end
part of my slide the last slides are
future state of aspirin and aspirations
of modern medicine
i see that medicine is actually
going interdisciplinary in terms of
cell-based intercepting
why because now we have
a huge explosion of you know single cell
data and single cell multi or mix of
single data means a lot of uh you know
advanced statistical and machine
learning methods because the data
dimension is huge
and and this also means we are also
getting better at understanding
orthogonal you know experimental disease
knowledge but this is a great future for
us because now we are trying to go in a
high dimensional era of medicine where
we are trying to understand the disease
trajectory from healthy to different
type of disease being neurological
cancer or you know
chronic
but we can actually understand one cell
at a time how the disease is evolving
and we can actually detect early which
can actually understand this uh the
molecular mechanisms and actually you
know get better new drug targets and
these are these can all happen if we can
efficiently use bioinformatics
so here i come to my last slide
uh i hope i was able to convey how
bioinformatics is actually you know
helping the modern medicine and biology
all these informations that we are
trying to accrue these days using
molecular spatial molecular astrological
anatomical
this is
uh a huge abundance of data
these are
you know high dimensional data
but the overall goal is to
take all these different modalities of
clear together
build up integrated you know cell uh
phenotypic map that can be multi-scale
multimodal
which can actually help us to understand
the underlying phenotype of the cell and
when we understand the phenotype the
cell we can better understand the states
that can be the you know epigenomic
states the cellular interaction the
tissue organization you know and the
identification of some sometimes news of
a cell type which eventually can help us
to understand disease mechanisms
interactions you know signatures and new
biomarkers
all and
overall can help in designing leaner
clinical trials
which can improve personalized medicine
and eventually also help us building
you know better improved drugs
so this is how i see the field of
bioinformatics contributing to the
modern medicine
and i hope
i was able to
share some of the thoughts with you all
and i thank
everyone who has been instrumental in
providing and guiding me with the
scientific knowledge i thank my
department for supporting me and my
collaborators
and
i hope uh you guys had a um had a good
time
this was a very nice conference that i
really enjoyed
everything uh about it
so i hope
you you had also some
uh you know
curiosity driven
questions so feel free to ask and i'm
happy to take more questions
thank you so much for the presentation
it was very
uh chris and shot in giving an overall
view about how these different types of
uh techniques are important and what
bioinformatics
role is in all of these studies
we have a question by just speed call
she's asking what is the first step to
begin with by learning biomathematics
and data mining what basic skills are
needed to start with and please mention
accessible sources
so i would say that uh
my field my growth has been i started as
a as a biologist and then i you know
went on to computer science
uh i always see that
it's important to
pick up you know soft skills
so programming
and
and you know a bit of mathematics
the way the field is progressing you one
would need a bit of more understanding
mathematics i would always say to pick
up uh programming and mathematics or
statistics a bit more if you want to
venture in in the modern bioinformatics
uh and the biology is important but that
you can
learn
there are some resources i can share
it's uh if if i get an email there are
some very available free resources that
is there from swiss institute of
informatics i keep sharing some
resources on my linkedin profile as well
so you know
i would be happy to share them offline
[Music]
yeah thank you so much sir and the next
question is what are the applications in
digital health and how are they being
employed in the process of drug
discovery what are your thoughts about
it yes that's a great question i didn't
touch much on the digital health but
what i'm trying to portray is when we
consider digital health the digital
health can be you know variables
measurements from the variables but
pressures right and these can be done
from your smart watches
and and these are often your snapshot
and they are these days taken also into
account when you're talking to your
doctors
now how it will be used in a day-to-day
it's still an open research problem fda
has not yet approved everything
we don't know how it is going to be
improved but having a blood pressure you
know ecg from your wearables uh that
that's already a great data point for
you to improve your lifestyle so you can
always improve your lifestyle on that
front in bioinformatics it's still very
early
but but there are some trials going on
so we will learn more about it uh in in
future at this moment i would just say
that
in in
in you know measuring blood pressure
it's it's it is it is some observational
way of doing it so yeah that's that's
the way i would see it
our next question is uh
can you break on the translational
potential of single cell omics and how
categorizing the heterogeneity of cells
will help in targeting the tumor as a
whole
well that's a that's a great question um
so when we talk about trials uh it has
to be so single cell as a diagnostic is
is still very early there are some
trials going on but what we are doing is
we are trying to understand
can single cell help us to
understand the mechanism of action of
certain drugs so their single cell is
used uh quite being used right now uh
where we're trying to understand
uh the role of uh
different
you know similar blue types and all
those things mostly in the chronic
setting
what what what cell picks up because the
effects are pretty low right that's
where the single cell is actually
helping a lot now cell type problem is
actually cell type heterogeneous in
terms of tumor
is is is a is a
very interesting problem because you
know it's an uncontrolled growth of the
proliferation of stuff i think there are
some very interesting paper that came up
recently in in drug tolerance i think we
should check on that i don't recently
don't remember the name of the author
right now but there what they they're
trying to say is your single cell is
actually trying to tell you when you're
giving uh in tumor patients particular
solid tumor uh a particular drug
how the drug is responding and what
cells are responding and what cell are
not responding i think this is one of
the fascinating thing to understand
whether the drug is actually
being treated by very some small small
cells that are responding to it and they
are actually reversing the disease so
this is how uh these things can help but
this these are still very open research
scope problems they're not only solved
because as i said the data is very very
complex and you know highly abundant so
it's it's not it's not something that
it's already solved we are still trying
to tackle these kind of massive problems
as an open research problem but there
are you know lips and bounds of work
that are already going on
right so
i
hope
the ones asking the questions your
questions are clear
and also we'll be able to share with you
some of the
resources that you can go through to
learn more about single cell and as the
question was put up like how you can
characterize the heterogeneity of cells
uh tolerating the tumor as a whole so
we'll be able to answer that as well and
more greater detail
and thank you once again dr vivek for
your talk it was an amazing talk and
it was nice to have you with us
now we would like to
thank you
now we would like to proceed ahead with
the next talk
by miss anka maria she'll be talking
about uh collaborate to innovate about
lab of the future and women and stuff
to introduce anchor she has more than 10
years of international management
experience
creating and leading
in cross-functional team working with
large corporates and smes she has led
the introduction of new products and
services across 114 markets in her
current role as a consultant at the
pastra alliance she is a strategic theme
lead for improving the efficiency and
effectiveness of rnd her role includes
leading communities of interest in life
science and healthcare r d for more than
one three member companies including the
pistol alliance lab of the future
community she also leads the pistol
alliance's new women's assembly
leadership pilot program and is
responsible for developing other good
non-competitive cross-industry
initiatives where members of the vista
alliance can collaborate to solve common
challenges together
so pleased to have you with us mrs anka
are you here
i
can't can you hear me
yes yes i can hear you
thank you very much for the introduction
thank you very much also for the
invitation could you see my screen can
you see my screen yes
we can see our screen
so um
again thank you for the invitation i'm
really happy here
my name is anka and before i start this
presentation
uh i would really want to tell you some
some things about me about my
educational background and career
background
i studied biotechnical engineering i
have a master's degree in the medical
engineering from the polytechnic
university
of bucharest and an mba degree from the
vu executive academy in vienna
i must confess that
although the university helped me a lot
in forming my mindset and in developing
the logical approach when it comes to
solving different problems
i never worked in the area i thought
that i'm preparing for as an engineer
what i did after graduation i actively
searched to join a multinational company
from the pharma industry because i had
the desire of
having a job that for me was meaningful
in terms of helping the people in need
but in the in the same time i had the
dream of of uh
becoming the type of the
business person that travels from places
to places and meets different people and
cultures so i wanted this international
exposure and i really wanted to meet and
work with with people from different
cultures
so uh i climbed in my career uh from a
project management and marketing uh
starting with romania
then i moved to responsibilities on
central eastern europe and then i went
at the european level uh
responsibility in in
less than seven years within the same
company
then i moved to a small medium
enterprise for a number another number
of years
where i got global responsibilities and
where i built the project management
department and then i became an
independent consultant
i joined the pistol alliance as a
strategic finlet as he presented earlier
and in my current role i see myself as a
connector
i connect people i connect their ideas
for
more than 200 member companies of the
pistol alliance all across the and the
ecosystem
i facilitate collaborations between
these companies in order to address and
to solve common challenges in a
non-competitive way
in this session i'm going to present two
of the currently running initiatives one
is called the lab of the future which is
a community of interest
and the other one is the women in stem
which is a program that we are currently
piloting
do you see my next slide
yes we can see that you see the next
slide okay thank you very much
so uh uh before going into the
presentation i'd like to tell you a few
words about the pistol alliance for
those of you that maybe didn't have the
chance to work with this organization
it's a not-for-profit organization
uh it gathers under its umbrella more
than uh 200 member companies including
the 16 out of the 20 pharma companies
uh top 20 pharma companies and
the mission is to lower the barriers to
innovation in life science
and in health care and r d through
pre-competitive collaboration
this means that we bring at the same
table different companies that might be
competitors in the business environment
but we facilitated collaboration between
them for a common purpose
the covet 19 changed our lives in many
many ways including in the way we work
more companies became more permissive to
remote working
and across industry collaborations also
increased we saw high acceleration of
digital transformations across the
healthcare industry
and the benefits of this
industry-wise collaborations are very
well known and
more and more organizations we see that
are leveraging a legal framework that
not-for-profit organizations can
facilitate in order to collaborate with
different organizations
research-based organizations maybe
digital technology players also page
patient groups for example
uh both of the examples that i'm going
to show you are global initiatives which
means that we involve people around the
world to support each other to share and
to learn and to address certain
challenges but also to look for
solutions together in the benefit of the
whole industry
and
when you will go on the pistol alliance
website you can see a list of projects
and the list of communities of interest
and i highlighted just some of them on
the right side of the screen
uh among all these initiatives we also
have the lab of the future community
which has a mission of driving a
pre-competitive approach to building the
next generation of laboratory
environment and we are looking from a
perspective of data standards processes
instruments and knowledge sharing
and the members of this community are
presenting use cases are sharing the
challenges and best practices but they
are also exploring different ideas and
initiate projects that can help support
the lab transformation in the
digitization
pathways
now one of my roles here
is to further more develop this
community and the engagement between the
participants so we are looking at short
medium long term perspectives and we
organize dedicated workshops webinars
projects and community discussions
looking at the improvements that can be
done in supporting these lab
transformations
no matter how far an organization is in
this
process in the digital journey
so we gather the good mix of industry
experts from the pharma cross tech
supplies academia also and other types
of organizations with wide diversity of
of roles
that are working in the ecosystem of r d
labs on the right side you see a
highlight for from the second half of
the year
when we organized uh different webinars
um
almost half of the participants came
from pharma companies but we also had
other organizations joining and also
almost half of the participants
are having leadership roles which means
that they are decision makers and and
they can have an influence also within
the organization but also for the
industry-wise project that we want to
develop for example
now how how will the lab of the future
look like and what does it really mean
um
there are many general predictions uh
people are talking about having a smart
lab or an automated and fully remote ai
powered
lab
cloud labs working hand in hand with
scientists
scientists working completely remotely
without
being confined within the four walls of
a lab and so on
uh but there are different types of labs
and there isn't one path that can fit
all and it's very interesting to see how
these laboratories are evolving what is
their digitalization speed their
particular vision on how their future
will look like
and
even though there are some differences
we can all agree that there are a lot of
common mechanisms
interfaces
terminology technology and so on and
they do have some similar milestones and
objectives that they want to achieve
in this transformational journey
let me show you
uh one of the common visions for all
type of labs is that they will make use
of the automation and digitalization so
the digital infrastructure needs to take
into account the large volume and
variety of data that is being produced
some later on challenges can be avoided
if the organizations have data
centricity in mind when implementing the
new systems and workflows and
automations
and one of the general challenges that
all
labs are facing
is how to capture this large amount of
data that is being produced
including the contextual data
in a fair format which means to be
findable to be accessible to be
interoperable and reusable
and how to redesign the current
paper-based workflow in case the
organization is still recording the
experiments let's say on on paper and
not on some electronic system
in order to fit the purpose right
how to extract the data from obsolete
device
as an example of industry initiative to
enable a fair aligned and comprehensive
semantic capture and translation of data
is the seed project that you can see on
the right side of the screen
seed comes from semantic enrichment of
eln data and eln is the electronic lab
notebook
um
this project developed a new standard
essay ontology in the phase one and now
aims at filling important ontology gaps
uh of interest for elns that are not
currently covered in the well-formed
public ontologies
another challenge related with the
digitalization is how to standardize the
practices across the industry in a way
that the data can be properly captured
and to be able to automate
somebody
something sorry you need to describe the
process
and there is a huge gap in the data
standards in the automation area and in
q3 in quarter free last year we asked
the community to highlight some of their
biggest barriers in the digitalization
process and we identified as top two
barriers
the fact that
the equipment is unable to communicate
with one another
and that there are no common data
formats so the participants proposed as
next step to create some sessions uh on
the different industry standards and
their practical uh
applications
and this is what we did we created the
series of webinars where we discussed
about the adoption of open standards and
why multiple standards are necessary
conditions for digitalization
uh we then saw the need of mapping all
the process communication and data
standards that are being used by the lab
of the future community
in an easy to understand format
so now what you see on the right side
the standards mapping across the r d
value chain this is a current initiative
and we are gathering ideas on how this
mapping should look like
it can either be an infographic type or
it can be a decisional tree that will
help the user to figure out which
standard is relevant for their work and
for their lab environment
now some standards exist and we can do
the mapping of all of them but others
need to be created where there are gaps
and this can be done in two ways
one way is from bottom up
this
for example coming from the research
need of the organization to have some
communication or process or data
standards to fit the purpose or it can
be developed from top down which means
from the compliance from the regulatory
side
and as an example of an industry-wise
initiative developed by the
alliance and its members we have the
help notation which is the hierarchical
editing language for macromolecules
which is a system of standardized naming
for complex biomolecules
it's widely adopted it's used for
representing therapeutic large molecule
in the bioregistration systems and helm
is now an fda recognized submission
format which also received an award of
best practice from the bioid world
here is another example of initiative
that can help standardize the data
across the industry this is called the
idmp ontology project the idmp comes
from identification of medicinal
products and the terminology is being
used in different domains as you can see
on the columns that are marked in blue
in the development in the production in
regulation authorization and so on
the project is aiming at creating the
ontology that will line top down the
idmp iso standards to the in-house
standards of the organizations to reduce
the current implementation
inconsistencies at the organization
level and in this way it can save time
and costs
on the right side you can see another
example of a regulatory initiative which
is called in vitro pharmacology project
where the fda
invited the pistol alliance to help
develop the data standards for in vitro
pharmacology bio assay
the project just started and the aim is
to accelerate the submission process
by defining the ontologies that will
enable better data reuse interpretation
and understanding
and all these examples and top-down
standards that are being developed will
be seen at the laboratory level in a
period of time but from a process
perspective these top-down standards are
very efficient because because they
created a need of everybody to accept
the same ontologies and data standards
now the pistol alliance
has
also other communities of interest that
are connected to the lab of the future
and we create also collaborations and
partnership between these communities
on the left side you can see the data
governance community this is managed by
my colleague john rice
in the middle you see the aiml community
of interest
this is managed by my colleague vladimir
makarov and on the right side you see an
ad another example of community which is
the uex community managed by my
colleague paola de matos
so if we take one by one with the data
guide finance community we created the
series of standards webinars data
governance is essential to enable
digital transformation and to advance
innovation and this growing community
already has more than 30 companies that
bring together
opinion leaders to identify best
practices common obstacles and some
potential solutions that we can all work
together
the ai community of interest is aiming
at discovering and promoting the best
ways to use these
new promising technologies
to apply them to solve the current
challenges and to educate
the companies through presentations and
discussions
and when implementing tools and software
ai ml an important aspect is to consider
the change management and particularly
the user adoption
so the dedicated user experience
community which is formed by
practitioners from the pharmaceutical
health care and software industries
is delivering frameworks and guides and
toolkits to enable the businesses to
adopt
ux principles and methods and their most
recent initiative is to create concepts
and ideas that will help the lab of the
future community
last few years we saw rapid growth in
terms of the number of new
pre-competitive collaborations between
the pharma companies and ai providers
and software providers
and in general the the organizations
from the r d equal system
and in 2022 digital transformation
continues to accelerate
and the pharmaceutical industry is
seeing the benefits of non-competitive
collaborations and at the beginning
when the companies are learning how to
assess their organization and the
potential for digital transformations
we do encourage them to join different
non-competitive platforms and groups to
learn from the experience of the other
companies and same for the organizations
that are
the digital journey because it's useful
to contribute into and to help each
other by sharing the use cases and best
practices and lessons learned and in
this way the organizations together can
share both the risks and the benefits of
the deliverables
now if you are not part of an
organization yet
if you are a student or an early
graduate i do encourage you to join the
communities of interest
most of the discussions are open you can
join without any registration cost and
you can be more in contact with what is
happening in the in the industry
i would say a recommendation to
stay informed to subscribe to different
newsletters about your area of interest
to join different webinars and
discussions
and very important to be proactive uh so
for example if you see a challenge uh
discuss it with others maybe look for
some solutions and if you see a
challenge and a solution
you can join different working groups
you can reach out to different
not-for-profit organizations that have
the means and the contacts uh to
validate the concept and to bring the
right stakeholders at the table
i want to show you how at the pistoia
alliance we create new projects we are
constantly developing uh new projects uh
and the process starts with the ideation
phase
uh where the pre-competitive project
idea is being raised the idea can come
from anybody
then the idea is being validated with
the community in terms of the benefits
and the interest
and once there is a buy-in for that
particular idea
it then starts to take a shape into a
project that has a clear problem
statement and the industry benefit
the outcome can be a member-funded
project or a program it can be a new
formed community of experts
and
this is the exact same path
that
we went on for creating the woman in
stem pilot program that i'm about to
present you
so firstly why is the women in stem
topic important for so many
organizations
you might not see
gender imbalance at the university or in
your early career levels
but the gender imbalance in the top
executive roles is a well-documented
case unfortunately so student so studies
showed
that women are more likely to leave the
stem career pipeline than men
leading to a wider gap
at a senior level
so women account for only three percent
of the ceos in this field and this is
why the pistol alliance has chosen to
focus this pilot's scheme on the
leadership roles because we believe that
um we believe in the top-down uh
changes and in creating more role models
for the future generations
and this was the process
we started in april last year at the
pistol alliance conference where we had
the women in stem panel with some very
interesting discussions that continued
even after the end of the conference
and by the way some of the most
interesting discussions happened before
and after the presentations so if you're
a student or an early graduate at the
conference
don't limit uh to
to the presentations to listening to the
presentations try to network and join
the conversations that happen during the
breaks
or in the organized networking events
and the poster sessions and and so on
you can get a lot of valuable
information from there
and connect with the right people
so um
going back to
how we started this program uh in april
last year we received the feedback from
the participants that really made us
think um
of the different programs that we can
initiate to help the woman who the women
who want to start uh all grow into their
stem career
so in quarter three we gathered more
interested parties and we asked the
participants what do they think are the
biggest barriers for women in stem
and the lack of child care maternity
policies
depending on
also the locations but also the absence
of female role models were mentioned as
the barriers
but by far the greatest thing to be the
workplace culture
and we didn't go into more depth at that
time
but we knew that the workplace culture
is highly influenced by the leadership
and the strategic organizational
directions and the management
so what was also interesting
in q3 was the feedback that came from
one of the only two men
who joined the court uh he experienced
for the first time the feeling of being
in the minority
uh and this feedback confirmed that in
the women in stem program all genders
need to be involved we agreed that any
diversity effort needs to incorporate
the intersectionality which is the
acknowledgement that everyone has their
own unique experience when it comes to
discrimination and that gender can make
people feel marginalized and that is why
we wanted to make sure that everybody is
well represented and that men are
included in all aspects of the program
in q4 we started the different
ideas on how the program should look
like and the most appealing
idea to our members
was the one to create a cross-company
training and networking program which is
what we are piloting now with top
managers from the pharma companies
uh the current pilot program uh brings
together 40 participants from 12
countries from three continents for a
period of six months
we started in january we will finish in
june this year we currently have 17
companies involved in this pilot stage
and each group of 10 participants
includes
two men as minority
uh the group meetings are held weekly we
have accredited trainer and coach and we
also have monthly networking sessions
uh each group includes diversity in
terms of the gender race location role
function
almost half of the participants are from
the us the other half is mostly from
europe and china and the prestiai
alliance brought together
leaders with different areas of
expertise because we wanted to see
different perspectives
and these are limited but not included
are including but not limited to the
drugs research development data science
industrial relations drug safety and so
on
and just to tell you that these women in
stem pilot program it's a first step in
a wider diversity and inclusion in stem
leadership initiative and we are aiming
to run a series of future programs as of
september this year
uh using the feedback and the learnings
from this pilot program um
we would like to form a community of
leaders who share the same values and
that want to contribute to the change in
the overall industry either by directly
changing or by promoting uh quality in
their organizations
uh if you want to find out more about
the pistol alliance and how you can get
engaged please do reach out to us on the
website and again for students and early
graduates uh join the industry
discussions
stay informed ask questions and be
proactive
reach out to us
thank you very much
thank you so much
for such a wonderful presentation i have
a question how do competing big pharma
companies collaborate in the pastoral
alliance projects
well we facilitate a non-competitive
environment so for example we bring
together uh
projects or ideas or solutions that if
the companies are working together
there's a benefit for the whole industry
there is no competitive advantage right
so that's why we can bring different
companies that even if for example in
the in the day-to-day business
environment they are in competition
we bring them together with projects and
initiatives that all of them can benefit
because imagine that if for example a
company has a big challenge
uh one thing is to try to solve the
challenge by its own
which means investing resources and
resources can be hiring a lot of people
to try to solve that issue uh
spending the money the time and so on or
they can share the risk right and the
resources with other companies that are
facing similar challenges and try to
solve them uh together
okay we got it
yeah thank you for answering the
question and the next question is
what is the challenge that big pharma is
trying to solve with bioinformatics
well i think it's also related with the
with the data standards and and actually
when it comes to challenges from the
industry we always ask the participants
and um
we want to understand what is the
challenge and what we can do for that
challenge right
thank you and do we have any more
questions
okay we have one more question what are
some of the challenges faced in the
current role as a strategic theme lead
and how do you handle those challenges
well the challenges that i see are
mostly related with uh ensuring that we
have all the right stakeholders at the
table so for example
if somebody comes to me with an idea or
a challenge and says look i need more
people that
would be willing to work
together on solving this issue right for
me one of the challenges is okay uh i do
have a lot of contacts who is the best
person to come and work on this
particular project all validating that a
challenge that one company is facing
it's actually a challenge that more
companies are facing because many times
it happens that the company comes with a
challenge
that is not very sure if other companies
are facing similar one so then this this
comes the validation process that i'm
doing going and talking with different
companies seeing if that challenge is
similar and if we have an idea on a
solution that we can work
together to solve it
okay
okay
and uh our last question
uh mohammed is asking how can we join
women in stem program
so currently the women in stem is for
the
people that are in the top executive
roles in the pharma because the way we
started this program we saw that at the
entry level so it depends on where you
are right if if you are at the entry
level in a career there are
similar programs for entry level right
um what we saw we saw the need of doing
the same in the top executive to make
sure that the people that join at the
entry level
can have the
same chances to advance in the career
right so our program is targeted at
leadership roles and you can join by by
uh going on the website of the pistol
alliance and you will see there under
the project the program and you can
register either to join either to be
informed or with the newsletter
information
okay perfect i hope mohammed you have
your answer and you can join yeah thank
you so much
now let's move ahead with
our next talk
so next talk is quite interesting as
it's a
special panel of researchers
so i'll just quickly introduce our panel
of researchers we have thus dr julia
panna
and she'll be talking about analysis of
single cell transceptor data that
enables detailed understanding of
multicellular tissue in health and
disease and then we have with us mr
avitavsky he'll be talking about
about container containerized pipeline
as a stable and secure solution to
bioinformatics analysis tools and dr
elizabeth will be talking about analysis
of 16s rrna metagenomics data and
especially resolved transceptromics and
last but not the least doctor wadim will
be highlighting manifold learning divine
perceptions and applications for the
analysis of biological processes
so we have uh the recordings by mr
abigail and dr vader
i will actually give them action
thank you
okay and uh
and everyone else who's going to
participate and can start your video
so um
i think we heard
a very nice uh overview yesterday about
different areas of bioinformatics that
are very important to many people
we heard about the microbiome and we
also heard about how important it is not
only to
have the data
but to analyze it and be interested in
it and so what are some of the questions
that people are asking from such data
sets
in today's sessions we heard also about
the single cell
transcriptomics and other types of
single cell technologies and we heard
about how rapidly this whole field is
developing uh what are some of the
challenges with such big data so this
session uh that will be
handled by the presenters from the tower
bioinformatics research center i think
kind of addresses a lot of these
questions so
one of the questions that you might have
is as a new user who's new to
bioinformatics who's new to a lot of
these methods how do i use them with
understanding and how can i still apply
them even though i might not know a lot
of the settings that need to be adjusted
we'll also hear about how
integration of multiomics data in a
sense spatial single cell
technologies
um can be used in a in a simple
interface and how important they are in
for the future of some of these
technologies that we've been discussing
so far
and i think an important part of this as
well and we kind of started talking
about this last uh
in our previous day
how can you once you understand the
pipeline and once you understand what it
does how can you deploy it in an
effective way so there are a lot of
technical challenges around
pipelines how to
resolve technical issues how to set up
the environment how to make sure that
you have everything installed and so the
last presentation will also address how
you can containerize
and deploy these pipelines and then
provide an interactive interface for
someone to explore the data in a in an
effective way
so with this brief introduction i'll
pass it on to dr julia panoff she's the
associate director of the tauber
bioinformatics research center uh and
she's in charge of uh kind of the vision
behind the platform that is being
developed there the tbi info platform
that we use extensively in all of our
training it's over to you
um thank you very much for the
introduction and um uh we are really
really excited to be here and thank you
for the invitation uh this is a great
opportunity for us to show our work
which is mostly behind the scenes
so um let me maybe uh share my screen
sorry
great
so uh we are uh we at tauber
bioinformatics research center are a
team of uh biologists bioinformaticians
uh mathematicians and computer
scientists
and and we uh developed this t-bio for
platform where we implement open source
and sometimes our own
[Music]
sometimes our own algorithms
and today we want to share with you uh
some of these
new sections that we have been working
on
uh and
so
the new sections that we will be uh
talking about
are
manifold utilities section and i will uh
go over some of the manifold learning uh
techniques
and what we can learn from them
uh and then uh vadim who is our software
engineer
will walk you through the pipeline that
we have been uh implementing for the
last uh uh
for the last couple of months actually
uh then we will move to uh actually
we decided in the last minute uh to skip
the single cell rna-seq and i hope that
you will have the video uh
next time
uh but we will uh
jump right to spatial single cell
analysis it's a new um
technology that allows us to
uh
to measure the gene expression and at
the same time know where the cells that
are expressing um gene profiles are
located in the tissue
and then we will kind of
move gears and we will
speak about metagenomics
analysis
uh lisa teranko who is our
bioinformatician will speak about both
the spatial single cell analysis and the
metagenomics analysis
and finally avi
who is our software engineer he will
talk about
the importance of
containers
in bioinformatics
so
let me start with
data actually
and before we begin
speaking about the manifold learning
itself
we can talk about biological data in
general
and so before
biological data sets were quite small
and you could uh use simple statistics
to investigate the data sets but today
these days are probably almost gone and
we are living in a data-centric biology
days
so our technologies allow us to collect
huge amount of data about biological
phenomena
for example we can study the behavior of
animal groups uh relying on uh
new tracking technologies such as
biologers remote sensing
uh also for example in the field of
behavioral studies we have new
technologies such as fmri which allow
researchers to quantify the behavior of
neurons and their interactions across
time
other examples of current biological
data sets include biopsy images
and transcriptics transcriptomic studies
on the level of individual cells
and
another example could be dna sequencing
which allows to trace the virus
population dynamics
and other huge
data sets in biology and in medicine
so
manifold is a
topological space
that is uh locally so near each point uh
resembles uh euclidean space that we are
all familiar with
so if we think about uh manifold
learning very intuitively what we're
trying to do is we're trying to unfold
the manifold
and position all points of this manifold
on a low dimensional usually
two-dimensional space
so that the distance between nearby
points is somehow preserved
and this procedure of unfolding the
manifold helps us understand the
patterns
uh in the original data set
and the actually the aim of this
exercise is to uncover some hidden
variables that can successfully expose
the underlying structure of the data
and most frequently these patterns are
either discrete clusters
groups or continuous gradients or
trajectories
so all manifold learning techniques use
three basic steps
first we are trying to find neighbors
nodes objects in our original space
highly dimensional space
that are somehow close or similar to
each other
next we would like to measure
distance between the neighboring points
and this measure of distance can be uh
measured in a different way so for
example we can measure euclidean
distance
um or we can measure uh
geodesic distance or we can use some
other uh distance measures such as time
in a random walk and there are others so
different algorithms uh in manifold
learning actually use different distance
measures and that's how they are
different
and uh finally uh using a partial
eigenvalues decomposition
we will try to
put this
highly dimensional data
graph into low dimensional space where
steps one and two are preserved
so there are several popular approaches
for embedding the original data points
into euclidean space of low dimensions
usually two dimensions
and for determining the underlying
patterns in the data and probably you're
all familiar with
principal component analysis
which is a linear dimensionality
reduction technique and it preserves the
euclidean distance between the points
in the original space
uh the next uh
[Applause]
highly usable a useful
dimensionality reduction technique is
called isomap
and it seeks such mapping on the low
dimensions that the geodesic distance
now is preserved the global geodesic
distance of the manifold is preserved
next would be a locally linear embedding
sorry and uh this local linear embedding
sticks the lower dimensional projection
of the data which preserves distances
within local neighborhoods
so it can be thought of as a series of
local principal component analysis
which are then uh
globally uh compared
uh the next one would be eigen map or
spectral uh embedding and it attempts to
preserve the local geometry by using the
placing operator
so in other words calculating the change
in gradient or the curvature across the
manifold
another
approach is called diffusion maps and
this approach uses a very different
way of measuring distance
it uses probabilistic measure of
distance uh the time it takes the random
walk
algorithm to find the
to go through the neighborhood graph
and finally we will talk a little bit
about the umap uh which is short for
uniform manifold approximation and
projection and this algorithm uses
entropy as a measure of distance
so we will show all of these
approaches
using
three examples some examples are
synthetic and other are biological
sometimes very simple and sometimes a
little bit uh more sophisticated so the
first uh data set that we are going to
talk about is a famous iris
data set which actually consists of 150
iris flowers which belong to three
different species
uh setoza versicolor and virginica
and
each flower in this data set is
described by four measurements sample
length sample width pedal length and
pedal width
so for example if we plot this data set
using two out of the four original
dimensions or we call them sometimes
features
without using any dimensionality
reduction techniques we will see that
one of the groups sentosa is always
separated from the other two groups so
here on the graph you can see that i
put the groups
on the two dimensions sepal length and
sepal width and the blue group is
separated and the other two groups are
mixed together but this is only in tuta
in two features what would happen if we
are trying to
conserve all four features of the
original data set well the first uh
thing we could do is just try to do the
pca and pca captures all features of the
original data set
but it reduces the dimensions from four
original dimensions to two
and it preserves the euclidean distance
between the objects so between my dots
and we see here that the toes of flower
is separated the blue group is separated
from the other two groups
however the other two groups
are not separated and if we would color
them in a gray you would see that it's
almost impossible to separate these two
so uh even though pca works quite well
for the blue group of flowers let's see
what other algorithms can give us and
how we can try and understand the
relationship between
between the flowers between our data
based on the embeddings that we will see
so for example if we use diffusion map
we will see
which uses the measure of time as
distance
after the constructing of the graph a
random walk procedure is used to
determine the distance or the time
travel between nodes on the manifold
and this technique is actually very
sensitive to outliers
because they are far away from other
nodes on the graph and you sort of get
stuck there
and
and it takes a long time to move to the
next node
and this is actually exactly what we see
in the embedding uh the blue group which
was very separate from the other groups
uh converges to one point and is very
far away from the uh other ones but also
interestingly uh we see another small
group of outliers the orange outliers so
sometimes uh diffusion maps are very
good approach to find your outliers in
the uh in
in your original data set
what about other ones uh here you see
the embedding of the data when only two
groups of viruses the ones that weren't
able to separate on the pca are present
and we see that spectral or eigenmap
give us two trajectories
while umap
gives the data divides the data into two
clusters
and both of these algorithms actually
have a number of mixed up samples
here is the
in spectral and also a new map
so if we look at the uh
on the spectral uh on the part of the
data set that was very separated
we can actually study these trajectories
and how they depend on the x and y axis
using for example linear regression
and we would find that the blue
trajectory so the versicolor group
can be described by change across the x
and y axis and the dependence uh is and
there is a dependence
of the location of each dot to the sepal
length and petal width
and this means that the larger the sepal
length and the petal width the more to
the right and to the bottom the iris
flower actually is located on this graph
on the orange trajectory is dependent on
three features sample length sepal width
and petal length
and here the larger are all three
features the more to the right and to
the top
the flower is located on this graph
um
sorry i forgot to put my uh swiss roll
animation but swiss roll is this uh
figure which is actually located in the
three-dimensional space and you can uh
turn it around
uh
so
so just to uh
demonstrate this we wanted to
demonstrate this is a synthetic totally
synthetic actually example of the data
where the colors don't mean anything it
is just to demonstrate some properties
of the embedding
so what you see on the
right is the pca embedding of this
three-dimensional if you can imagine it
moving around
um
[Music]
here if you could imagine this moving
around like this
oh it's not working
yeah it is okay
so if you could imagine it uh
just moving around this would be
uh swiss roll
um
[Music]
so for example in the pca it makes a
projection on the two-dimensional space
and retains the euclidean distance
between the points
so for example if we look at the
blue points
and the pink points
on the pca we see them as positioned
very close to each other and the
euclidean distance so the distance in
space between these points actually was
preserved by the algorithms
by the pca algorithm
uh
however it did not preserve the geodesic
space between those points because we
would expect
actually if we were to unroll this role
at the swiss role we would expect the
pink points and the blue points to be
very far away from each other so pca is
not able uh to give us this structure of
the manifold
uh but if we look at the
isometh
and this is the iso map measures its
distance as did as a distance here is
exactly what we see we see that the blue
points and the pink points are very very
far away
uh what happens if we look at the same
embedding the same dataset embedding by
l or
local linear embedding
and see we here we see that the local
distances are preserved so that the
nodes close that were in close to each
other in the original data set are still
close to each other but the global
geodesic distance uh is not so well
preserved for example the dark blue and
the light blue nodes uh are closer in
the loe embedding than they are in the
isomap embedding
and now
another example biological example that
uh is more close to uh real life
would be uh the next example where uh
we have a data set of expression of 77
proteins in the brain of a wild-type
control and trisomy model mice
and if we uh just project uh this data
set on a two-dimensional space using pca
this data is actually well separated we
see that the expression of proteins in
the brains of control mice the blue dots
is different from the expression in
trisomy uh model mice and already this
results can be interesting and we can uh
explore which proteins are uh
are involved in the separation of the
samples but maybe we can find additional
patterns in this data by using
non-linear embedding techniques
for example
examining the isomap embedding which is
based on the geodesic distance and not
euclidean as is pca we will find two
trajectories or changes from one state
to the other to another
and if we investigate these trajectories
using for example again linear
regression
we will discover that there is a
dependence between the position of the
blue object
uh wild-type mice on the x-axis and the
expression of the protein called nr2a
so the higher the expression of this
protein and r2a the farther to the right
we see the sample in this embedding
nr2a protein is a subunit of nmda
receptor and is linked to neuronal
plasticity to learning and to mammary
formation so you can imagine these mice
furthers to the right having a lot of a
higher expression of this protein
if we will
investigate the changes across the
y-axis
we will find that they are dependent on
the expression of another protein of a
phosphorylated pkcg protein
and this protein kinase is expressed
solely in the brain and the spinal cord
localized to the neurons and it has been
demonstrated that this protein is
involved in important neuronal functions
such as long-term potentiation long-term
depression
so and it is also linked to
neurodevelopmental and neurological
disorders such as autism and
schizophrenia so the higher the
expression of this phosphorylated
protein the more to the
the higher is the
sample
of our
mice
so isomap gave us an additional way to
look at the data even though pca
separated the samples here we find a
very different uh
trajectory and how they are related to
the original proteins
uh another embedding could be done with
spectral embedding and it also gave
trajectories that could also be explored
what on which proteins are they
dependent
uh if we would look at the diffusion
maps it is it gives us um another
interesting pattern um namely that the
control samples are all clustered
together so they are very similar to
each other
uh and the truth
model is actually uh some kind of a
gradient a trajectory so it changes uh
across the y-axis and we can also again
study this trajectory and what it
depends on
so if we look at umap
it is very different and unlike the
other methods that we have been uh
looking at
um umap uh which is based on the notion
of entropy tries to make round clusters
and separate these clusters as much as
possible from each other
so again we see that the control mice
and the trisomy mice are very separately
from each other but instead of giving us
trajectories
we see type clusters
so
the question here
with a manifold learning i think the
question shouldn't be which embedding is
best
but rather our question should be uh
which embedding or a combination of
embeddings is useful
for trying to elucidate hidden data
structures and dependencies
so by using many algorithms and trying
to look at our data from different
perspectives using different uh
embedding methods
we can discover different dependencies
and different structures of the data
so and now maybe vadim will show you how
to we implemented some of these
algorithms on the platform and how you
can use and play around with your own
data
vadim
maybe
or ilia
i'm not sure what's going on
maybe you can show us just uh
oh
my name is vadim and
i would like to demonstrate how to
visualize our complicated data easily
let's i show my screen
i'm glad to show you tower above buying
for the platform start page firstly we
need to go
to data integration and manifold
and modern
zone
when we choose the manifold utilities
section and now we
on the page
where we can process our data sets with
one of manifold learning approaches
which we talked about earlier
such as either map l e
spectral
umap
diffusion maps and other
here we can
select the
type of dataset it can be object
features table
or distance matrix for graph
which will be
used as precomputed graph for
manifold method
let's get
object features table
for mice expression dataset
and upload it to the platform
if you already know about
classes of our objects we can upload
table with this information tool
or if you don't know about it we can
skip this step
okay we are ready to choose
the
approach
manifold learning
let's start
try
umap
approach
and this page shows us a small
description of
method and it parameters
advanced users
can change
all of these parameters
each parameters
has each parameter has description
which we get
by hovering the mouse our eye icon near
parent
newbies in
manifold learning can be
can save default parameters and move to
the next step we press save button
now i am filling the name of our
pipeline
for example
test
nice
and
okay
now our simple pipeline is ready to
start
and let's run
we need to wait for a little time for
the pipeline to finish
while data processing we can look at
input data format
in this
data set
each row is expression values of
70 proteins
the classes
of
each object
written in the following format
column these
objects id
and classes
let's return to our pipeline
when pipeline
will be finished
the
email
will be sent
on
my
email
okay
ready let's click download output files
and
we can choose
a png picture of our data manifold
embedding visualization
or you can
choose with txt
file with the points coordinates
let's check a visualization
grid your map approach works
we can see dividing of samples into two
clusters
control samples and threesome samples
okay it is oh
[Music]
thank you very much you continue
thank you very much so now we will have
uh lisa
uh who will uh present to us the
um
who will present to us the
uh
the spatial transcriptomics
lisa
yeah hi everyone
can you see my screen
yes
okay great
[Music]
okay so yeah i'll be speaking about uh
georgia tool uh the tool that is used to
analyze spatially resolved
transcriptomics the
method that was uh
named the method of the year by nature
um
well
it was a great breakthrough when
a single cell was developed compared to
bug dna it allowed us to
specifically study separate cells
but when we
analyze data using single cell we end up
with something like this
just uh
cells in an artificial dimensions in
this case it's umap but we never really
know where exactly in our tissue the
cells are located
um and with spatial transcriptomics
finally we have this opportunity to map
the cells to our tissue like here this
example this is the
kidney
and this is normal kidney uh injured
kidney and
another
injured kidney and we can see that for
example our cortex
is comprised of a mixture of different
cells that are located here the
glomerular
or the collecting ducts
and our
other cells for example proximal tubular
cells this third segment is located here
it's pretty much all the outer medulla
is comprised only of this type of cell
but other than organs we also can look
at for example biofilm populations
um this is the clustering of different
functions that cells individual cells in
the colony
do and uh
using spatial transcriptomics it was
possible to map them to the specific
positions in the colony which allowed to
identify some hot spots for functions
for example here we can see that this
hot spot does the dendritic
denitrification here we can see it's hot
spot for high oxidative stress and so on
of course it's not the only application
of spatial transcriptomics it's used a
lot in medicine for example in studies
of cancer because tumor is very
heterogeneous and there are different
clones some parts are evolving faster
and of course we can see some
differences in expression
also it's very useful to identify the
invasive margin of the tumor and
actually how the cells this
cancer interact with normal cells
and it was possible to build a bunch of
um
expression atlases for healthy organs or
the ones in disease
also in molecular biology
it allowed to
localize the individual
molecules and of course study their
expression inside the cell for example
in cytosol or in nucleus
also help to understand better the
chromatin organization and cell
development
um so there are different experimental
platforms uh to study spatial single
cell
um we can separate them into microscopy
based methods like segfish awesome fish
or murfish all the hybridization based
methods
and sequencing based methods for example
division
the difference is that for microscopy
based methods since it's based on
hybridization we can we have a single
cell or even single molecule resolution
and thus we can identify their locations
if it's in cytosol or nucleus or
somewhere else
um
but we're restricted to only known genes
and we cannot
study any novel ones and we also
continue lies too many genes at the same
time because we are restricted in number
of colors or they can just basically
overlap and we won't see exactly where
this molecule is
sequence and base methods are easier and
cheaper and they don't
really need
a lot of pictures made on microscope to
study the locations
and we also can
study novel genes that we don't know the
sequence of
but it's not always a single cell
resolution and we will be focusing on
vision that is
exactly not single cell resolution
but basically how vision works we have a
plate
like this and the capture area that is
comprised of small spots
and each spot already has the barcodes
the spatial barcodes that will tell us
where exactly
um this position is located so we place
our tissue above the
the capture area and we treat it so the
mrna will ligate to our barcodes
and then we just proceed to sequence and
we get stick ones like this
so after sequencing we end up with our
metrics where we have gene counts per
cell and cell coordinates
and of course we can get some pictures
to work with as well
so um
with the data i just showed we can start
our pipeline and um
spatial transcriptomics actually very
similar at the beginning it's very
similar to single cell analysis it also
has the pre-processing steps the
dimension reduction
uh different clustering
algorithms and different algorithms for
cluster-specific marker gene
identification
cluster annotation
but um giotto also allows us to
check
to play with clusters to separate them
or to merge them based on their
similarity
and run enrichment
and this module the spatial analysis is
what is really different and interesting
for us
um it starts with a building spatial
network and then we can
find spatially variable genes that
have some spatial pattern
and study coexpression and cell night
neighborhood
so um i will focus only on this part
so um
we already did all the pre-processing
single cell analysis and ended up with
our artificial
dimensions in this case it's umap
and we color them with laden clustering
so in this case we have 11 clusters this
is kidney
sample
and what is different from single cell
at this moment is that we already can
map our cells on our tissue
and we see here that for example
clusters six and seven comprise the
inner medulla and classes two and nine
comprise the outer medulla and the rest
of the classes comprise the cortex and
it's really a mixture of cells
what we can
see here is for example we can plot how
many genes are expressed by which
part of our tissue and we see that
medulla is
expressing a lot more transcript than
the quarter text
so the first step in spiritual analysis
is to applaud a spatial grid or network
that will allow us to
um calculate the relationships between
these parts in case of grid this is uh
the expression will be summarized inside
the grid and for in case of network it
will
remain as a single cell or single spot
resolution
and this allows us to run um
spatial
spatial gene
search and i wanted to show you example
of two genes snaps and gpx3 which are
both
marker genes of proximal tubules
but you can see on these plots that they
actually have completely different um
spatial expression patterns right we can
see gpx3 expressed in the cortex and not
expressed in the medulla and napsa is
expressed in out permedulla
so um comparing it to already known um
cell types in the kidney we can see that
actually gpx3 is
a marker gene for proximal tubules but
segments one and two which are located
in the cortex and napsa is mark
correlating with proximal tubules the
segment three which is located here in
the outer medulla so spatial analysis
can help us understand marker genes
better
um also the next thing is spatial
coexpression um
so this actually allows us to identify
the metagenes a group of
genes that are
sharing same patterns of expression and
for example for this data set
this study said eight
metagenes were uh
were identified and here we can see
the uh correlation between these g eight
methyl genes and
here are um the expression
for the
genes on our tissue and you can see that
they all have
different patterns of expression some
are specific to inner medulla some are
specific to outer metallus some are
specific
well not quite because the here's a
mixture of cells really but they're
specific to the cortex and we can go
from the
metagen medical gene level to single
gene level if we want to
and one more
maybe the most interesting thing is how
the cells interact and in this case um
it shows how really
well the first step is to find the
interaction changed genes so the genes
that actually in uh change
when um their expression changes when
there is interaction with different
cells
and based on these genes we can find
cell types that are interacting within
this cluster or with other clusters
and we can say for example that clusters
four five eight one and three they all
are here
they aren't really um correlating even
to each other very well
and um
for example cla cluster 10 and 11 these
are small ones they're located here and
here
they have very strong
interaction inside the cluster and not
so much with other clusters well they
interact with each other as well
so um
a spatial single cell really gives us a
lot of opportunities to study
um pretty much anywhere we can apply
single cell we can try applying switch
to a single cell and it will give us
more information at where exactly this
function
is happening and
a lot of a lot of information about
expression
patterns spatial expression patterns
so um
that's it on the giotto um if you have
any questions i think you can type them
in the qa section if there is one here
and i will move on to
amplicon
right julian
yes thank you very much for this uh
introduction to the spatial uh
uh i think we do have uh i think we do
have a couple of questions if we can
answer them
okay yeah
yeah so
um the first question is how do you
select between various manifold methods
when analyzing complex data such as
spatial single cell
so i think
yeah
you want to answer
take that lisa sorry
you can take that
um no i mean um how i choose i just look
at the data i guess and see if it makes
sense or not
i would also suggest that you can use uh
there is no right uh embedding so it's
and i think it's an important uh issue
where
it's an important uh thing to remember
that you're not trying
each of those embeddings is going to be
somehow right and somehow wrong it will
preserve some of the
hidden structure of the data but it will
lose some other hidden structure so by
using many different methods you can
find uh different you know sometimes
it's trajectories that you're interested
in sometimes it's clusters that you're
interested in so uh so
we always uh try to recommend using as
many uh methods as you can to look at
the data from different sides so also
such complicated data as single cell or
spatial single cell
the umap is actually most uh if you look
at all the uh
the articles you will see that most of
the people use umap or tsne
but there are many many many more
uh embedding methods available and we
recommend to really look through at
least a few because some of them
um they're based on different things and
then
they also will uh reveal different
struck underlying structures of the data
so
i hope that helps
great thank you both
um another question will spatial single
cell rna-seq make uh rna single cell
rna-seq
obsolete without imaging data obsolete
um
can you please specify what obsolete is
i'm sorry
yeah so will
will single cell rna seek without
imaging um
become irrelevant with the introduction
of spatial single cell
well um i think that there are options
when
we don't really need spatial imaging or
we can't really capture it
so
well looking at the pipeline yeah it
looks like uh all the steps we do the
same as single cell so we can replace
all the single cell projects with
spatial single cell i think that's a
good idea but still i guess there are
options when we can't really use spatial
single cells so we can
continue working with only
just regular single cell
also if i could add to that uh
if you are using vision
then
as lisa has mentioned you are not
actually capturing each individual cell
you are capturing a small well that has
a few cells in it right nisa so probably
uh it
at least for now
uh
single cell is still the resolution of
the single cell
rna-seq is probably better than at least
this vision
and another important things for science
is a matter of resources
spatial single cell is a very expensive
technique
so
we cannot imagine that
all of our
studies will become all of a sudden
only single cell and only spatial single
cell it will be just too expensive
to do science this way so for a
well
identified project you know we hear
prices around 100 000
200 000
so not every lab
uh can actually afford this
actually one more thing uh julia
made a good point that uh vision is not
single cell resolution there are studies
when just regular single cell and
spatial single cell are combined
together so you get a spatial
information but at the same time you can
kind of get the single cell resolution
so yeah i think single cell will won't
go anywhere we'll use it
and if to add a little bit to that uh
you know a lot of people ask us if now
we have this technology that allows us
to do a single cell will bulk rna-seq be
absolute
and the answer is probably related
probably not
you know there are more and more
computational ways of combining single
cell data which is very sparse so you
have a lot of
genes that appear to be not expressed at
all but in reality they are expressed so
the data is very sparse and you combine
it with your bulk rna which is much more
stable but has this average cell that is
never actually exist um
and you do something like the
convolution and use other
computational techniques to try to
connect those two together
uh so i think it's the same kind of
question
great thank you so much
all right
now
uh sorry no uh i think now we will have
quine
and lisa i was going to show the
recorded presentation is that correct
no no no it's a different one maybe
yours is the next one
sorry
uh can you see the screen
yeah
okay yeah um i'll speak about our
platform section for chime
and chime is a tool that analyzes
metagenomics data this culture
independent microbial communities and
what we basically learn about them is
composition and function of
these communities
and it can be um applied in a bunch of
areas like agriculture where you can
study soil properties or any bacteria
driven processes in healthcare where we
can study microbiome
microbiomes of different organs
or ecology where
biosensors are developed using
metagenomics and biodegradation of
plastic is also bacteria during process
and of course biotechnology the
nutrition produced or pharmaceuticals or
biofuel everything is done thanks to
bacteria
so um
basically when we sample our data and we
extract dna um
and then we want to amplify it we can go
two ways we can either go a whole genome
sequencing way or target sequencing way
and in case we want only to sequence the
target
16s
ribosomal rna is
the region that mostly is targeted in
bacteria because it has both conserved
and hypervariable regions actually there
are nine just they didn't have a picture
good enough for the two included
but this higher variable regions help us
differentiate between
um different species
so
16 as
um or
target sequencing or amplicon sequencing
it's cheap compared to whole genome
sequencing it's pretty standard we
already know all the primers so it's
easier to conduct but it's restricted to
previously known um an annotated taxa
and sometimes it's not enough to
differentiate between the samples
also we only get the compositional
information we don't know any function
that are done here
whole genome sequencing allows us to
study novel organisms and we can
assemble the reads in
and we can run functional genomics and
understand what uh function this
organelles does
it's also more information on to
differentiate between the taxa but there
are a bunch of problems uh to whole
genome sequencing of bacterias
because it's expensive it's hard to
understand what is contamination what is
not
and so on
so on the platform we
present three modules uh pre-processing
that
consists of filtering and denoising
algorithms and we go on to taxonomy with
silver classification
filtering our classified sequences and
conducting philogenetic trees
then we can move on to metrics to
calculate for alpha and beta diversity
so
at the very beginning we start with the
quality control and it's very
important not to include
regions of low quality because they will
interfere with all the downstream
analysis with our abundances with our
philogenetic tree and taxonomy and
everything so you have to um
understand where you want to trim your
wrists like this so you will not include
low quality
nucleotides in your downstream analysis
so after filtering the replication we
come to denoising or clustering
techniques
so the idea is that when we first
assemble our data or we have
um one sec well sequence per species or
something like that but when we run
amplification there are bound to be some
errors and we get small fractions of
sequences that are slightly different
from our original one
and when we sequence there are even more
errors and more unique sequences and so
we end up with a plethora of
unique sequences and
classics
clustering algorithms would look for the
most abundant sequence and design it as
a center
and cluster everything
that is 97 similar in one cluster
um
well there are a few problems with this
approach the first is that not all the
species are 97 similar some are a lot
more similar
and um
researchers came up with another
approach to noisy
which was taking into account different
models of errors and sequence same
quality calls
to try and correct
the errors the mistakes and
end up with hellotypes but these
haplotypes
are 100 similar
so after denoising or clustering
for paired entries there is also option
to merge well not an option it's a
little step to merge the reads
um
[Music]
since
even for targeted sequencing we can pick
different
size different regions and the size of
region may
vary and sometimes the reads are
separated like this
sometimes they overlap and for example
data too treats them a bit differently
in case they overlap they only take the
part that overlaps and in case they
overhang it will take one of the reads
and if they are separated it will
concatenate the reads
together so
when we sampled our data extracted dna
amplified it and did the noising we end
up with a table like this where we have
counts of each unique representative
sequence
per sample
and here we can ask ourselves
three main questions uh first is how
similar different the things are in one
sample and that will be alpha diversity
um second question is how similar
difference are the samples between each
other that will be beta diversity
and the third is what specifically leads
to differences between the samples and
that will be a taxonomic profile and
we'll start with the third one
so for taxonomy analysis it is uh
strongly advised to use the same primers
that you used for yours
for your uh
data
so
the same region will be extracted from
the database um here we use silver
database that has been updated and
curated
um
and you can see the
mostly used primers here and primary
sequences so you just take the sequence
add it to the platform forward and
reverse
primers
and they will extract exact regions from
the database
and run classification so it will look
for
if the sequence
is in the
silva database and it will assign
taxonomic unit to the sequences
and you will end up with a bar plot
showing uh what bacteria
are there in your samples
if you want some of them removed you can
exclude them now just type the correct
name of the taxa or if maybe you want to
include just several samples so you can
do the same
and you can also group the samples based
on
some categorical columns in your
metadata for example i was interested in
body size to see if samples from god
were any different from palms and tongue
um so after taxonomy analysis uh we go
on to
philogenetic tree so this is um this
will show how similar our representative
sequences are
and it starts from multiple sequence
alignment and then um the there are a
few algorithms are available to build
the tree fast tree and iq tree
this is mainly used for core metrics but
you can also extract the tree and
visualize it and for example fig tree or
any other tool that helps visualize
photogenetic tree files
so after that
we have
looking at this table the artificial i
just came up with it to show um
looking at this table we see that
total counts for each samples are
different and
in case we can
compare sample four and sample one
they're pretty close in total counts
we can't really compare example three
with others right
so because they have different sampling
depth and we can't really run any
reliable statistics on something like
this so one of the ways out is to
subsample the frequencies um
so that the total count will be the same
for all the samples like here
so we subsample um all the table and
change the table
so that the total will be the same
and
this is
not ideal because we'll lose information
sometimes we even lose whole samples
if their uh sampling depth is lower than
uh what would peak
but this is a good way
to normalize your sample so the
statistics will be reliable
but how actually
should we pick the value um
for example how did i pick 100
we should be looking at our samples and
their sampling depth now for example
here
we can see that some samples have
sampling depths lower than 1000 some
have uh something that a bit less than
2000 some are here
but the majority are
having bigger sampling depth also we can
see that the number features are quite
stable starting from here so it looks
like this region
um looks appropriate to take the sound
and depth um
but if i it's also very meaningful to
look at your groups and if the samples
in your groups of interests are still
there for example if i take sampling
depth of 2000 my right palm sample group
will be almost will consist of only two
or three samples
but if it takes something that's one
thousand uh my right palm group will be
okay i can still work with it
excuse me uh i'm interrupt uh we're a
little bit running over time uh and i
know you still have a few slides uh
would you be able to maybe wrap it up in
a couple of minutes because we have some
other
on the schedule thank you
yeah so yeah the only thing that is left
is core metrics basically calculating
all the metrics for alpha and beta
diversity using the sampling depth that
we just um identified
and it will give us an idea so the alpha
diversity was give us an idea how things
are inside the sample
basically telling us how rich and even
our samples with different indices
shannon index filler index
and beta diversity um will give us
understanding how samples um
are between each other
um plotting pca based on different uh
distances like jakarta or
curtis and we also can run a perm anova
test
on a column that we are interested in in
this case it was bodyside and
i got really good p-value meaning that
this
group has very different beta diversity
statistics
that's it thank you very much for your
intention and uh yeah here i just is
mentioning some studies that were done
using amplicon and whole genome
sequencing of medical genomics
thank you
thank you very much for that
presentation that was great
so um in the interest of time i think uh
we are going to we have a recorded video
from um mr ave to devesky
and we are going to actually share that
on our youtube channel the link to that
video on our youtube channel
and move
forward
and the next speaker
is also going to be recording
um
so it is my pleasure to introduce dr
tony gia
dr gia obtained a bs degree with honors
from caltech in chemistry and business
economics and management and in 2010
and phd's from harvard chemistry in
202012 and 2016 respectively
since 2017 he has been a researcher at
the earth life science institute at the
tokyo institute of technology and in
2019 he became a specially appointed
assistant professor and lab manager at
elsi
an affiliated researcher at blue marble
space institute of sciences
his current research interests include
origins of life astrobiology and
primitive compartments
so here is dr gia's recording on the
origin and evolution of biopolymer and
non-biopolymer based compartments
good morning good afternoon and good
evening to everyone thank you for
joining the symposium and thank you for
joining today's talk um
unfortunately i'm really sorry but i
can't be there in person uh
unfortunately the way time zones work
it's not so great but i hope that uh
this video presentation will be
interesting and exciting to you and of
course at the very end i'm happy to take
questions uh i you know text by email by
chat or or any other way so today i'll
be talking about the origin and
evolution of biopolymer and
non-biopolymer based compartments
so first of all i'd like to start with a
little bit of a self-introduction so i
actually did my bachelor's degree at
caltech where i studied chemistry and
business economics and management and
part of my research involved studying
chloroplast protein expression
crystallography as well as using mass
spectrometry to study pulmonary
surfactant lipids
next i moved to harvard where i did my
phd and i studied mostly rna i studied
rna sequencing technologies specifically
used for non-coding rna quantification
and i also studied ways which rna
polymerize and replicate without using
enzymes so-called nonzen enzymatic rna
polymerization
because i had so much experience working
with all of these different biomolecules
lipids proteins nucleic acids i got
really interested in
how exactly those biomolecules emerged
and evolved in the first place and that
led me to my current position so since
2017 i've been a researcher at the earth
life science institute at tokyo tech
institute of technology and also since
2019 i've been an affiliated scientist
at blue marble space institute of
science
and since then uh at lc i've been
working on a variety of different topics
related to
origin of life and astrobiology but also
related to other interesting topics such
as dna liquid crystals or
continuing with some rna sequencing
technology work
so uh before i get into today's main
part of the talk i'm going to turn off
my camera in case
there's uh
you know if in case the the the portrait
interferes or blocks some of the content
so today i'd like to go through four
different you know minor topics so
in case you aren't familiar with uh what
exactly is astrobiology especially in
the eyes of a prebiotic chemist
i want to introduce and give maybe a
little bit of a review about primitive
cells and what they might look like and
then give two short case studies in
origins of life research featuring
different polymers one is from a
biopolymer
based background one is from a
non-biopolymer based background so
hopefully you can see the similarities
and differences of those sequences and
those systems that we study finally i
want to
introduce some opportunities for
students and researchers to participate
in astrobiology research both at lc my
current affiliation as well as outside
of lc
so
what what exactly is astrobiology i
think many people have different um you
know concepts of what exactly is
astrobiology for example uh if you take
a look at the word astrobiology you
would think that it's the intersection
of astronomy and life science
and basically it is uh astrobiology
takes
um you know concepts from astronomy
takes concepts from life science and
what astrobiology is encompasses many
different things so what what i think
and from a prebiotic chemist perspective
what i think astrobiology research
encompasses includes
for example the active search for life
in space this is you know searching for
current life or former life and often
this is through missions
for example in japan there's a hayabusa2
mission which went to get samples from
the asteroid called dugu it recently
returned to earth a couple years ago and
they're studying those
samples right now and in a few years
jaxa will be sending a mission to one of
the martian moons uh and study uh kind
of the structure of the martian moons
and bring that uh those samples back so
that's one aspect
another aspect is searching for
habitable planets in space so for
example searching for exoplanets probing
the habitability of extraterrestrial
bodies and this can be done for example
through space-based telescopes like the
james webb space telescope shown on the
left or through uh these radio
telescopes that are
on earth and this is alma on the right
next we also have the active search for
the origin of planets earth and life on
earth and so this includes the search
for organisms that live in extreme
environments which might provide a
window into what life was like back on
early earth as well as research on
planetary and geological formation and
this also involves studying you know
areas of the earth which might simulate
areas that one could find on other
planets
and these three last topics are
something i my research has a hand in so
the search for how to make synthetic
living systems in the lab how primitive
chemist chemicals assembled in the
primitive life and finally how this
primitive life evolved into modern life
so this is the the topics that i'm
personally researching it's part of this
you know subfield of astrobiology which
is origins of life field and it's a
really small part of the field but
extensive collaboration is really
essential in order to really understand
aspects of the origin of life and
especially collaboration with different
types of researchers and even
researchers or you know those with an
engineering background or people from
non-scientific backgrounds is really
essential
so
coming from kind of a biochemistry or or
a biology background i'm sure many of
you are really interested
in how the cell works what the structure
is and so you know this is a simplistic
cartoon of the cell but
essentially it's built up of many
complex
parts
and researchers have really
had a lot of success understanding
many of the structures and what they do
and what they um what what they're made
to do or maybe during diseases when they
have trouble
and we've learned a lot about the cell
in the last 20 30 50 years but there's
still many unanswered questions and one
of the big unanswered questions is
what did the first cells look like how
did these first cells function
and some researchers believe that
something like a more primitive type
cell existed on early earth some people
call this a protocell
and maybe this included some type of
compartment boundary some type of
replicating genetic system
house you know catalysts like enzymes or
primitive enzymes and then also could
participate in evolution growth and
division and so one way to think about
origins of life research is to we want
to understand how the chemicals on early
earth in the prebiotic stoop if you will
assembled into these primitive
compartments or protocells and how these
protocells function and eventually
evolved into modern cells and
specifically
if we think about this a non-biomolecule
or non-biopolymer-based
prebiotic soup
how could this eventually assemble and
evolve into a biomolecule or a
biopolymer based modern cell is a really
interesting and big question
and in order to do this one
way is to try to see or understand what
this primitive cell looked like what it
could do and we can approach this in two
ways going from the bottom up building a
primitive compartment
using these um
non-biomolecules available on earlier
through your biotic chemistry or we can
go from the top down taking what we know
about biology and kind of working
backwards to see
what you know minimal what minimized
functions or what minimized types of
cells could have existed so what i like
to say is kind of we want to build this
primitive compartment from both
directions
and so let's say going from uh top down
i think this is something that uh most
more more of you in this audience are
familiar with
um let's see how this primitive cell
would have looked like if we work
backwards from a modern cell and
forgive the simplicity of this cartoon
as well this is uh you know one of the
processes we see in the modern cell it's
as you know the central dogma and
these are composed of different
processes made up of biopolymers and
biomolecules and catalyzed by
biomolecules so what we want to know is
on early earth or in an early cell which
of these processes were still essential
so
for example it's very likely that
proteins did not exist on early earth
they're too large they're
they're folding is too difficult to have
achieved
and also it's very likely that our dna
couldn't have existed really on an early
earth so this leads many to postulate
that the first cells on early earth
contain rna
and this is specifically
leads to a
origin of life hypothesis which suggests
that rna is the first and most important
biomolecule of life
this hypothesis is called the rna world
hypothesis and it postulates that
because rna can store and pass down
genetic information
because it's similar in structure to dna
and also because rna can fold into
specific structures that can catalyze
chemical processes in the form of
ribozymes similar to proteins that rna
was the first and most important
biomolecule on early earth and while
there's been a lot of research
in this
field and a lot of progress has been
made
there's still a number of outstanding
questions
in the rna world for example how the rna
could be synthesized how it polymer
polymerizes how it's prevented from
hydrolyzing there's many questions that
researchers are answering to this day
and there are also hypotheses that rna
wasn't the only biomolecule that existed
on early earth for example
some researchers have postulated that
dna and rna could have coexisted on
early earth maybe in a hybrid form
and based on the structure of the
ribosome as we know it today it's also
been postulated that perhaps rna and
peptides co-evolved so instead of a
purely rna world you might have had
something like an rna peptide or an rna
protein world
and so what all this is just saying is
that we're not exactly sure exactly
what was in this early cell and it's
plausible that all of these or even more
types of molecules existed in or around
these cells so let's assume from now on
that we have access to a number of
different types of biomolecules for
building this primitive cell
the next thing i want to focus on is
this boundary so this boundary is really
important and defines a cell from other
cells specifically it makes the cell
defined as a compartment and
compartments are really essential to
origins of life
compartments segregate and con
concentrate reactants they promote
chemical reactions promote evolution
prevent fusion of genetic materials many
many different important functions on
early earth
and
you know modern cells they're made up
mostly of a phospholipid membrane that's
the boundary
it's been postulated that perhaps early
cells that are membrane bound were made
up of fatty acids rather than
phospholipids because they're much
easier to synthesize
using prebiotic chemistry and what's
available back in early earth due to
there being only one chain rather than
two
and so one further question is that
when you actually make a boundary that's
even simpler than fatty acids that that
doesn't even require that type of
bilayer and so what we're interested in
is seeing whether such types of
compartments could have existed and
whether they could form or function as
early cells or protocells
so
one way is through liquid liquid phase
separation for those who are familiar
with this um you might have heard about
this if you haven't it's actually one
way to form droplets
in solution these droplets are are
membraneless but they're still liquid
and they provide compartmentalization
without a membrane they allow exchange
of molecules between phases and in fact
they're present in modern biology so
there's a phenomenon called biological
phase separation
which results in formation of
membraneless organelles in the cell
these organelles you know there's some
some of them are called for example
nuage granules or stress granules maybe
chromatin is even considered one of
these and these are membraneless
organelles in the cell that are really
important for controlling biological
processes and it's been postulated that
because
you know most cells or almost all cells
have this
type of phase separation inside to make
these membraneless
um organelles that perhaps they're an
ancient invention and that phase
separation was also used to make
compartments on early earth
and so here let me move on to a couple
um
case studies of origins of life research
and let me start with a biopolymer case
so this is a case study on primitive
liquid crystal coaster rates so you
might have heard of liquid crystals
before they're present in
tvs or displays
and in fact you can actually make liquid
crystals out of dna so this is in
collaboration with
uh
tomaszo fraccia who's a researcher at
espci in paris
and so his previous research showed that
if you took short dna oligomers that
were self-complementary such as this
sequence shown here
they can actually form these duplexes at
aggregate end to end they stack together
and they form these long rods and these
rods will bundle together and after
drying after increasing the
concentration of the dna significantly
the structure that results is this
columnar liquid crystal structure uh
shown in this uh polarization microscope
microscopy image on the right
so these structures are you know
somewhat liquid they have liquid and
solid characteristics and you can
visualize them through polarization
microscopy because of their super
molecular chirality
so we postulated that
perhaps
it would be interesting if for example
a primitive compartment like one of
those phase separated systems could
actually house one of these liquid
crystal structures because they've shown
the ability to affect electrochemistry
or regio chemistry or reduce selectivity
so what we did was we knew that
you know when nucleic acids like dna
and when peptides
like cationic peptides uh are mixed and
bind together they actually form these
liquid liquid phase separated structures
so we took pll poly lysine um about 250
residues long polydisperse mixed it with
high concentrations of this dna ligamer
and we were able to find conditions in
which these
structures these nice membraneless
droplets or coastervates co-localized
with this dna crystal liquid crystal
structure shown on the bottom through
the polarization microscopy so we we
believe that this dna liquid crystal
structure is formed through this
end-to-end stacking interaction of dna
and we actually found that these
structures the co-localized structure of
the liquid crystal coast survey only
exists in a very narrow range of
salinity for example when we vary the
cylinder we found that at low
concentrations of sodium chloride
precipitation occurred whereas at higher
concentrations of sodium chloride only
droplets formed without liquid crystal
characteristics or no droplets could
form at all and we believe that this is
because
um the ionic strength of the solution is
really important for this interaction if
there's lower amounts of salt the
peptide dna binding interaction may be
too strong forming precipitation or
solid-like particles whereas
at higher salt concentrations it
makes these structures these
interactions between the peptide and the
dna weaker suggesting that you know when
when the peptide and dna can no longer
interact for example one molar sodium
chloride these droplets can't form as
well
we next wanted to hypothesize test our
hypothesis
uh as to whether this end-to-end
interaction is indeed what's forming
these crystals so we did the same
experiment but with a slightly different
dna sequence this time we included a 2t
base overhang so this stacking
process could not occur
and we found that through all of the
different conditions we tested
in no
single case did we find liquid crystal
structures we did find many
conditions where these droplets could
form these phase separated droplets
could form but liquid crystals could not
be observed and this shows that this
end-to-end stacking interaction is
really essential for these liquid
crystals to form
we then next wanted to study the um
what happens if we subjected these
liquid crystal coast surveys to
processes or environmental processes
that might have existed on earlier so
one of them is dehydration
it's been proposed that dehydration
could be one way to
you know effect
different chemical reactions on early
earth you'll see this in the second part
as well and so we subjected these
systems to drying and so what you see
here is that
throughout the drying process
you can see these structures go from
these solid-like structures
transitioning to these
liquid crystal coastal like structures
to just a simple coaster rate and then
to
a disassembled structure i'll play this
video again and we believe this is the
case because similar to the salinity
titration dehydrating the solution
actually up concentrates the sodium
chloride in the solution perhaps which
suggests that the this phase transition
follows a similar phase transition as
what we observe in the sodium chloride
titration case
next we started again and we wanted to
see the reaction of when we heated these
samples
so
we actually heated these samples up to
about 60 degrees and we can see a
transition from this solid like
structure to a liquid crystal coastal
rate structure
furthermore further heating resulted in
disassembly of these liquid crystal
structures
resulting only in these non-liquid
crystal coaster rates
and then upon decreasing the temperature
we noticed that at 40 degrees on the way
down these liquid crystal coaster rates
started to pop up again and we saw a few
different types of liquid crystal
cluster rates but also we saw that the
um
the population was also heterogeneous
some of them were still um you know
typical droplets without liquor crystal
characteristics some of them had liquid
crystals inside
and we found that upon decreasing at
uh further to about 10 degrees that
almost all of these droplets uh
reconstituted this
liquid crystal character if we compare
between these before and after heating
the structures are pretty different and
we think that this is because this
heating process is basically akin to an
annealing process and of course
annealing is used to
allow in in you know dna and rna case to
allow the strands to bind completely to
find the most stable thermodynamic
conformation and we believe that in this
case perhaps the right figure here is
um this is what the most stable
conformation is for this system
and so we believe that what's happening
is we have these liquid crystal
structures here um with increasing heat
and salinity uh you have these um you
know dna long dna rods and teal and
these uh red strands of peptides bound
together the rods the dna rods are in
this packed hexagonal pattern upon
increasing heat and salinity these rods
start to come together
come apart um
causing some structural change and then
the rods start to disassemble these into
um
you know d stack and so you lose this
liquid crystal characteristic but you
retain the droplets and then further
increasing heat and salinity results in
disassembly of everything and you result
in no droplets
so for those who are interested in
learning more details some of these
studies are published you can see
one here
and one here as well i'd highly
encourage you to take a look if you're
interested in the details
next i'd like to
talk about our other side non-biopolymer
side of orange of life research and here
we focus on membraneless polyester
droplets
so here we're building from the bottom
up and you see
we're interested in building this
primitive compartment from the available
chemicals on early earth and it's
actually known that there's many ways by
which biomolecules could have formed on
early earth through you know meteorites
or atmospheric discharge
but we also find that together with
biomolecules that there's also many
non-biomolecules synthesized at the same
time for example merchants in meteorite
has tons and tons of molecules inside
and if you analyze the miller reaction
or atmospheric discharge reaction
products you also get tons and tons of
different molecules not all of these are
biomolecules
this suggests that non-biomolecules were
just as or even more abundant than
biomolecules on earlier so we're
interested in understanding how
biomolecules could catalyze how
non-biomolecules could have catalyzed
life's emergence
the system we like to use are alpha
hydroxy acids they're monomers similar
in structure to
amino acids but with an amine group
that's replaced by hydroxyl group and
what's great about these is that through
simple drying
these monomers can form polyester
polymers shown on the bottom here
so we wanted to create these polymers
these polyesters and see if they could
you know assemble into something useful
for the origin of life so we first took
monomer solutions and dried them to form
polyesters and here's some mass spec
data and you can see that in all cases
the
monomers were able to polymerize into
polymers
let's zoom in again this is one of the
monomers lactic acid so you see that the
products are polydisperse they're not a
single product so you make many
different lengths of polyesters and so
you also form this gel-like structure so
this was observed in almost all cases
where all of the polymer gel structures
were formed through
by these polydisperse polyester products
so we took these gels and we dissolved
them in aqueous solution
and what we found was that droplets
could form they were turbid and we could
see these nice spherical droplets in
solution for almost all of these
structures
we actually took these droplets and we
asked them a bit further so we first
found that these droplets could
you know encapsulate functional
superfold gfp
we also found that these droplets could
catalyze or scaffold the assembly of
some type of lipid structures around the
droplets
and finally we found that rna could
segregate and into and function in the
presence of these droplets so one of the
next questions we tried to pursue was
that you know only one type of polyester
droplet we found could it could
compartmentalize rna but these are all
neutral droplets that we studied can
other polyester droplets or droplets
made from other compositions
compartmentalize rna
and we hypothesized that if we included
a basic alpha hydroxy acid something
that could be positively charged in
solution um the droplets that contain
this positive residue could allow the
rna with a negative backbone to
um segregate more strongly than than
before and indeed we incorporated some
percentage of these cationic residues we
we still saw droplets um but we found
that increasing the amount of cationic
residues actually resulted in
disassociation of the droplets
and we actually believe that for example
at really high concentrations of the
cationic residue it's very likely that
the droplets are too polar and too
soluble in water or they're too charged
and too soluble in water so they don't
form the droplets but at lower
percentages
of the cationic residue we still see
droplets and it's very likely that these
droplets are still cationic so it's
likely that the polyester formation is
governed by the total charge of this
mixture
and in fact we did find the ability for
these new novel you know cationic
droplets to segregate rna you can see
here on the bottom that the fluorescent
rna is really strongly segregated into
these droplets here and we found that
even increasing
the amount of
charged monomers
into a neutral polyester by only about
20 percent allowed polyesters which
originally went in the neutral form
couldn't segregate any rna to be able to
segregate some rna here shown in the
middle and the right
so even just a small amount can change
these structures
and so again if you're interested in
learning more details about this study
or these studies some of them have been
published i would highly encourage you
to read some of these papers here
for more details
so i'd like to of course thank my
funding sources a lot of these funding
sources came from japan but also one
from the french embassy in japan
i'd like to thank some of my
collaborators that have worked on this
project with me before especially irina
jim kuhan and tommaso both at lc and
outside of lc
and i'd like to thank all the
collaborators at lc and tokyo tech
especially chan and rihanna who recently
have been working with me on some other
really exciting projects related to
polyesters
and also a lot of my collaborators
around the world for all these projects
as well it's been a great experience and
i hope to continue working with everyone
so finally i'd like to give a few um you
know
programs that you might be interested in
to get into astrobiology research so
blue marble space institute of science
has a young researcher program over the
summer if you're studying in university
or recently graduated and are interested
to do a virtual project over the summer
uh you can take a look there are
different projects of different types
and
some are research based some are you
know outreach based some are
communication based
and so you can take a look at the
website shown here
my main um
affiliation elsie we're a research
institute located in tokyo and uh we
study the origin and evolution of earth
planets and life on earth
and
here's some other pictures here we've
recently started a five-year integrated
master's phd program and this program is
open to both domestic and international
applicants and you will be fully funded
if you're interested uh the next
deadline for fall 2022 enrollment is
mid-april you should visit this website
here uh hopefully you'll be interested
in this
and finally uh last year i was part of
the organizing team for a conference
called appgradcon which is astrobiology
graduate conference it's an annual
conference for students and postdocs in
or looking to get into astrobiology and
it's organized by students in postdocs
and it's a really great experience
especially if you've never done a formal
astrobiology or formal presentation it's
a really good
experience and opportunity graham
actually also was
one of the other speakers of this
session was a
an organizer back in the day as well so
the next edition is
online uh it's going to be held in
august and the abstract deadline is may
15th so if you're interested please
visit the website and the the new team
of organizers they've been doing a
really great job and i highly encourage
you to attend that
so thank you all for your time and
attention thank again thanks again to
the organizers for giving me this
opportunity i'm sorry again that i
couldn't be there live with you but i'm
very happy to take questions either by
email
or if you want to leave a comment on the
youtube i'm sure we can be in touch so
thank you again and i hope you enjoy the
rest of this meeting
okay great
so now we will continue forward
so
it is my pleasure to welcome our next
speaker dr fati karuya
dr koruya is a scientist affiliated with
blue marble space institute of science
within the astrobiology and space
sciences division division at nasa ames
research center
dr korea conducts research related to
astrobiology space biology and human
space flight in particular he is
interested in life beyond earth and how
biological systems respond to the space
environment
understanding and mitigating the effects
of long duration space flight on
astronauts health
and developing high throughput
technology for in-situ space research
furthermore dr frepti karua is also a
project scientist
and to date he has successfully
implemented 18 investigations using
model organisms or humans aboard the
international space station
to contribute to his research with
associated space exploration and until
recently
um dr korea was a research professor at
the university of california san
francisco and the nasa space biology
non-rodent portfolio lead scientist
for the latter he oversaw a broad
portfolio of investigations conducted
aboard the iss and managed by the nasa
space biology program
dr korea received a phd in biology from
the university of houston a master's
degree in space studies from the
international space university a
master's degree in space technologies
from louis pasteur university and a
master's degree in physics and a
bachelor's degree in physics and chem
chemistry so it is now my pleasure to
welcome dr fatih karuwa
hi how are you good morning good
afternoon or good evening wherever you
are thanks again for the introduction
let me share my screen
are you able to see my slides
yes we are
okay great
so um
again thanks thanks for having me uh it
is my great pleasure to be able to spend
some time uh as you can see it will be a
very short period of time and so i would
not have time to go into detail
so the attack obvious presentation is
just to tease you out a little bit about
space biology and and more importantly
about the different type of ongoing
studies
and the need of talented scientists like
you
that will need to be involved in the
next few years or even decades to try to
help
human spaceflight and space exploration
so
let me start with giving you a brief
outline
of my presentation so as i previously
mentioned it would be just like a 20
minutes talk so would not go into too
much details
but i just want to emphasize that
currently we are leaving under exciting
time since i will be
spending a bit time related to that and
then i will dig into describing a little
bit because i will assume that many of
you don't have
a strong background uh related to human
space flight or space biology in
particular and therefore i will spend a
little bit of time trying to describe a
little bit of different type of
special environments and what is the
impact of the lack of gravity increased
level of radiation on humans and then we
kind of transition with uh giving you
an example of a study that had been
conducted on board the international
space station and in particular the
microbial tracking 2 study which was
looking at the microbiome of the
environment as well as from the
astronauts and then kind of transitioned
from what we have learned so far for
example
in low earth orbit and how we
extrapolate
by going beyond love of orbit and for
example going back tomorrow to the moon
i'm sorry and hopefully soon
to mars and then i will emphasize the
fact that there is a need a need for
having
space biotechnologies on board habitat
or spacecraft and that would be the only
way for us
to be able to sustain a safe
space exploration and so
let me start briefly by mentioning that
we are living under exciting times and
as you are well aware between
now and 2025 a lot of people are
currently working and trying to
implement the artemis program and the
idea there is to have the first woman on
the lunar surface by 2025 and that will
start with
a habitat orbiting around the moon the
gateway and hopefully then we will be
implementing habitats and street fest
exploration on the moon and so but that
is only one step one step forward uh one
step forward towards hopefully
exploration of mars and here is
is a is a roadmap of of nasa by
continuing
performing studies in low earth orbit
onboard the international space station
then as i just mentioned
with some lunar activity and hopefully
within the next decade also then having
exploration of mars and i think that we
all have an important role to play in
those new types of robotics and human
exploration
when we deal with the space environment
obviously it is an environment which is
very different from what we are
experiencing here on earth and so it's
composed of a near vacuum or vacuum
depending of your locations extreme
temperature variation
lack of gravity and so going from
microgravity to partial gravity if
you're on the moon on mass
and then obviously one of the main
limiting factors is space mediation and
depending on your location you have
different type of environments
when we transition to the impact of that
environment on the human physiology as
you can see
the effect of microgravity in particular
on the human physiology
is important are functions of emission
durations and here i'm laying out uh
some references related to the impact of
the special alignment on different
organs or physiological system and so
just to kind of tease you out let's talk
about the central nervous system
and so studies have shown that actually
there are nerve vestibular problems and
cognitive alterations in regards to
the cardiac system
there are uh heart atrophy cardiac
arrhythmia decrease of plasma volume and
blood cell mass and then orthostatic
intolerance have been returned to earth
in regards to the immune system i mean
as probably well aware of the astronauts
immune system is and i guess we have a
tendency to call it immunocompromised so
the crew are uh immunocorporates and so
that means that actually they have a lot
of problems related with the immune
system and that leads to for example
alterations in a natural
killer cell steel cells activity
there is a lower phagocytosis and
oxidative burst capacity from
neutrophils there is a reduced
antimicrobial function of monocytes and
then also there are changes in the
distributions of interferons and
cytokines production and then
also some issues in related to virus
trailing and so there's an increased
frequencies of of viral tradings when
crew are in space
then there's uh bone loss bone loss
density which is also obviously very
important and the rate goes from one
percent for the lumbar spine to 1.5
percent for the hips and the femur per
month obviously muscle atrophy because
of a lack of gravity so there's a
decrease between five to ten percent of
muscle size and over 20 of muscle
strength for a six month mission and
then there's a
new uh
new issues related to the health of the
astronaut which is called space flight
associated neural ocular syndrome which
results actually
in the in optic
disk edema and also some issues related
to the optic nerves and so some of the
crew comes back to the ground with some
visual impairment and so certainly this
is an issue and then on top of that as i
just mentioned i mean radiation could
have some additive or synergistic
effects
so as i just mentioned i've been
involved in a few projects and i've been
lucky to do so and
and so
i will call those astrobiomes and so
microbiome of the space environment and
i will be talking about project that
i've been involved with and so i've been
involved with the microbial tracking one
studies which was
a recurrent studies sampling different
area from the international space
station and
today i'll be talking mainly about
briefly about microbial tracking 2 which
was a combination of attacking samples
from the on that on view environment as
well as taking sample from 4 crew
members but as you can see
nasa is not just the only
entity conducting those type of studies
there have been also similar studies
coming from european space agencies as
well as jaxa
so microbial tracking 2 was an
interesting study and actually that was
the first human related space biology
study that was sponsored by the space
biology program and so the study was
looking at as i mentioned taking samples
from your environment so we were
swagging different surfaces
dining table
toilet exercise equipment and so forth
and then we were also taking samples
from the crew so we were taking samples
from their mouth from the nose and from
different skin
areas so like forearms and the navels
and behind the ears and so forth
and
and so this is a picture from the
international space station as i
mentioned there was a sampling that took
place
mainly from the the
united states orbital segments and so
what i mean by that those are the main
elements
from international partners as well as
from the us
and so here's a snapshots about all
those different locations and again i'm
not going to go into details but
different samples so here you can see
the toilet so we took samples from the
toilet which is samples from the
exercise machines here you see the
dining table so we also took samples
from there and again that was
combination of environmental sampling as
well as taking samples from the crew so
obviously
these days
so after collecting samples from
the station or the and then those are
returned to the ground and then
obviously we use half throughput methods
to be able to characterize the
microbiome environment and so here's a
snapshots
looking at the relative abundance so the
top 12
genera are here depicted here and so
for each rows correspond to one crew
members as you recall there was four
different crew members and so we took
again samples from the ear the nostrils
the skin which was a combined from
different locations the mouth and saliva
and so again here different crew members
some of which
were
operating at the same time which was
also interesting and then actually there
was also from crew members from
different countries which was also
interesting to see
and uh for example from a saliva
perspective so as you can see the
changes when we take samples prior to
the mission during the mission and after
the mission as you can see there's a lot
of changes depending uh of the time
period and the locations
and what was interesting also in this
case for example when we try to
perform what we call non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling and practical
coordinates analysis where we were
comparing
samples location by crew members and as
you can see there's a a good
correlations
when we look at for example the saliva
and the mouth we could very easily
identify them by crew members as opposed
to other area which was more mixed
within the samples so here is just like
giving you a
brief synopsis of the type of studies
that can be conducted where we collect
samples uh from the environment as well
as from the crew using half throughput
methods and so again i don't have a time
to go into details but what was
interesting to see is that
when we took the samples from the crew
samples coming from the
skin nostrils and the ear were much more
similar to the surfaces as opposed to
those samples coming from the mouth and
the saliva and in some fashion it makes
sense there was a strong correlation
when crew member was taking surface
samples with the microbiome of the
astronauts
interestingly speaking
when we were looking at samples coming
from the saliva there was a lot of
changes in relative abundance
from
from those samples
similarly there was an increase in
anti-microbial resistance from the
saliva samples
and then again there was a lot of
changes related to the saliva but those
seems to come back to normal after the
crew returned to earth
so when we extrapolate from what we have
learned from low earth orbit to
[Music]
moving forward to going back to the moon
for example and going to mars as you can
see i mean up to now you know we we we
have activities on the stations that are
the maximum roughly you know over a
little bit over a year
and certainly when we went to uh to the
moon uh some time ago it was only for
like up to two weeks and so certainly
now by having
those different type of explorations and
going back to the moon which will be for
a longer period of time and even more
importantly when we envision emission to
mass which would be three emissions as
you can see there's still a lot of
unknowns so the unknowns can be
characterized in different uh elements
some of which as i mentioned are related
to the effect of radiation probably
space radiation is one of the main
limiting factor to a long-duration
spaceflight
isolation and confinement there is there
will be limited capabilities for you to
return as i mentioned i mean you would
be very far from earth and communication
will be obviously an issues close
habitat so if there's an issue with the
habitat then you big trouble
and then
there's transition from
microgravity environment to partial
gravity and so certainly this is
something that we don't have a lot of
information on and so
when we look at
human spaceflight certainly there's a
lot of factors which are associated with
human in general and then and then as i
just mentioned uh those five different
risks which are currently being tracked
by the program and so by combining those
two
then there is our work that needs to be
done and there's a need for talented
scientists like you and using those
half-throughput methods to be able to
try to solve some of the risks and
mitigate those risks so that we have a
sustained
space exploration program
so i will argue that this generation is
a lucky generation because the 21st
century is the century of biology
and uh as you as you are well aware i
mean the central
dogma of molecular biology states that
dna contains the instructions for making
a protein which are copied into
ribosomal and their rna and so here you
have all those different methods which
enables you to
try to get some
information at the different stages so
obviously
by doing sequencing you can get some
information about the dna by
transcriptomics analysis of rna
proteomes and so forth and so all those
new type of methods and health
throughput methods will enable us to
actually be able to discriminate from a
healthy individual to someone that might
have a disease
either
short-term or like long-term and so by
combining all those different methods i
will argue that this is the key for us
to sustain a safe uh
human spaceflight
and long generation spaceflight in
particular
however when we look at
space research i will argue there is a
lag face so a few years ago i published
a review article about specifically that
and so
it's it is a busy chart but it's pretty
straightforward so on the the y-axis you
have different type of methods
so going from imaging to genomics on the
y-axis uh on the x-axis you have here
time duration so let's talk about
imaging so for example there was a
microscope that came out into the market
in 96 it took actually 15 years actually
six years 15 years to be
deployed a similar version of the
of the device to be deployed on both the
international space station so very very
long period of time between moment the
device came out in the market
from the moment where it was integrated
onboard the international space station
another example for example if you want
to look at transcriptomics
so rt pcr came out in the market
as a new technology in 96 there was a
new system that came out which is called
the cypress smart
cycle in 2000 and it took us roughly 16
years to deploy that specifically device
on the international space station and
as you can see i mean this is way too
long
we did better for a sequencing and the
mini iron in particular for example
minion came on and mark in 2011 and
actually was on the station tested on
this on the station by that in 2016 so
here's kate rubins using the mini iron
and again that was very very exciting
for us and certainly because this is a
small device doesn't require a lot of
resources certainly this was very much
appealing to the program however you
still need to take samples you still
need to do some amplification steps and
so forth to be able to do
a reading and be able to use the the
mini ion and so
if you want to transition
to
an environment where we could for
example either use commercial
off-the-shelf
instruments and so certainly there's
advantages in doing so because then that
will be something which is new and very
much advanced and therefore that might
require less development to be able to
use that technology however from a space
perspective well then you know there
would be an issue for automation does
the device adapt to the space
environment and then maybe we need to do
some qualification on the other hand
if you for example from the gecko from
the beginning try to design a
space-based platform and therefore you
will be optimizing the the three digits
it will be automatically miniaturized
but then that will require a long time
to develop and test
the technology and most likely that
would be a less advanced type of
technology and then you have that
hybrid platform system which could be
kind of plug and play which is a kind of
mix of commercial
available
a platform and maybe combining it with
space-based platform and so i've been
involved i've been lucky enough to be
involved in the development of such
technologies one of which is to design
an automated a nucleic acid extraction
and the other one was to specifically
test and dilate the prototype to do gene
expression analysis so again i don't
have much time to go into details but
here i'm giving you
a snapshot of
an instrument which was developed and
tested actually at yellowstone national
park and the device as i just mentioned
is automated so enables in automatic
fashion you can have six different
caches it so it's based on magnetic with
bit beating and that enables you to
extract in automatic fashion in a very
short period of time nucleic acids for
downstream applications so certainly
it's very appealing because that takes
away
the input from the crew
and so we tested and validated
the device on the field and actually we
showed that using a device as compared
to status protocols to extract nucleic
acids and then using illumina technology
of the nanopore technology actually we
showed there was no differences between
using the device which again is
automated or
standard laboratory practices
similarly as i just
mentioned
i was involved also in the biological
validation of a prototype which was
specifically designed for nanosatellite
technology so here you have a 10 by 10
device which enables you to grow cells
than to extract so to kind of
lyse those cells and then
extract the nucleic acid and rna in
particular and then hybridize it into a
chamber which enables you to measure
gene expression
and so the idea there is to have that
system on board a nanosatellite and
better understand the effect of space
environment on microbes for examples and
so we did show that extraction from the
system again which is miniaturized and
automated was similar to ground control
and then we ran in comparisons uh
looking at gene expression analysis
from rna extracted from the prototype
versus
laboratory practice and we show that
there was a very very strong correlation
between the two
so again i will argue that if we want to
use space-based technology
on board space habitat or spacecraft i
think that
for
going from now to the next three years i
think all the pcr bears or microarray
base and mini ions can be used
uh i think within the next few years we
can implement certainly the next
generation of sequencing and then have
microarray-based proteomics but it might
take a little bit more time to be able
to have a proteomics and metabolics type
of platform that would be very very
useful for
human space exploration
so again i will argue that within the
next few years we can deploy those omics
based
capabilities and i think that we all
have a role to play in helping
developing those new platforms and i
think those will be tremendous and
critical to
enable to minimize risk associated with
long-duration spaceflight so before
completing obviously i just want to also
use a minute or two to kind of as an
outreach platform and maybe some of you
might be interested and again i will
argue we are living during interesting
times and and i think there is many
opportunities for many of you to be
involved either in academic institutions
we're all within space agencies or maybe
you have your own id and if so then
maybe you can start your own startup
certainly interact with the community
either at conferences and you know it's
important to a network i think graham
would be talking a little bit about blue
marble because i am also affiliated with
the institute so i will i will not um
talk about that but certainly i also
participate in the international space
university program so there's different
programs that enables you to in some
fashion to explore your interest in
in space research
and uh again there's many different
programs which enables you to be entered
to be involved and nasa actually have a
positional fellowship which is actually
open to anyone not just the u.s
based student but also for
internationals and then there are the
u.n um
office of outer space that have many
different programs for
countries that don't have a space
program and so actually you are they are
sponsoring you to do some flight
experiments or to develop some cubesats
and then if you're interested in space
biology and human spaceflights in
particular there have been some special
issues one of which i was managing and
that kind of give you a snapshots of
what are the state of the art in
relation to
space biology and human space flights
and then gene lab gene lab is
an interesting
database that nasa has developed
throughout the years and actually that
enables
all space-related investigation to
deposit all the omics data into the
platform and then the enable talented
scientists that are interested in to go
and mine the information and so
certainly there are also multiple type
of tutorials inside and actually there's
also working groups that you can
participate if you're interested in that
and then i mean currently i'm involved
with the pressure in a laboratory in
characterizing some of those samples and
certainly we there's always a need for
us to have
people which have an interest in
and actually some talents in
bioinformatics to help us better
characterize all those different samples
so i will stop here here's my info i
mean certainly you're more than welcome
to reach out if you have any questions
and thanks again
great thank you so much dr korea that
was a great presentation
so we have a few questions for you
um number one what qualifications do you
think are most important to have if you
want to get involved in astrobiology
um
i mean i don't think there is
one
fits all i think at the end of the day
you need to do something that you're
passionate about
and i think this is key and so
certainly if you want to be involved in
astrobiology or space biology
i mean having some backgrounds in
biology would be critical
but there are many different venues for
you to be involved as just laid out um
in my i guess last two slides and so
again at the end of the day is just you
need just to try to do something you're
passionate about and you know there's no
limits and so
certainly there's many different venues
for you to be involved uh obviously i'm
coming from a u.s based
i guess institutions and so i am
familiar with uh
many of the nasa programs but these days
i mean everybody's at the international
level is involved
and i think
by networking attending conferences
that kind of enables you to kind of
have a better understanding of what type
of
science you would like to focus on but
certainly we need we need this next
generation to be involved
in a human specified because certainly
there's many different opportunities for
for all of us
great thank you
the next question is what is the most
critical challenge in astrobiology one
might be able to solve using
bioinformatics
i mean i think
when we
move forwards
they have all those risks that have to
be addressed
and and i think
omics based
studies
and therefore
people that are talented with
bioinformatics i think actually
bioinformatics currently and
computational biology and
artificial intelligence will be probably
the key
type of disciplines
that will be needed
for us to be able to address all the
risks
that limit us to be able to explore
our solar systems and so forth so
certainly
as i mentioned get involved with the
gene lab there's all those different
working groups that you can participate
because they have we have you know a lot
of
data which are currently available and
that just need to have talented
scientists to be involved with them so
great and then i think we have one more
question along similar lines um how can
we create safe space exploration using
omics methods
well i think that kind of goes back to
what i just mentioned uh i think it's
kind of twofold one is related to the
need of having
um omix platforms
as part as an integrative part of the
mission as you probably aware i mean
currently we have limited capabilities
on board international space station in
theory the stations the international
space station is the laboratory but
there's not much
uh instrumentation for analysis and so
currently the way things works is that
you expose your samples or you take
samples from the crew and then you have
to wait until those samples come back to
the ground to be able to analyze them
and so
this that's not going to work well when
we envision
missions where we
don't have those capabilities right and
so if we envision a mission to mars
which would be a mission of three years
most likely and so therefore you need to
have all those by
all those omics based platforms
inside the habitats or inside the
spacecraft and continue
monitoring the health of the crew on the
health of the environment obviously the
crew is important but also you need to
samples the environment to just to make
sure there's no issues certainly life
support system we will be also a key key
component and therefore you need to
study that
and having all those omix platforms will
be critical to minimize the risk and be
able to monitor the health of the crew
and so
certainly
there are a lot of venues for us to be
involved either from a science
perspective or from a technology
development
great thank you actually one more quick
question what is the most exciting thing
for you about in-situ proteomics in
space
i mean i i have an interest as a
scientist so certainly having those
platforms uh help us
to
stay away from the long cycle of how we
do science these days and space science
in particular i mean it roughly takes
five years from designing a study to
implement it and to
analyze the sample so that's way too
long and so having those platform and
proteomics in particular i would argue
that these days it's all about genomics
but yes i mean having informations about
the dna is important but
having an information of what type of
proteins and metabolites have been
secreted by the by
cells all the the human system is even
more important and by combining all
those different methodologies and
technology then we will be able to
address all those risks and make sure
that
the
the health of the crew
are kept at bay and making sure that we
are returning them healthy back back to
earth and so so definitely combination
from a science perspective as well as
from technology development
great well thank you again so much dr
korea for speaking with us it was a very
informative talk
thank you
all right
so
it is my pleasure to introduce our next
speaker dr graham lau
dr lao is an astrobiologist and a
communicator of science
with an academic background spanning
biology chemistry after physics and
geology dr lao is an expert on how
living things affect the environment
around them and how we search for alien
life beyond earth
he serves as the director of
communications and marketing for blue
marble space
a research scientist with the blue
marble space institute of scientists
and as the director of logistics for the
university rover challenge
and also as the host of the nasa funded
show ask an astrobiologist
dr lau also serves as a meditation
instructor and a public speaking coach
so please join me in welcoming dr graham
lau
thank you very much laura and thanks
everyone i'm going to do the share
screen thing here very quickly
hopefully everyone can see this
all right it's a pleasure to join you
all today to talk a little bit about
careers in astrobiology and we're going
to step back a little bit from targeting
just you know really research focused
things and talk a bit more grand scale
about what astrobiology is and then i'll
give some of my personal suggestions on
how to be involved and what i think is
the grandest challenge the grandest
quest of of human history is to know
where we've come from what we are
and whether or not we're alone in the
universe
astrobiology truly is the quest to
understand the nature of life
to understand our position here in the
cosmos on this blue marble this of
course is the famous blue marble image
from december 7th of 1972
when the the last apollo astronauts were
on their way to the moon they snap this
beautiful shot of our world
and i love sharing this image and i
think often of this image and other
images of our world from space
it's a view i'd love to have personally
one day looking down
but it reminds me you know that we are
together on this planet we share a
biosphere all of you here from young
undergraduate students maybe graduate
students and others who are interested
in omics research and other forms of
research involved in understanding life
are part of the grand quest of
astrobiology
um in careers in astrobiology and i'm
going to talk just briefly about some of
the different things astrobiologists do
and then i'll give some of my my
personal take-home messages for what i
think you can do to be even more
involved we have people just like tony
gia who talked this morning a researcher
at lc and bmsis who's involved in
understanding the origins the early
transitions into life on our biosphere
and maybe on other worlds we have
researchers trying to figure out did the
material for life come to us from space
did it all start here on our world
could life have started elsewhere and
then come here these are all really big
questions
we also have people studying geology and
planetary history
the formation of worlds and the
processes that happen to them through
time
researchers studying meteorites to
better understand the history of our
solar system researchers using large
telescopes to look at worlds out there
to better understand not just how worlds
form
but also what kinds of worlds may have
life out there for us to target even
more and to look for things out there
and and many of you here who might be
involved in omics research are probably
in some way involved in again this this
quest to understand how life functions
here on earth you know not just the
genes that various populations have here
on our planet but the expression of
genes that have led to such beautiful
biodiversity across our world you know
we are very lucky to live in this
extremely diverse biosphere with so many
different forms of life
often i just kind of nerd out and get
super excited just thinking about all
the weird almost alien things that live
right here beside us
in the next talk you're going to hear
from gary trouble about viruses and soil
ecosystems you know we don't really know
yet how to even classify viruses
relevant to life are viruses alive or
not is a big question i've heard
throughout my life i i personally lean
towards them being part of life and
being alive we also have people studying
you know extremophiles living in very
hot systems like prismatic spring here
in yellowstone national park and in very
cold or very saline
high pressure environments ways for us
to better understand how life pushes the
limits of chemistry and physics to
inhabit so many environments across our
world
and of course there are many people
involved in going out into our solar
system with robotic missions and and
even hopefully in the near future with
human missions uh to explore other
worlds we we have some candidates for
potential life in our own solar system
that are worth looking into and
exploring further
of course we've sent lots of things to
mars but there are also other potential
candidates like europa and enceladus and
titan
icy worlds in our solar system but we
also have potential for life in the
clouds of venus even and it's worth
exploring that potential to better know
if life only happened once in our solar
system or if maybe life has happened
several times in our own solar system
but
you might have recently heard the news
that there are now more than 5 000 known
worlds around other stars out there when
i was a young child dreaming of becoming
involved in astrobiology and space
science we didn't know of any exoplanets
at all and now we've passed 5000 and
that makes me wonder when do we pass ten
thousand when do we pass one hundred
thousand when will humans look out to
well over a million worlds that we know
for sure exist out there
based solely on the numbers we've found
we've found so far
there should be something at least
around the realm of 100 billion to maybe
even a trillion planets in our galaxy
alone
and that to me makes it seem like if
there is life out there beyond our solar
system it makes it even more likely that
we might find some of that life and so
if you want to be involved in
astrobiology you can be involved in in
the biological side in studying the
populations we see here but also trying
to figure out how would we find
signs of life on some of these
exoplanets out there right now we're
really just limited to looking at their
atmospheres
so the james webb space telescope has
been launched
it's successfully aligned now and we're
going to soon start getting some really
great data back some of the first
exoplanets that we'll be looking at are
ones that we already know
exist within the goldilocks zone for
liquid water around their stars uh
worlds like the trappist worlds um the
trappist-1 exoplanets
and others that might be good candidates
at looking at their atmospheres for
possible signs of life and so we need
young people who want to be involved in
this exploration in helping us to bring
together all of our knowledge to figure
out what could be out there
and if you're a nerd like me maybe you
also want to know if there's intelligent
alien life out there in the cosmos the
drake equation was originally developed
in 1960 by frank drake primarily to help
him organize a meeting of other
scientists to answer a question of what
do we need to know to find out if there
could be communicating aliens out there
in the universe
but it's also a very intriguing
expression primarily because of the
final factor in the equation the l
factor which is the average time span
for a civilization to exist
it was poignant and beautiful for drake
to have added that at that period of
time in 1960 we were becoming aware
uh very aware of our potential to
destroy ourselves primarily through
nuclear war and a nuclear holocaust
um but there are many other potential
existential threats that we face and
that other civilizations most likely
have faced or do face as well if they're
out there
and so that that factor the l factor
makes a lot of us wonder what is the
future for our species you know in in
korea's previous talk he was talking
about the factors that are involved in
space exploration and how we can study
the expression of genes and things like
that in space exploration but we've only
really just begun human space
exploration we don't really know what
happens to our species with another
century or a millennium of space
exploration where our species goes a big
question is will we see this idea of the
singularity of all of us kind of merging
into our machines when our technology
advances so fast that we basically
become the machine or the machine takes
over and leaves us behind
we don't know what that looks like it
might be likely that a lot of life out
there in the universe is post biological
life that most life is artificial
intelligence
and basically written in silicon and
other materials of metal rather than
being built in organic chemistry as we
are
but all of that said there's a lot of
need for a lot of people to be involved
in astrobiology a lot of people involved
in answering these questions and
again you know we also face this
potential for our own destruction and we
should question what our future is
one of my favorite science fiction
stories is star maker by olaf stapleton
uh it's a story written in 1935
originally where a human consciousness
leaves its body and travels out beyond
the earth and looks back it travels
beyond our solar system it travels out
into the galaxy the consciousness itself
experiences becoming a type one attack
to a type three civilization on the
kardashev scale
in this story this this this idea of of
galactic and then universal exploration
it really really it's a fun way to kind
of explore what it would be for a human
to leave
uh our bodies and to explore the
universe but one thing i really love
about the book
is that stapleton faced some issues with
others questioning
why he would write such a fable about
space exploration at a time when europe
was on the brink of war
and in the 1937 intro to the story he
wrote this that perhaps the attempt to
see our turbulent world against the
background of stars
may after all increase
not lessen the significance of our
present human crisis
it may also strengthen our charity
toward one another and i also i often
think that way about astrobiology
thinking about our place in the universe
and the origins and the evolution the
distribution of life out there
it makes us think a bit more about our
our own fragility
our own precariousness and our own
preciousness as a species in this
biosphere and i think it makes us be a
little bit kinder to each other and want
to do better for the future and so i
would love to see a lot more people
involved in learning about astrobiology
if not becoming astrobiologists
themselves and the interest has
certainly grown over the years this is
charles coquell's course for coursera
it's had well over 70 000 students now
have taken this free online course
my friend sid pandey who leads the amity
center of excellence in astrobiology at
amity university in mumbai in india a
couple of years ago had an introduction
to astrobiology course that had 795
students from 53 countries take part
and i love this graphic created by a
young student who previously worked for
me catherine herrera
where she created a graphic bringing
together 36 different languages of how
you say astrobiology
so all of that long-winded kind of idea
of this grand idea of what astrobiology
is brings me to this
i have a few things to share with you if
you're interested in astrobiology but
honestly these are kind of my my career
advice suggestions for any field really
the first one is to be a generalist as
well as a specialist
what i mean by that
um to become a research scientist so i'm
a research scientist my background is
primarily in geochemistry and mineralogy
i have a paper coming out here very soon
about some geological structures from
the arctic and how they relate to our
mars exploration for instance and so i'm
a specialist in the realm of
geochemistry applying it to field sites
on earth to other worlds
but i'm also a generalist as i
understand a lot of different things in
biology and astrophysics and philosophy
history and other realms and that helps
me to frame my thinking
one of my favorite arguments ever for a
liberal arts education comes from star
trek the next generation there is an
episode where captain picard is looking
out at the cosmos and talking to a young
man named wesley crusher and the young
man um laments that you know that he
can't really read this book the captain
gave him because you know history is not
going to be on his exam for how to pilot
a starship
and the captain responds that you know
the most important things never will be
on your exams
but if you understand if you study
things like theater and poetry and
history and philosophy it'll make all of
this make sense and he looks out across
the stars
and so becoming a generalist will help
you in your career in every way you go
here's a great page from nasa
astrobiology their career path
suggestions for getting into our field
and astrobiology it really is a very
diverse realm of study that brings
together many disciplines but you know
you can learn about astrobiology through
courses through people like me online
and shows that we have various social
media but a good place to be is to earn
a degree in in biology or chemistry
geology
and then start to specialize in the
questions that you really drive you
specialize in the realm that you want to
work in yourself but again be a
generalist try to speak the language of
all these different sciences
and again we need everyone and anyone
can be an astrobiologist and join us
in this adventure of coming to better
know ourselves in the universe
secondly i think you need to own your
own learning
you know when you pay money to go to a
university and earn a degree that's
great and it's great to have a formal
education
but you should never let a formal
education get in the way of your own
learning
you know the classes you take the
courses that you pursue
certificates that you add to your cv
those things are okay
but you really need to be in charge of
how you approach your learning how you
approach your reading and your writing
and the time that you spend in research
so there are some suggestions we have
for our young scientist program
participants i'll mention that some more
later even though tony and fathee both
have mentioned it already
but we also recommend amongst learning
about science is to learn about how to
be a good researcher how to learn more
and so i recommend books like limitless
from gym quick and deep work from cal
newport different ways that you can
study and learn a bit more about how to
be a good learner and how to own your
own learning
and of course there are lots of books
out there that you can read to learn
more about our explorations of the
universe from the writings of carl sagan
in cosmos and pale blue dot to david
grinspoon's works chris impai's works
there are many great books uh i
recommend my my amazon shopping list i
put together a small list
of books related to learning
astrobiology that i found helpful for a
lot of young people
thirdly i think you need to build a
network build a community around your
research and what you want to do
if you're working in bioinformatics find
networking find communities of people
who are working in the same field who
can help you answer questions but also
who can help give you ideas of where to
look for job postings to further your
career and astrobiology there are a lot
of great organizations who are doing
things relevant to astrobiology
organizations like saginet of which i've
been a part the planetary society the
mars society
tony mentioned the astrobiology graduate
conference
for graduate students if you're
interested uh the ab grad con and ad
grad e the european astrobiology
graduate conference are both great ways
to start meeting other graduate students
and and for undergraduates sometimes
they accept undergraduate students who
are really good at what they're doing
um and then tony mentioned and thoughty
mentioned as well this young scientist
program that we have at blue marble
space not only am i a mentor for the
program i'm also the program's director
and so if you're interested this is a
summer research internship um from june
through august and we'll have it this
summer uh here's just a small list of
the projects that we have available with
our researchers for this summer
um you know things like graph theory
viruses versus the human immune system
ancient microbes
a lot of things that involve coding and
programming in various ways
i have a project
through elsi as well with tony
called the landscape of community
engagement in the origins of life
research um lots of great projects if
you're interested in learning more you
can check out our website bmsis.org
ysp
projects the applications are due fairly
soon by april 15th but if you have any
questions feel free to ask me about that
i'm always happy to talk further about
our program
through the years we've had now over a
few hundred young students be involved
in this process
learning about not just research and
science but also learning about moral
philosophy applied to science and about
how we communicate and share our science
also uh in laura's intro for me she
mentioned that i'm the host of the show
called ask an astrobiologist this show
is primarily targeted towards the
younger kind of undergraduate level
and even for those who aren't actually
involved in astrobiology to learn more
about our field but during this show
which we air live on youtube once each
month i interview other astrobiologists
to talk about their career paths their
research
i even just the other day was speaking
with a young student he watched my
episode 37 with melissa trainor uh the
deputy pi for the dragonfly mission
going to titan
um after watching my episode with her he
reached out to her and just asked you
know like do you have any research
available that i could work on i would
love to learn about dragonfly and it
turns out she did and he ended up
joining her for a research project uh
they now have a manuscript in
publication and so he'll be involved at
least somewhat for some of the research
going on with dragonfly going to titan
finally uh if you if you can and you
want to be involved in engineering
competitions and science competitions
there are lots of ways to network and
join various groups
i help to lead the university rover
challenge where undergraduate student
groups from various universities around
the world they build mars rovers and
they bring them out into the desert of
utah
after what is usually a year-long or
even multi-year process of development
and testing and showing us that they're
ready to come out to the desert and then
we give them a very hard challenge at
the mars desert research station which
you can see in the background here in
this image where i've also been an
analog astronaut
we have the students running their
rovers around in different kinds of
tests
including science there's there's a
science site
where the students have to you know
drill or sample in some way to learn
about the biology in this desert
environment to learn about the geology
of this desert environment and so
there's lots of really cool ways to get
involved and build your community and
build your network if you want to be
involved in astrobiology
and so finally i'm going to end this
with this real quickly that it's really
important in your life and your career
no matter which field you pursue
is that you find the right mentors
and i've seen this a lot i think because
of how we structured academia a lot of
young people a lot of early career
researchers they think a mentor is just
a teacher
or an advisor like an academic advisor
and that's really not the case a good
mentor is far more than that a good
mentor is someone who knows when to be
your friend and when to be your boss
it's someone who knows how to teach you
but how to help you to learn how to
teach yourself
a good mentor is someone in your life
who is really going to be there for you
to help you answer questions
to steer you in the right direction when
you feel like you don't know which way
to go but also to to allow you to grow
in your own ways and so a mentor is
someone whose hindsight can become your
foresight for those of us out here in
the world who've been very fortunate and
blessed and honored to be mentors for
young students and i'm so fortunate that
i've had the chance now to impact so
many other lives and to help others out
there i can tell you it's an honor and a
privilege to be a mentor but it's also
something that many of us take very
seriously and so if you have a teacher
or an advisor and they're not really
taking that job seriously they are not
your mentor your mentor doesn't have to
be in the same program the same research
group or the same university your
mentors in your life can help drive you
forward and help you define what ends up
becoming your career and like i said
earlier i really hope it is in somewhere
in this grand scheme of understanding
the nature of life out there
so i'm going to leave it just with this
slide of how you can reach out and find
me out there if you're interested
i will say i'm giving a talk in denver
on the 4th of april
at the museum of nature and science
about mars exploration and sarah
johnson's book the sirens of mars
it's part of the science friday book
club program i'll be at the university
of north florida on the 22nd of april if
anyone's down in florida and wants to
come here to talk about chemistry and
astrobiology
i'll be at the analog astronaut
conference uh the 6th through 8th of may
so if any of you have been involved in
analog astronautics or want to be
involved i think there are still some
tickets left to come down to biosphere 2
and hang out with a bunch of us
including astronaut cyan proctor
and then finally uh here in may i'll be
at absycon from the 15th through 19th if
any one of you are going to abscicon or
the astrobiology science conference and
want to meet up
feel free to send me an email drop me a
line find me on social media or my
website i'm always happy to chat
so with that i'll take any questions
that are available
thank you so much dr lau that was an
awesome presentation
so we have a few questions for you uh
the first one is what is your own belief
for how life began on earth ooh i love
it
you know i i i don't know and i really
don't think we're ever going to know
um so the way that you know the history
of our planet works you know the oldest
rocks we have on earth are around like
three and a half 3.8 billion years old
the oldest minerals we have on earth are
four to like 4.2 billion years old but
those minerals usually zircon grains get
trapped in younger rocks but the very
early history of our earth is erased in
the geological record by the fact that
we live in a dynamic planet with plate
tectonics
and so i think the only way to really
ever know for sure is if we had some
really nice alien neighbors who've been
out there watching us this whole time
and one day we can meet them and join
the galactic federation and they can say
hey this is how it happened on your
planet just so you know
i will say that i am a big fan of the
concept of panspermia that life might
have started first on venus for instance
and then gone to earth
i think starting on mars and coming to
earth is less likely
but still also a possibility but i don't
want to rule that out it is very
possible but we don't have any evidence
yet to support that and so it does seem
like life at some point very early in
our earth's history started here on our
planet
great thank you
our next question is does biology or
bioinformatics support the theory of
astrobiology and how does it go about
doing that
well i would first state there is no
theory of astrobiology
and one thing i really loved in the
original cosmos by carl sagan you know
is he spoke about in in chemistry in
physics we have you know defined laws
you know we have this idea of the the
physical nature of our universe but
we're still trying to figure out what
life is you know we have some attempts
at a definition of life but all of them
are somewhat questionable the current
best one is the nasa definition of life
uh that life is a self-contained
chemical system capable of darwinian
evolution uh i was even just chatting
with richard dawkins here this past week
um about whether or not all alien life
all life out there must be darwinian
which he argues it must be but i don't
know and i i don't know if there's some
other possibilities for life out there
and so for any of you out there who are
studying biology who are doing work in
bioinformatics you're helping us to
better understand what life is you're
helping us to understand the populations
of organisms out there how their how
their genetic information is expressed
and sure alien life might not have the
same information systems it might not
have the same kinds of structures of
encoding information getting it out
there but by doing this work in
bioinformatics you're helping us to
start kind of preparing for what we
might find if we find life out there
great thank you again
well i don't know if there are any other
questions for you so i think we will
move on but again thank you so much for
presenting it was an honor to have you
here thank you all
okay
so moving on it is my pleasure to
introduce dr gary trouble
dr trouble earned his bs in
environmental science with an emphasis
on microbiology at the university of
arizona and worked for the usda for two
years researching how to use fungi as a
biocontrol on crops instead of
pesticides
he then did an ms in environmental
science and health at the university of
nevada reno in the desert research
institute where he researched active
bacteria inhabiting the sub-zero
temperature like vitabrine in antarctica
gary finished his studies by earning a
phd in microbiology at the ohio state
university where he characterized
viruses and soils underlying with
permafrost in their roles in ecosystem
carbon processing
gary did his postdoc at lawrence
livermore national laboratory in 2018
where he used stable isotope probing
combined with metagenomics and varroa
mix to track microbial and viral
activity and substrate utilization in
various soils
gary is currently a staff scientist at
the lawrence livermore national
laboratory where he continues to use
metaomics combined with other techniques
for example isotope probing to
characterize viruses microbes and virus
microdynamics so please join me in
welcoming dr gary truble
all right everyone can you hear me
yes we can hear you
great
so this is such a cool time to go that
way graham that was such a such a good
talk and i knew i was going to be going
after you such a great speaker
um i think that that was perfect
oh right before my talk because it
really has this take a step back
think about
what are what are we doing for
astrobiology what are our goals what do
we need to think about i think
a lot of us get bogged down in what
astrobiologist has to be
and you know as as you heard in my
background the way i got into
astrobiology is different than other
ways that people get natural biology and
i would arguably say an astrobiologist
is somebody
that questions life like what do we do
and why are we here what what is life
all about
i think one of my favorite quotes is
from a nasa uh
nasa astrobiology institute poster where
for astrobiology it says
what is life where is life and how do we
find it and that that's really what it's
all about there's no direct path that
you have to take to become an
astrobiologist
so here i'm going to give you
kind of some vignettes of work that i've
been doing
ways that i'm pushing the boundary to
really detect and look at life
i arguably think viruses are alive at
some points we have our working
definition of life but there's no set
definition
but
for instance when a virus infects a host
it redirects its metabolism and the host
only does what the virus wants it to do
so is it the host that's alive or is it
the virus that's alive
so i chose soils to go into because
they're the most diverse ecosystem and
to really look at detecting our limits
for life we need to be looking in soil
ecosystems
so i'll have some shout outs at the end
for some astrobiology and astrovirology
endeavors that i've done but i want you
to take some time to really
learn about viruses and viruses and
soils and please ask questions if you
have any at the end
so the first thing i want to point out
is that
metagenomics and metamic processes these
are metagenomics meta transcriptomics
metaproteomics metametabolomix there's
so many out there have really
revolutionized how we look at viruses
and just microbiology in general
um here's a figure i took from a paper
from by simon rue in 2019
where in blue and green you can kind of
see our isolates of viruses that we just
accumulated over time but in just such a
short span of time we've shot up the
number of viral population genomes that
we've gotten in databases so quickly
and kind of
help you understand that what a meta
genome is the way we're looking at
viruses without needing to cultivate
them
is that we're taking a sample like soil
and we're extracting all the nucleic
acids so for a metagenome this would be
all the dna from the soil and we're
sequencing it then we're reconstructing
all these genomes
we're also reconstructing the variants
that go along with these genomes so we
like to call it population genomes
so this is what i've been pushing is
really looking at viruses from soils
using metagenomics primarily
so until recently if you looked at viral
studies
they haven't really been in soils
we had some of our first studies in the
oceans and then we had everyone caring
about human viruses taken off and
there's nothing wrong with that i like
human viruses but i specifically focus
on viruses that infect microbes
especially bacteria and we call these
bacterophage so these viruses are host
specific they can only infect bacteria
as we know
but there's so much that they can do in
the environment and this is what i'm
exploring and they have the largest
diversity of any viruses out there
so what i've done with my time now at
lln lawrence livermore national lab is
really push
soil viromics a study of just focusing
at the virus comportment
of viruses and soils so we've been
pushing the studies up there
so the problem
why am i shooting for soils and how does
soils help with our detection of life
when we take a metagenome when we
sequence all the dna from soil
less than two percent of our data we
like to call this assembled reads
actually go to viral sequences
less than two percent so we're not
really seeing viruses in our main way in
which we're detecting viruses
and the reason for this is if you look
at soil i have this small area that i've
zoomed in for you there's so much going
on in soils you have your plants your
roots the rice is here it's so rich you
have your macrophage your meso5 the
microfauna then if you zoom in then you
get at your micro do you have your
bacteria archaea
and if you zoom in even further now you
can see the viruses
so when we're taking this dna we're
taking all of this dna and so the
viruses
yes they're highly abundant they're the
most abundant biological entity out
there but they have these small genomes
that get swamped by these large genomes
so i've worked for my phd and since on
really being able to get as much
information we can from the tools that
we have and then bringing tools together
to increase the detection
so the first thing i'm going to talk to
you about is when i use from a postdoc
now is stable isotope probing to really
look at microbes and viruses in
ecosystems but specifically soils so if
we look at microbes we have bacteria
here
they can exist in many different
metabolic states when they're in soil or
any environment i'm just going to keep
saying soil
but the majority of them are actually
dormant or deceased and when we take all
this dna we're looking at this whole
community so we're actually seeing who's
who's contributing we're seeing all the
members it's kind of if we looked at the
human population 17 everyone alive now
we saw everyone who was ever on the
earth and
for different research questions we kind
of care about what's going on now or
who's contributing right now
in order to bypass this i'm going to
talk to you about two different diff
versions of isotopes that i use with
compounds to look at viruses
so the first one we call heavy water so
you have traditional water which is h2
around 160 that's the most abundant
isotope of oxygen but we can change that
oxygen isotope to 18o this is enriching
it this is less abundance so when we add
this
any organism that uses water which is
everything that's active because water
is a universal substrate for life it's
going to incorporate this heavier oxygen
into its dna or rna so we can actually
pull that out and we know who's using
the water so we know who is active so
with heavy water we're going to label
all active organisms and the viruses
that infect them
another experiment that i'm going to
talk about is where we can use specific
substrates to target certain parts of
the community and so instead of all
organisms in this study i mean used in
rich plant biomass this is where we grow
plants
with 13 co2 so the plants will take up
the co2 for photosynthesis they'll be
enriched with 13c carbon so the whole
plant is now 13 streets see labeled so
any organism that's munching away and
breaking down that carbon is going to
become labeled so i'm going to
specifically look at the organisms that
are responsible for degrading the plant
biomass
once we have that organism labeled we
then can extract its dna and then we can
do ultrasonification to separate the dna
physically separating the dna based on
its density so in these tubes here we
have our dormant deceased or
non-degrading 13c plant biomass dna up
towards the top and then the one that's
enriched with the 13c or the 180 is more
dense so we can physically separate it
we can pull them out separately and we
can sequence them separately so this is
helpful because now we can sequence who
is active and who's contributing but
also for comparative reasons we also
know who else is there and the reason is
when we sample an environment we're
taking a snapshot in time so just
because something's active right now
doesn't mean it's necessarily active
later and we're still trying to figure
out this time scale this temporal
sampling to really understand how the
environment and the dynamics are
changing it could be i sample something
now and then a minute later those are no
longer active this is what we're really
trying to figure out so we take both and
then we can compare
also by looking at both we get this nice
genetic catalog of everything that's
possible in the environment and this can
help other fields such as biotechnology
or looking at the health of the soil
possibly
okay so going into my first paper that i
want to talk about so this is something
that we published last year and it was
exciting work um it kind of brought me
back to my phd work where i was working
on viruses and permafrost which is
frozen ground so here we looked at
permafrost which is groundless frozen
for two or more consecutive years in
alaska
and what happens is every year the
permafrost has an active layer that
seasonally thaws and the microbes become
active and then during the winter
freezes back up now it's currently
thought that all the carbon that's
leaving the soil you know leading to
climate change and global warming
is for microbes coming from the summer
that's when they're active that's when
there were spiraling releasing co2 but
there's been mounting evidence to
suggest that co2 is leaving during the
winter as well so we really wanted to
look at this so we went and we sampled
this peat which is this highly organic
nutritious soil
that just hangs around
because it's so cold and the conditions
aren't right for microbes to break it
down readily
so we took this p and we simulated
winter conditions so we brought it down
to below freezing we made it anoxic so
there's no oxygen and we incubated it
for a full year and we sampled that a
half year and then at the end of the
full year
from this we physically extracted the
dna and separated it and then we
sequenced 23 metagenomes
during this time we also measured carbon
dioxide being produced in these bottles
all right so the key takeaways of what
happened here
we realized that there were active
viruses and bacteria in the subfreezing
anoxic permafrost soils
and then when we compare who is active
to who is not active the communities
were very different so in this figure we
have these larger pills which are
bacteria and then we have these hexagons
which represent viruses if they have
numbers in the larger they were active
if they're smaller they were inactive
now they don't show you their abundance
but if you look at the pink ones on the
bottom typically when we look at these
permafrost oils these are arctan
bacteria these are the most abundant
organisms they just dominate and if you
look most of them actually were not
active
and the ones that were active were our
green ones and our yellow ones so these
are our firm cubes and our bacteria
deities and what's crazy about this is
if we had just taken a traditional
metagenome we would have never looked at
these organisms their abundance is so
much lower we would have ignored them
but they're actually who is there and
who's active so we would have missed the
important part of our research so by
adding the stabilized snow probing with
our metagenomics we got to see this
we also got to see that while only a
small portion of the bacterial community
was active
a large portion of our viral activity
was active over 70 percent
looking into the metabolism of these
bacteria we saw that they had the
capabilities for fermentation and for
breaking down carbon okay
so we also know that they were aspired
in peru too so we physically showed
that respiration was occurring over
winter so this makes us rethink how we
think of activities of organisms in
different environments that in these
subfreeze environments there is carbon
dioxide coming from they are active
we were able to link a third of these
active viruses to host and when we
looked at their genes the viruses
actually carried these genes that when
they infect the host they can make the
host use these genes
and it can help the host scavenge
nutrients to help survive the winter or
possibly help them break down other
plant biomass
another thing as we saw is that as the
bacterial community shifted over the
year the viral community shifted towards
the bacterial community so we know from
previous research that viruses will lyse
their host and kind of kill the winter
hypothesis so they maintain diversity by
you have one population that shoots up
and the viruses kill it and control it
and bring it down this way it feeds all
the other organisms and gives them
ability to actually compete so now we
have a more diverse community and this
could be really important for how our
earth is changing with climate change
okay now moving into a completely
different environment we're leaving the
cold frigid anoxic environment now we're
moving to the lush puerto rican
rainforest
as you can imagine this is where we're
using our 13c so we have these luxury
foresters which are known to have this
high diversity and are critical for
storing carbon on our planet
but one thing a lot of people don't know
is that the rainforests have these crazy
redox conditions in the soil where you
can get this this
downpour that just floods the soils
and these microbes are highly diverse
here so what is going on how are they
surviving this they go through periods
where there's oxygen and then no oxygen
and they have to be able to respond and
survive that we wanted to know how are
they surviving and who's active is it
are they constantly dying and other ones
are emerging are viruses active and more
importantly how does this redux
condition the switching between toxic
and anoxic environment affect the fate
of the organic carbon there are we is it
helping store carbon or is it causing a
problem releasing this carbon
so we set up a treatment experiment
where we had four different treatments
we had octet the whole time and oxygen
the whole time a high frequency switch
every four days and then a slower
frequency shift of four and eight days
to mimic rain patterns of area
so this where we use a 13c enriched
plant biomass and we incubate it with
soil over 44 days and remember we're not
we're not looking for all active
organisms we're specifically looking at
the organisms and viruses that are part
of breaking down this plant biomass and
the fate of this biomass being released
in the atmosphere or stored in the soil
um so we were able to maintain this kind
of head space of oxic or antioxidant
using a nitrogen gas
and then we incubated for 44 days so
here we also wanted to compare are we
actually getting increased resolution on
our viruses bacteria by teasing apart
the active versus the inactive so we did
a comparative study we took 10
traditional metagenomes which i call
bulk soil metagenomes and then we had 85
sip fractionated metagenomes and this is
where we teased apart heavy fractions
and fractions and compared them
the main takeaway from this is if you
think about in comparison to our arctic
samples the diversity was so much higher
here
we had 64 active or sorry 46 active
bacteria before here we had 326 and that
was just looking at the carbon there was
other ones that didn't didn't care about
breaking down the plant biomass
and these bacteria spanned 20 different
phyla so this huge diversity
we also had 640 viral populations almost
double compared to our last one and this
is just looking at the carbon only
when we compared our sip fractionated to
our traditional metagenomes we see that
we did increase the resolution
antiviruses because when we compare them
we got about seven percent more
viral population so we increased our
diversity that we captured
now i want you to focus on this figure
here let me help you break it down
because i know these heat maps can get
crazy so let's focus on the one on the
left at the top i have the black ones
these are kind of my bulk samples and
then in blue i have my control samples
this is just regular plant biomass and
then the red at the bottom this is the
13c enriched plant biomass and what i
want your eyes to see is if you see
white
there's no abundance that's a viral
population that wasn't doing anything
you see some orange there's a viral
population there it's doing something
you see green not only is there a viral
population there but it's taken off it's
killing its host it's redirecting its
metabolism it's influencing the
environment so that's what we care about
i also have zoomed in on the figure on
the right just the active ones because
this is the ones we really care about
right these are the ones that are
controlling the carbon right now
so you'll see that in the octic we had
the most each line is a viral population
we had the highest diversity of viral
populations and this decreased along the
redox gradient so when there was anoxic
and there's less oxygen there's less
viruses and if you think about it that
makes sense when you're a virus when
you're taking up your house you want to
kill it and make more progeny viruses
you're like oh my babies
or you want to lie low in it and you
want it to become strong and efficient
so it can survive this hard time before
you make your babies later so what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
a fish
earth the kind of the fastest the
strongest metabolism arguably
is oxygenated metabolism
then if you look at the anoxic
environment you'll see we have these
green ones remember i said that was
important these are viruses that are
highly abundant so even though we have
less viruses in that anoxic in the no
oxygen soils
they're highly abundant so we have
things
we have these viruses that were able to
feel this niche space that others
couldn't
and they're taking off they're loving it
they're living their life to their
fullest they're happy so this is
actually a paper that we're still
developing and we're really trying to
look how are these viruses different how
are they dealing with this metabolism
that doesn't require oxygen and that's
going to be critical to look at what
genes are using what their pain
and
viruses to the bacterial host we knew
which ones were involved with plant
biomass but
are they only affecting the plant
degradation by killing the host and
preventing them from breaking down the
biomass or are they doing other things
so we surveyed their genomes and we
found that they actually encoded genes
that when they infect the host they're
helping the host break down the plant
biomass and this is a reoccurring story
that we're finding in soils
typically in in the oceans you don't see
these
suicide hydrolases to help break down
biomass but install those
[Music]
more and more of these genes that
viruses are carrying to help the host so
they're having these roles in carbon
cycling that we just don't know the
whole story on
okay i'm moving on to my ldrd work so at
a national lab you can get research
funded and what's called an ldrd this is
lab directed research and development
and this is something i love about
working at a national lab these are
called high risk high reward studies
this would be
you you spit ball an idea to a friend
and they're like oh that sounds crazy i
feel like it would fail that's what they
want to fund here they want a high risk
high reward you dream something big and
it's either going to be amazing or
you're you're it's going to fail but
you're going to learn something from
that failure and that's what i got
funded and that's what i've been working
on and that's what i'm going to tell you
about right now
okay so i'm stepping back we talked
about metagenome before and i just want
to remind you from the meta genomes
we're getting this low resolution on
viruses
so i set up this experiment using a
grassland soil because there we found
out recently that they could be super
important for carbon storage by having
these long roots so we took a grassland
soil and we had four different
treatments we either had our water or we
had our heavy water to look at the
active ones and we added we added
phosphate because we thought you know
viruses use a lot of phosphorus when
they make their capsids so we're
wondering if it's critical for infection
so we had some treatments where i added
that we also wanted to know how these
viruses changed
in this how they affected the ecosystem
and themselves how they changed over
time so we sampled over the course of a
month
before we're adding the water and after
adding the water and what's important
here uh if you if you're not from
california like i originally was and you
don't understand this that the whole
summer there is no rainfall it's great
for tourism but you would think it sucks
for the organisms in the soil how do
they survive
half the year with no water
so they have no water for half the year
and then come to the fall they have the
first rainfall you get this birch effect
you get water being added and all these
organisms come to life and so much of
the carbon is lost after that first rain
event because we're now getting
substrate to the organism to reactivate
so this is what i want to study so we're
adding the water here to these dry soils
to really see what's going on here
but it wasn't just metagenomics i wanted
to do i spent my whole phd optimizing
methods for what we call biomes or viral
targeted metagenomes and as you can see
from the figure here it's a multi-step
process where we take soil we wash it
with different buffers and then we
physically separate by size
fractionation typically a 0.2 or 0.5
micron filter to get things a virus size
out of the soil and then we sequence
that
so i can i'm showing here visually
comparing the circles we get so much
more information on the viruses from
this viral we also
funny enough information on ultra small
bacteria and archaea as well so it's
just it's a really cool technique
and so the con about this though is if
you just take a biorum you're not
necessarily getting all the hosts unless
of the ultra small host you kind of want
to take both if you want to know if you
want to relate viruses back to the
ecosystem level consequences from
mitigating their hosts
on top of this though we wanted to take
a meta transcriptome and this is going
to be looking at all the rna from the
soils and this is important because
there's all these viruses out there
there aren't a virus is the only
biological entity that we know can have
double-stranded and single-stranded dna
or rna some can reverse back and forth
between that as well so we needed to get
the rna as well to look at these viruses
finally something that we kind of hit on
here and invented some methods for us we
call this e-dna metagenome so in the
past it's been called ancient dna relic
dna degraded dna blah blah blah
or environmental dna or exogenous dna so
this is just dna that is in the
environment and i wanted to see okay if
we have dna environment
what what's its origin what's its
function is it being used in biofilms is
it coming from organisms dying are other
organisms eating is it a buffet what's
happening
and by taking all these methods together
we can get a better understanding of the
whole virus here from all these
different components
okay
so
relating back to edna we've only gotten
into a little bit of data so it's
preliminary but i wanted to share some
of it with you so in this figure i have
our time points the t-zero is pre-wet up
and then we have one week two weeks and
three weeks after we added our water and
the white scale we have the log scale
right so huge changes between the amount
of e dna we're seeing so the t0 we have
a lot of edna so which means if you're
taking a metagenome you're also seeing
dna not from inactive organisms but also
not even inactive in organisms at all
just in the environment so what's going
on there
okay so it accumulates over the dry
summer this is my leading theory so far
as i'm investigating and then we have
this downshift so what's going on
okay well we added water organisms now
have this water to use to fuel their
metabolism and this dna is juicy they're
hungry these are cheeseburgers or salads
if you're vegetarian they're loving it
they're like no no no no so the e dna is
dropping the microbial populations are
increasing and we see that we see the
number of microbial populations and our
vitamins increasing
then we kind of have 11 alphabet and we
have viruses killing microbes so we have
the microbial populations dropping we
have a little bit more of e-dna going
into the environment so viruses are
contributing to the e-dna environment
not by killing the host and their
necromancer going out there
but then we see maybe the community
stabilizing where we have this arms race
where viruses are killing micro bringing
the population down that micro becomes
resistant to the virus so then it can
start increasing so we kind of get this
leveling of the e-dna in the environment
and when we actually compare
where is this edna coming from so on
this other figure i have here i have our
viral populations on the y-axis and i
have a microbial populations on the
x-axis and then the dots represent
who does the e-dna belong to and the
majority of it if you look at our line
that i provided for you actually belongs
to the microbes so they're coming from
these microbes that are being killed or
the microbes could be exuding it to
build biofilms and survive
okay so i want to
make sure i have enough time to give
everyone questions but one last thing i
wanted to talk about before going into
my astrobiology shout outs is i want to
talk about other ways besides
bioinformatics and omics that you can
look at viruses and look at detection of
life
so nanosims which is nanoscale secondary
ion mass spectroscopy this is where we
can use a beam to destroy
a substrate a particle something and we
reconstruct it into a picture so we've
been pushing to be able to look at
viruses this way and what's cool is we
can have nano sims on a rover to go
somewhere else and we can actually see
things that are alive or that we
consider alive
um so i have here some tem images where
we've been purifying to look at viruses
so we have this sifuvir day it's a cut
of varieties it's a double-stranded dna
bacteriophage that we were able to see
with the nano stems and then we are on
team and then we put on the nano sims on
the top right we've been able to see
these other cool filamentous um viruses
these really cool ones
and the specialty about seeing something
within anderson's is you can physically
see it so you know it's there it's not
just a dot or something that we have to
infer you're seeing it that it's there
but also we can add in isotopes to
actually see if it's active so here we
use the 13c so we know where carbon is
incorporated in the virus and we know
that the virus is active as well so you
might have heard about the viking
missions in the past we've come so far
since then so this is exciting stuff to
think about for the future
okay so my quick shout out
is that we really wanted to push viruses
and astrobiology and really get
astrobiology you don't have to be
someone who studies viruses to get into
it there's no correct or direct path to
be an astrobiologist if you study life
in any form whether it's physics
chemistry biology you can become an
astrobiology to care about the questions
you're asking
so we did a white paper to increase
awareness and funding for viruses and
that's available now if you want to go
to the link
and this is really just how to
incorporate viruses into astrobiology
and we had questions that we asked
and what was really cool is i got to
work with penny boston which was the
former head of the nasa astrology
institute i'm ken stedman's who is at
portland state university and my good
friend catherine bywaters
we also so that was already published we
also wanted to change our framing and
get other people to be excited about
astrobiology as well so the first one is
everything viruses viruses are cool
usually viruses as well our second one
which i hear in the bottom which we're
calling viruses as modulators of
cellular metabolism this is specifically
how we can use viruses
for long-term space travel or short-term
on space travel and what are the effects
on human beings of viruses or even on
keeping our ecosystem viruses infect
plants so how do viruses affect plants
in space viruses and technology that
we're using to clean up our waste or
make food they also affect us or if we
come back we need to understand this
viruses are also really small and
they've been detected even in our clean
rooms so we also have to think about
viruses for planetary protection as well
so that's one that we submitted last
fall and so hopefully to be published
this year so just keep an eye out for
that
i also wanted to point out that in 2019
nai funded our astrovirology workshop
without walls this is a free two day
event that we did spaced out over two
parts of the day to really engage the
whole world so i have a map here of
everyone that was active during it but
i've had many people from other
countries reach out to me that was
helpful so both of them are available on
youtube you can watch the whole thing
the questions everything is there we've
tried to organize into two themes but
everything's about viruses on earth and
the potential for space and how viruses
can have all this different nucleic acid
so i implore you to please check it out
um email me if you have questions i'd
love to get feedback on it hopefully we
can do more workshops like that in the
future
uh the final thing i wanted to say is
we're going to abs icon this may
grandson he's going to be there i'm
going to be there as well please come
see us please join our session we have
two amazing speakers dr rachel whitaker
and olivia negro and we're talking about
viruses
everything viruses and what's cool is at
the end of the
session we're gonna have kind of a town
hall with all the speakers to really
discuss where the field is going what
are questions you have how you get in
the field where do we need to push to
really get people to start thinking
about viruses
whether you consider them alive or not
is semantics they are integral to life
as far as we know they've been here
since life if not before life so when
we're looking for life why not look for
the most abundant thing that's related
to life the most abundant biologically
which are viruses
with that i just want to acknowledge
the diverse teams i'm working with at
berkeley jgi
lawrence um lawrence berkeley national
lab lawrence livermore national lab uh
we have our science focus area grant
that i'm working on um i also want to
do fun talk about funding from
uh our ldrd these hybrids hard work have
really pushed our science and have been
foundational for really understanding
viruses and all ecosystems
i also would just want to do a land
acknowledgement for where our studies
are taking place and the people have
took care of those lands before we got
there and are taking care of them now so
we appreciate that
um and then i want to end the question
so here i have a nice diagram that penny
boston made about you know viruses are
not considered life sometimes they're
not incorporated into the tree of life
because we use a marker gene that
viruses don't have
viruses infect all life viruses even in
fact viruses
so we need to be thinking small and
thinking viral
and with that i'll take questions
great thank you so much dr trouble that
was an amazing speech okay so we have a
few questions for you
um number one with such a small
proportion of reads mapped viruses how
do you know of the actual sequences
found with low coverage
that is a great question so
let's take a metagenome and let's say
you have a hundred percent of your data
this is the data you get these are what
we're going to call our reads
so less than two percent go to viruses
but if you actually look at traditional
soul imagine them depending on where
it's from and how they're doing it
not all those other reads are going to
be used either right
i said two percent less than two percent
assembled read so we have all these the
majority of reads actually not being
used because life is so diverse and so
complex that we just can't even tease it
apart
so then we're just looking at data that
we can assemble so that we are aware of
okay so looking at this usable data
how do we know
if something's virus enough it has low
coverage well we need to increase our
coverage so that was why i traditionally
pushed for the viral approach and really
looking at the biomes and then
you're saying for those one few viruses
that we get from metagenome how do we
know that those have coverage well
that's that's what's tricky is
in a metagenome you're also getting host
right so a virus can be integrated into
a host
when it's integrating a host if that
host is highly abundant
every time its genome is duplicated the
virus's genome is also duplicated so if
the host is highly abundant the virus is
also highly abundant so when i say less
than two percent go to viruses
the ones that do go to viruses go to
those highly abundant viruses
so we get low diversity
but we get high coverage or relatively
high coverage of them
now
you're right though it's it's hard
especially with variance
in either a technology or that just
exists within populations how do we know
what is and what isn't
so a lot of times we get incomplete
genomes where we're just recovering the
parts of the genome that have a lot of
coverage or we use great tools out there
um simon rooney made virus order which
is one of my favorites and now there's
viewer sorter too that really look for
hallmark genes or parts
that relate to a virus like strand virus
or short genes to really say hey this is
a virus and it gives you confidence and
rules with that as well
um
but yeah where it to really increase the
resolution of viruses you have to
decrease the complexity of the sample i
had tried virums before i'm now using
stable isotope probing there's so many
other methods out there that we can push
to really increase our resolution on
viruses there's now single cell genomics
there's microfluidics being used
arguably you could
use a tem to try to look at part of a
sample i mean there there's so many
different ways we can do and i hope that
answers your question
yes thank you
um the next question is has there been
any evidence to suggest that there are
archaea that associate with viruses and
soils
oh absolutely yeah sorry
it seems biased here that i'm like
bacteria bacteria bacteria
um i just want to step back and say
most of the viruses we see in soils are
bacteriophage which are viruses that
infect bacteria and most of them are
double-stranded dna viruses
and if you think about metogenomics in
our sequencing we were set up to look at
what we thought of his life so this is
humans plants fungi bacteria they have
double-stranded dna genomes
so our sequencing technology is set up
for that so it's no chance that like
this is why we do it this is why we have
double stranded dna viruses right this
is why we can easily see them more
easily
so
there are ways out there which you can
start to get a single strand of dna
viruses i had published some papers that
way we have to really think about when
we're prepping our samples for
sequencing and thinking about that
single stranded dna or you know if
you're thinking about relicting or
ancient dna the highly rated dna is also
usually single stranded so if you think
about them as the same single stranded
dna viruses in line with e-dna you kind
of are going to find methods to help you
get that
finding rna environments is really
difficult so there hasn't been a lot of
work with meta transcriptomes and i've
been trying to push that others have as
well um
that's one day we're going to get an rna
viral to really look at the encapsulated
rna viruses if they are the majority out
there
so
yeah i i
know can you rephrase the question or
say it again so i can make sure i
answered it
yeah just asking about um like archaea
associated with our systems i was going
off on intelligence
so sorry everything was set up towards
bacteriophage so for archaea they also
have viruses but
what we know about viruses that largely
come from isolates and we can eat more
easily grow bacteria compared to archaea
so we also have more isolates on viruses
and bad bacteria so we know more about
them so i talked about veer sorter
before well it looks for enrichment of
genes for cautions which are
bacteriophage so they also push towards
our kill or sorry bacterial viruses
we have found some great archaeal
viruses um ken steadman has done it in
hot springs which are not soils but you
get some cool lemon shaped ones
um we know they exist in soils there are
some previous papers um i'm trying to
think of the names right now there are
that we know that they're there
why we don't see them as much
people have said oh archaea have
more christopher's or less crispers
you've heard of both ways they they're
less abundant so viruses don't care
about them
i really just think it's it's our
sampling um they are there but we know
very little about them especially in
soils as you probably know that if we're
going to find them it's usually in hot
springs or these other aquatic
sorry i i hope i could answer that
answer your question but there's not
much more i can give you on that
yes definitely no thank you
um okay so i have one more question for
you
would you consider virus to be life's
fail-safe against mass extinction or are
there more of an intermediate step that
have found a new way to propagate
so let me make sure i got this right the
fail-safe against mass extinction in
terms of the virus controlling these
populations to make sure everyone else
has a fair share
um so if i think of it in that way
i would say yes and no i mean i don't
think anything's engineered that way i
think you have
a biological entity that is selfish it
wants to replicate so it goes after the
most food
if you had a buffet out
that maybe that's not the best
comparison but because yeah
you you're more likely to go where
there's resources so i guess a better
comparison would be if you knew you had
to survive somewhere for three days and
we had
a beach that was barren or desert land
and then you had a condo here with all
the amenities you would choose a condo
with the amenities because you want to
make sure you're caring for your progeny
your offspring you want to make sure
they're still going so viruses i think
have just evolved
to kill the most abundant i don't know
if it is a way for nature to control
itself
i mean there's the gaia hypothesis is
you know it's self-regulating this this
giant mega ecosystem
um and if you want to go down the road i
could agree with you that viruses are
doing a good job at keeping diversity at
regulating that now what's tricky though
is
they don't do it alone right the hosts
have to adapt to survive it was just up
to the viruses they would kill and make
a population go extinct right and in
cases where we have like phage therapy
that's kind of the goal we're trying to
get a population to go extinct so we're
also relying on the host to be able to
evolve to out-compete it so is that the
host that's the failsafe that it learned
its lessons coming back if we're gonna
um personify it
but i i don't know and then when it i
think you're leading to when it comes to
humans that gets more tricky because we
might conjugate we can think about
thinking we're self-aware
and we can change our actions so unlike
this microbe that that has to evolve
genetically to survive
we
can take stances where we can fend off
the virus right where we can stop the
thing that's trying to control us so
there's there's so many different ways i
don't want to go too far down that
rabbit hole but i know what you're
thinking and i don't think life is
malicious i think everything is trying
to do its best and the virus itself
wants to propagate and it wants to keep
itself happy so it's going where the
most resources are
definitely okay thank you very much of
course well that was again a great talk
by dr trouble
and now i think we are going to have our
prize distribution ceremony for the
poster session
yes thank you so much laura and thank
you so much dr gary for your wonderful
talk
now let me share my screen
and the participants who can switch on
their cameras it would be great if they
can because it would be nice if we all
could applaud all the winners together
okay
so we have had a lot of uh abstract
submissions we then finalized some of
them as the posters that we wanted to
have it up in the competition
and we have three categories the first
category is for best technical and
research project on a competitive topic
and the award goes to
it's for pond raj vidanganam and her
topic was a microbiome of four different
lung diseases a comparative 16s rna
metagenomics to understand the diversity
and functional profiles so
congratulations brenda can you please
turn on your camera and say a few words
i think we need to give for the
permissions
hello can you hear me
yes we can hear you
yeah thank you very much and thank you
omic logics and all the judges to
recognize my work it was a great
pleasure to present in this
international symposium where i got
opportunity to learn and explore recent
advancement in bioinformatics from
scientists across the globe thank you
very much and thank you everyone
thank you so much brenda and
congratulations once again
and
the second prize was a tie between two
groups and the first
uh
person who has got the second position
for most promising research direction
for future potential is dr iman and dr
iman's research topic
was on racial disparities in thyroid
cancer biomarker testing does
one-size-fits-all
congratulations dr emman can we here can
we hear it from hi hi can you hear me
yes speaking okay
i'm so delighted to receive the word at
this research uh symposium for 2012 and
i'm really humbled and encouraged by
this recognition but really i can't
emphasize enough that i would achieve
nothing without my best mentors in
college their hard work dedication and
innovation are a pleasure to be part of
so it was a great opportunity now to
share a bit of within one minute my
experience if you can allow me for that
it's um okay during my research
fellowship in buying bi-tech i was so
grateful to learn new things every
single day
stepping from diving into amex to
actively engage into real life research
and that was really amazing for me being
able to complete the work connecting the
dots inspired even by other ideas how to
improve myself so with the current the
problem is and challenge is the seldens
of omix's study that's available online
and published each year it's becoming
more difficult to wait through the sea
of information to achieve insight and
make new discoveries that will be the
basics for your future grants and
projects and that's why scientists even
those who are non-specialists need to
have minimum knowledge skills and tools
to interpret this eminence amount of
data on what has been done before
understand how this is related to your
own data that would be
saving money and time so i'm supporting
those not only specialists in the
genetics or bioinformaticians to be
enrolled in this fellowship but also all
other specialities even clinicians even
and non-scientists because minimum
knowledge of these will upgrade your uh
your research activities so while my
primary research interest was oncology
to understand disease answer to risks
and progression i would like to pinpoint
that there was other opportunities to
learn other cross-omics domains like
metagenomics genomic fiction as we say
as we saw in these two days so it's like
a multi-disciplinary opportunity in a
single part i've witnessed continuous
improvement in the content of the
courses during the last six months i get
this is
based on the continuous feedback of the
research fillers and i even learned from
the experience of other fellows in the
troubled shooting they faced through the
weekly uh research fellowship meeting
that was very fruitful so you have now
availability the courses the projects
the programs that is available in the
omics logics and the super pipeline had
the potential to accelerate our research
goals
from just discovery new target
identification validation to drug
repositioning to uh to cross over and
saving lives so at this end i would like
to thank everyone even those behind us
in like cinelika for supporting me in
the long journey and i'm i'm thankful to
my mentors who i kept sending a lot of
questions all the time day and night and
they kept replying back so thank you so
much for supporting me in this learning
journey and i hope everyone else got
enrolled soon and enjoyed this
experience like what i have busted
through thank you so much
thank you so much dr emman these are
very kind words and it feels good to
hear about the research fellows
experience that they could learn so much
and gain a lot from this program
congratulations once again and the
second prize was tie as i told you all
so the next group that is also uh
selected for the most promising research
direction for future potential
uh goes to mr ojasi
and their project was on effects of
microgravity on high psc's cardiac and
muscle activity so this was a group
project uh between just the instagram so
can we have them both
yes oh just see i can see you
we'll just see what would you like to uh
say
so i want to thank like everyone here
and especially agave and india
so
like without their guidance and support
we could not have completed this project
and they pushed us a lot to complete
this and
thank you so much alika for making me
join find biotech and
like this was a great journey for me
till now here and
i have not so i like like i have learned
so many things from starting from
transcriptomic analysis and ending to
the astrobiology project so i have done
like what i feel is this is this is the
really amazing uh time for me today and
i am
grateful to receive this award
good to hear that congratulations oh
justine and what about you sugar are you
here with us
i saw him
i think you need to yes he is
yes hi sugar
hello kiki has a background showing that
he has an astrobiology project that's
amazing yeah
so i would like to thank say my uh ilia
and dr raghav andrew for their um
support
and obviously your omics logic and fine
grab tech to join to make me join as a
research fellow
and this malika as well
and thank you everyone
who helped me in this research
fellowship and
thank you to all judges
amazing very good uh keep it up and
congratulations once again both of you
and now let's see who has got the third
position for most innovative approach in
an established domain
it's
annually and his project was on a cell
type specific machine learning and
protein interaction approach to identify
autism risk genes
and also to add here andrew uh
uh the first prize in the last symposium
and he has been doing amazing jobs with
with respect to his projects all the
time so we are pleased to have you with
us once again and congratulations are
you here with us andrew
he's there like
yes uh andrew we can't hear you
okay so uh meanwhile andrew one mutes
himself let's do one thing can we have
a group photograph with all the uh
winners and also the participants if
they can turn on their cameras it would
be amazing so we can capture some
beautiful moments from this
session
i think i need to
okay so who all do we have searching on
their cameras andrew
are you here with us
thank you thank you everyone
so with this we are good to go ahead for
the next session and now i'll pass on
the stage to laura to take the session
ahead over to you laura
thank you so much and congratulations to
all those those winners
um
let me share my screen
okay so our next speaker is mr elliot
brodsky
mr brodsky is one of the co-founders and
ceo of pine biotech
he has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams
mr brodsky oversees the research
projects and manages the development of
the prototype preparation of relevant
data projects and implementation of the
system for the needs of the students and
teachers that the project is designed
for so please join me in welcoming mr
ellia brodsky
thank you very much again
congratulations to everyone and it's
really exciting to see how all of this
actually connects and i'm really pleased
to be a part of this symposium today
and what i want to share with you today
is actually how we're going to uh
continue and expand the omics logistics
program
so what we saw
in the past couple of days
are the multiple directions that
bioinformatics can play a role from
precision medicine to
pharmaceutical companies biotechnology
companies astrobiology
origins of life right it's not really a
domain specific discipline but it
empowers researchers in many different
directions and so what i want to talk to
you about today is uh first how did we
establish this program in the first
place where it's going and specifically
focus on one aspect
which is the program that we're
developing together with the national
association of idea principal
investigators
so the national association of idea
principal investigators is a
network of idea-funded
pis
idea program is an nih specific
program designed to elevate biomedical
research and so what
is common
across all of these different states
that you see on the map
is that they don't receive as much
funding as some of the hubs
but i think that actually speaks to a
general problem that is also beyond the
united states
unfortunately uh the money is not
equally distributed um across all
institutions
and so i think in the u.s it's exciting
to see how special allocation of funding
is making
a high-level
research possible in these states but if
you go to um you know we're located in
new orleans and louisiana right here uh
and and if you kind of compare how
things are done here
you might see a lot of differences
between let's say what's happening
in boston massachusetts san diego or san
francisco and what's happening here
and
similar to what you know others
experience around the world
there is a challenge to attract talent
and there's a challenge to
make this talent work together focusing
on local problems
and accelerating research that addresses
local issues and that is what this
program is specifically designed to do
the funding the idea funding is really
designed to help establish
sequencing centers cores
really
enabling technologies so that other
researchers that are striving to pursue
advanced topics in different areas of
research especially biomedical research
can be successful and across all of
these states there is a need in
bioinformatics
so
over the course of the past just several
months we've started a pilot with the
national idea uh national association of
idea principal investigators to design
a resource and implement uh programs to
support training in biology as a data
sign so i'll briefly talk about omics
logic uh for anyone who's here and who's
not heard about it uh previously
so omix omixlogic is a portal designed
to
kind of combine multiple things that we
saw today
and it starts from a portal that you can
find on this link learn
omixlogic.com uh you can register for
free and uh you
become a part of the community once you
register it's a free registration you
get access to not only free resources
but importantly a network that we're
building and i think a network that you
have seen today that combines experts
students faculty
researchers and others
and importantly what this portal allows
us to do is it allows us to combine
the learning and the research
around a personal profile so in the
personal profile we've designed elements
like sharing about your background
connecting your social media tracking
your progress of learning
badges for different programs that you
complete and it allows the faculty to
see
how the progress in your learning
matches with the objectives of whatever
the program
pursues
so importantly we've designed a
process of certification that actually
allows us to make sure that people when
they become interested in a particular
area of research are actually ready and
prepared and informed to apply
bioinformatics in a meaningful way and
so after you receive this basic
certification then the next step is to
make sure that your profile is complete
and you're able to pursue your research
topic your idea so some of the projects
that we saw yesterday in the poster
presentation uh today we had uh dr
emantoria
and uh jesse so they were a part of the
research fellowship and actually many
many more students participate in this
process every semester
attempting to complete
novel independent or group projects
using publicly available data and so
we've built this format because we think
that you know beyond certification and
kind of basic skills really the
validation that you know something is
when you can apply it to something of
your own and because bioinformatics is
such a diverse and dynamic field because
natural interests are so different we
cannot design programs around everything
and so we're opening it up for anyone
who would like to pursue a project to
really be able to do that in a
reproducible way
so once that is done
uh we um are actually uh going to
do uh biannual events like this one to
bring the community together select the
most promising projects and
one of the things that we would like to
do is actually turn those projects into
opportunities for others to learn so
it's not just a way to learn and develop
your own research it's also a way to
contribute and share what you have done
with the broader network and the
community
beyond this
with this expanding library and i want
to pause here by the way and say that uh
one of our objectives in the next few
months is to open this platform to other
contributors and we've started working
with several programs around the nepe uh
southeastern region
to start working on new materials to add
to the library that we've developed so
far
and this is going to be around several
different basic topics like genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics or
epigenomics
data science and a general free course
that we're going to make available for
anyone to kind of take and use as they
need
called introduction to bioinformatics or
bytes and molecules
and so um that is really uh one aspect
that i wanted to highlight today
is that
um you know one of our missions as a
company is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
make it easier to participate in make it
easier to
apply practically
and make it easier for someone who does
not have any technical background
to really benefit from it as soon as
possible so in a faster uh way to kind
of appreciate the role and the meaning
of bioinformatics and so for that we are
creating this free resource anyone can
use it uh anyone can uh you know as a
faculty uh use it as a resource for
teaching
um and in fact we're going to start a
partner program
that will allow um for the more advanced
topics to follow after this brief
and maybe optional introduction
and one of the things that we're going
to include in this package is not just
the the basic modules like introduction
to bioinformatics or bytes and molecules
or getting started with bioinformatics
and are in python but it importantly uh
provide a view of these many different
topics like we heard in the past couple
of days
how is bioinformatics used in
precision medicine
how is bioinformatics used in
astrobiology how is bioinformatics used
in pharmaceutical companies uh drug
discovery you know all of these topics
uh they are uh the things that drive
bioinformatics forward right so
bioinformatics i think is not driven by
just computational and algorithmic
innovation but primarily it is driven by
people that understand the data
challenges that these domains bring
and so another part of what we um are
really passionate about as a company is
not just the diversity of bioinformatics
applications but also how
these bioinformatics methods and tools
are used by experts so um obviously uh
it is great when we can have speakers
like her today and yesterday come and
present a topic that they have been
studying for decades
but i think it's equally important to
appreciate that even these presentations
are based on a
hypothesis that has been addressed in
some way with evidence
but also reviewed by peers by the
broader community and so that's why the
key
we believe
is to focus on publications so these
peer-reviewed publications that we can
review and extract uh kind of the
methodology used by experts including
data that was submitted by them and made
publicly available is the foundation for
these courses and projects that we
develop on this portal
so the portal really provides six basic
courses
that anyone can
take and and kind of we standardize and
make sure that we improve uh the content
of these courses that include
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and an introduction into data science
and on top of the the basic level we
actually introduced specialization
tracks
and this is how
bioinformatics is used in oncology in
infectious diseases in neuroscience and
in agriculture and i'll talk a little
bit more about some of these upcoming
programs in the next few slides
what's important though is that as a
part of this coursework we have a
package of enabling technologies and
these enabling technologies are designed
to
again lower the barrier for entry
speed up the process
of going from base to more more complex
topics
and be able to identify the best track
that fits your
current stage and your objective in the
future
uh what do i mean by that
a lot of students
might be pursuing bioinformatics as a
degree
but i think an even greater proportion
of students are not directly interested
in bioinformatics and so for many as
we've seen yesterday especially this
interest in bioinformatics is something
that shapes over the years and so it's
not appropriate to dump all the
complexities and kind of the
requirements for coding languages and
statistics
right up front in that process and so
we try to present a variety of paths
that you can pursue
to be able to analyze data and make
discoveries which is the exciting part
and if you choose to do so enough depth
for you to also learn how to develop
your coding skills how to get certified
in different levels of biostatistics or
machine learning and even how to pursue
a more technical resource for cloud
computing for example as we will hear
today as well
so one uh
one important aspect of this is that we
have
code and no code bioinformatics pass and
that means that you can either perform
analysis using the big data analysis
t-biome for platform and we've heard
today about new sections on this
platform it's a dynamic place where
experts contribute new and more
efficient workflows as well as learn
languages like python and r to learn how
to program your own or use existing
packages
and so in a variety of domains i think
that you will see how bioinformaticians
range from biologists that are experts
in using these packages with
understanding of the different settings
with understanding of when to apply what
kind of methodology to answer a specific
question as well as those that go the
technical route and they are able to
engineer novel applications and make
these applications user friendly and
more efficient for discovery
so
with that i think that you know i'll
briefly now speak about several
different programs that are coming up
that you can participate in and we have
our team here with us so if you are
interested in any of these topics as a
faculty or as a student i encourage you
to reach out and at the end we will
share some of the contact information
for you to be able to connect with the
right person
so
i think there are exciting many new
ideas and challenges arising in the
field of gene expression and
transcriptomics and so traditionally
we've run a program called
transcriptomic data analysis or
rna-seq
where we explored bulk rna sequencing
and the volume of bulk rna sequencing
has really been growing over the years
so at the foundational level it was
always important to understand
what is rna sequencing how do these next
generation sequencing technologies work
what are some important methods to
explore and understand this kind of data
design statistical hypothesis testing
techniques
and
as of recent it's been really important
to also understand the differences
between bulk rna sequencing and single
cell rna sequencing which is a
technology that is becoming more and
more popular and applicable in many
different domains so we've designed a
program
and standardized it to include some
specific aspects that can be taught
either in a short
setting where face-to-face students meet
or supplement that with a synchronous
training exercises that one can complete
both on the omixlogic portal
and utilizing the t-biome for platform
so for that we again have a section
section is color-coded and explained and
it really covers how you can
analyze data from understanding the
inputs and outputs to the logic behind
the analysis that is color coded and
explained in detail why do we have to
perform each one of the individual steps
and i think what we've seen as a result
of doing this program multiple times is
how this approach helps students
appreciate how
any kind of analysis can be structured
in a very logical way
after they understand the logic we then
introduce a variety of different types
of projects where they can see the
application of rna sequencing techniques
in oncology in precision medicine in
infectious diseases and epidemiology
with the popularity of single cell um
we've seen
a
kind of like an expectation that this is
just exactly the same as bulk rna
sequencing and it really is not there
are a lot of new methods there are a lot
of specific approaches and a lot of
emphasis is put on downstream
interpretation and so as we have heard
today
now we have a full section that kind of
automates and simplifies the downstream
analysis of single cell rna seq data
using such packages like silverad
and monocle and importantly it we
provide a step-by-step breakdown of each
one of these logical steps
using exercises that you can perform
independently and i'm excited to say
today that this course is also available
and anyone can find that course on the
onyx logic portal
obviously supplementing the basic
training with project examples is a big
uh part of what we are trying to do and
so we take these
publications that have an impact
in this domain and we break down the
methodology proportion and really
describe how one can
analyze such data and replicate an
analysis found in a publication
with so many different types of omics
data now it's important to not only
understand how to process analyze and
visualize a single type of data but
importantly integrate multinomics data
as well and that's a big part of what we
do on this portal is introduce
multi-omics integration methods that
could be contrasted and compared and
applied in specific domains with a
benchmark so an important part of what
we do in the projects are curated data
sets that one can use to establish an
understanding and really test how well
you apply the methods to get the same
results
as we've seen over the past two years
infectious diseases from
being kind of a domain that suffered
from a lack of funding
became a domain with exciting new
research
and applications that touched the lives
of all of us today and so back in 2000
back in 2020 we launched our
bioinformatics for infectious
diseases program
and we quickly adapted that program to
address the challenges around covet 19
so that not only we're able to
understand pathogens and kind of study
those pathogens using project examples
but also think about applications
and i'll briefly kind of mention a
couple of these applications that we've
seen
resulting from
this program
so as a result of understanding the
methodology and seeing how next
generation sequencing can be used to
study these viruses and and different
types of infectious diseases
we have developed a number of
collaborations around wastewater
sequencing of cobit 19
monitoring variants of concern and other
types of kind of strange phenotypes that
have been reported in literature
and i think that you know this kind of
interest in bioinformatics as a result
of the pandemic
of course the pandemic in itself was an
unfortunate event that we're still not
out of but i think it really gave a lot
of popularity
to
terminology methods and even types of
data
that will in the future
i think this generation that went
through this uh pandemic uh will uh be
so aware and so familiar with some of
the methodology that they
will be able to address uh future
challenges of similar character in a
much more effective way
and so uh we've uh designed several
project examples a variety of different
viral
epidemics
and an in-depth training resource for
sars cove 2
where both consensus level and
sub-consensus level analysis could be
performed
not only at the sequence level but
importantly also translating the
sequence level to the immunology and to
the protein protein interaction level so
looking at 3d structures of proteins and
understanding how
they have an effect on vaccine design
and protein protein interaction
and so really at the core of this i
again want to emphasize how significant
it is
that this is available not only for
engineers
the team bound for platform really hides
the complexity of analytical pipelines
and complex algorithms that have been
developed by experts in the field
to make it possible for someone who's a
student
or a biologist or a biochemist to apply
these complex methods and understand how
they are used with practical examples
so methods like processing faster and
fast q files for multiple sequence of
alignment and comparative analysis of
different sequences
reporting uh generating a full report on
uh variants of concern found in
different types of viral populations
understanding how this data can be
visualized effectively and presented
and also importantly as i mentioned
mapping the mutations that we identify
and understanding how they impact uh
different aspects of immunology
uh during this these exercises that we
actually also
look at protein protein interaction
really trying to understand uh the
available resources uh like protein
crystallography but also how to connect
the different types of data
and really understand uh the the way
that multiple sources of data could be
used together
now yesterday we spoke with uh dr sona
vasudevan from georgetown university
medical school where she leads a program
on systems medicine and together with
her team and her students we've
developed this program specifically to
introduce a non-engineer to the basics
of data science and machine learning
using r and python
i think that it's a very critical skill
for anyone to learn how to code and i
think that it's
non-trivial for someone who doesn't come
from an engineering background to do so
but
we've seen
how these resources can make it much
easier for someone to learn how to code
quickly and develop a practical sense of
the application of languages like r and
python to address bioinformatics
challenges and so the exercises that we
have available on the the portal
include uh mapping mutations for
metabolism of different drugs
uh really learning how to code uh from a
syntax perspective from the perspective
of data visualization
and the application to many different
types of data such as genomic data
analysis metagenomic data analysis as
well as
different types of big data
repositories that could be explored and
visualized using such tools
um
to uh you know summarize i think that
you know what we have seen is an
explosion of
interest in
different domains
starting from you know very basic usage
of genomics in the lab
to
such interesting concepts like space
onyx
and
when i mentioned that we're opening this
platform to other contributors this is
really what i am implying
in different universities and different
labs and in different research fields
experts have dedicated
years if not decades of their life to
identifying important topics and
learning how to
address them in a reproducible and high
quality way
and we would like to kind of establish a
way for those
experts to be able to take their
expertise
and
allow us to design high quality training
materials that could help effectively
many of the people that are
locked out of these domains
to be able to participate by first
learning about these topics and then
knowing how to apply their skills and
their insights and innovation and maybe
creative thinking to address the topics
that are
pressing and urgent in each one of these
domains
so we have these programs
on cancer biology precision medicine
space omics and and many others and
we're excited to
share with you that you know these
types of programs have already impacted
hundreds of students in louisiana
thousands of students around the world
and we're hoping that many more across
the national association of idea
principal investigator network as we are
completing our first pilot which um
lasted from january until the end of
march so until yesterday
so with that um i am going to be um
available to answer any questions uh if
anyone had
any questions uh i'm going to share my
email address if you would like to reach
out me
i'd love to talk to you about these
programs i've shared my email in the
chat
we will have a few more speakers from
nepe
speaking about
different efforts that we're going to
kind of combine into this program as
well
and
i thoroughly enjoyed
seeing some of the results
that
we have seen and i think that is really
the
demonstration of what we are trying to
do some of the research projects that
we've seen from the students
so thank you again
uh yes uh laura back over to you
great
so
we
are still waiting on one of our speakers
so dr crabtree are you available to
speak right now
i am we can go ahead and go if you'd
like
great okay let me introduce
dr judy crabtree
okay
so
please welcome dr judy crabtree
dr crabtree received her phd training in
biochemistry and genetics from the
university of oklahoma in one of the
original labs that was funded to
sequence the human genome
she did her postdoctoral work at the
national human genome research institute
at the national institute of health in
bethesda maryland
under the direction of dr francis
collins studying the biology of an
endocrine tumor disease called multiple
endocrine neoplasia type 1.
from there she entered the world of
pharmaceutical drug development at wyeth
pharmaceuticals
in 2009 she left the pharmaceutical
industry and join lsu hsc as an
assistant professor of genetics
she is currently an associate professor
of genetics and the scientific and
education director of the precision
medicine program at lsu hsc
more recently in the pandemic she
implemented the covid testing program
for the
lsu hsc campus and has launched the
viral sequencing efforts to track
covered variants of concern in southern
louisiana
so please join me in welcoming dr judy
crabtree
thank you laura
so i'm gonna share my screen now
get me set up
oh come on
okay
so thank you for this opportunity i mean
this has just been a great meeting the
past two days we've seen so many great
talks and posters i'm very excited
and so um what's interesting though is
as i was preparing this talk
i realized that today is 25 years to the
day since i started my postdoc and so i
had just finished uh my phd work under
the direct direction of dr bruce rowe at
the university of oklahoma where we were
sequencing regions of human chromosome
22 as part of the human genome project
and on april 1st 1997 i began my
post-doctoral study at the nih under the
direction of dr francis collins now i
can tell you if you've never started a
new job on april fool's day it is quite
the experience
and so as the new green postdoc i was
immediately the april fool and the easy
target of many practical jokes in my new
lab
but what i didn't realize at that point
was that this was the beginning of a
translational career built on genomics
and its application to human health and
so i was fortunate to not only
contribute sequencing data to the human
genome project but to also be in the
epicenter of human genomic research in
the us upon completion of the human
genome reference sequence in 2003
so at that time i was infused with
optimism about what we could do to
understand human health and disease how
we can further understand what makes
each of us alike but also what makes
each of us different so how are we
different in our responses to
environmental stimuli to
pharmaceutical drugs to chemotherapy
and since this day in 1997 i've studied
cancer and performed large-scale
transcriptomic analyses
of several tumor and cancer syndromes
i've worked in the drug development and
pharmaceutical industry and then now
here we are 25 years later i'm
translating what i've learned in each of
these varied research environments to
supporting patient management in our cap
accredited clinical precision medicine
laboratory
now in order to understand the current
state of affairs with respect to
precision medicine we kind of need to
start at the beginning so i hope this
isn't repetitive to some people
um but it's always fun to look at
history so uh in the late 1980s a group
of scientific thought leaders that
included francis collins of the nih erie
petrinos from the u.s department of
energy eric lander from the broad
institute at mit and several others they
sat down over a pint of lager and
outlined on the back of cocktail napkins
a plan for mapping and sequencing the
complete human genome so this project
launched in 1990 and ultimately took 13
years to complete at a cost of about 2.7
billion dollars and so here you can see
the publications the cover the public
effort in nature and the competing
private effort in science
now the key thing that i want you to
remember is that the human genome
reference sequence is not the genome of
one individual it's a compilation from
the 20 anonymous individuals mostly
anonymous
further the 20 individuals were selected
from a pool of over a thousand donors
whose information was ultimately
de-identified so that even those who
contributed do not know if their dna was
used or not and so this was done
intentionally by the architects of the
human genome project to ensure that no
single person's genome was exclusively
represented and also so that no
individual could be identified by their
contribution to the reference genome
now once the reference genome was
complete this opened up a huge number of
questions about the genetic diversity of
humans and so one of the astonishing
facts from the human genome project was
that single nucleotide variants occur
approximately one every 300 nucleotides
so if you do the math that means there
are roughly 10 million single nucleotide
variants in the human genome and these
variations are one contributing factor
to the genetic diversity in humans
and so this opened up a whole new set of
questions so what is the intersection
between disease and genetic variants
what's the relationship between drug
metabolism and genetic variation is
there a cancer genome and does that
cancer genome change over time and in in
between the the primary tumor and a
metastasis or a recurrence um how does
the genome impact mental health
behavioral health um it had already been
observed that some diseases were more
prevalent in certain populations and so
then questions about what's the role of
genetic variation in ethnicity
and so over the years that followed the
completion of the human genome reference
sequence it became more and more clear
that we knew too little the genomic
community as a whole began a sort of
haphazard way um collecting information
we needed to answer some of the
questions about genetic variability but
as time went on the cost of full and and
as time went on the cost of whole genome
sequencing decreased so now it's
approaching a thousand dollars with a
turnaround time of seven to ten days and
so so now the big picture idea was that
if we can perform genomic testing um at
an acceptable cost get private insurance
and medicaid medicare buy-in to perform
genomic testing in the clinical setting
we can use this as evidence-based
medicine to identify the best
therapeutic and preventative
interventions to best benefit our
patients
and so to set this up in a more
organized fashion
we realized that there was a need for a
more concerted effort to understand
genomic variation so the nih announced
its support of precision medicine in
2015 when then president obama in his
state of the union address described
precision medicine as an emerging
approach to disease prevention and
treatment that takes into account
people's individual variations in genes
environment and lifestyle
so this was accompanied by a publication
in the new england journal of medicine
written by then director of the nih
francis collins and past director of the
national cancer institute harold barmus
this perspective further supported the
convictions of president obama that
science offers great potential for
improving human health and this
officially launched the nih precision
medicine initiative in 2015.
now a key part of the precision medicine
initiative is the all of us research
program
this was launched officially about four
years ago and this is a cornerstone of
the precision medicine initiative that
sinks to enroll one million or more
participants that represent the broad
diversity of the united states so that
we can understand variants much better
than we do
so patients will complete surveys
provide biological specimens for whole
genome sequencing and then grant access
if they choose to their medical records
for de-identified population-based
studies that correlate genetics and
genetic variants with disease and
environmental factors such as where you
live
now the all of us network is composed of
national partners in regional medical
centers across the u.s to enroll
participants from all walks of life and
all states of health within the united
states so just this month the all of us
research program hit a key milestone and
released the first set of nearly a
hundred thousand whole genome sequences
more than half of this new genomic
information comes from people who
self-identify with racial or ethnic
minority groups and that's extremely
important because until now more than 90
percent of participants in the large
genomic studies were all of european
descent and so this lack of diversity
has had huge impacts it deepens the
health disparities and hinders
scientific discovery from fully
benefiting everyone
so i do want to point out that lsu hsc
is a flagship institution in the
southern region of the all of us program
we affectionately call this program the
all of us network for those of you who
know about the southern dialect
and this is in collaboration with tulane
university the university of mississippi
medical center university of alabama
birmingham and other major institutions
across the gulf south
so this is the website where you can
learn more information about the all of
us program and there's still time to
join either through the website down
here or the app which looks like this
blue banner up in the upper left corner
once you've registered you can then make
an appointment to donate your sample for
sequencing
at one of our participating clinics
so all of this is going to contribute to
our understanding of the human genome
and how genetic variants can impact our
health
and so what i'd like to do now is share
a study with you that was one of the
first studies to come out in
phosgenetics in 2011 to show you the
predictive ability of precision medicine
and so this study used next generation
sequencing to evaluate human health in a
predictive way
i mean in this study the authors
performed whole genome sequencing of
four members of a family mom dad
daughter and son
and as an aside the family used in this
study is the west family and if you look
at the author list carefully you can see
john west and and west are both authors
on this study so john west was the ceo
of celexa at the time so this is the
company that developed the current next
generation sequencing technology that
was then sold to illumina and is now the
foundation for their current almost
market cornering technology for next
generation sequencing
and so this is the pedigree for the west
family if you aren't used to reading
pedigrees um the squares are males the
circles are females
horizontal lines indicate either a
marriage or siblings
and diagonal lines across the symbol
indicate that the individual is deceased
now the arrows indicate the four
immediate family members of the west
family so we have john his wife
the daughter anne and her brother and
note the multi-generational history of
cardiovascular and blood clotting
problems within this family so there are
several incidents of myocardial
infarction congestive heart failure deep
vein thrombosis and hypertension
john was
hospitalized twice with venous
thromboembolism in two separate
incidents um during the period of time
when he and his doctor were working out
the appropriate anticoagulant for him to
be taking for his condition
so the whole genome sequencing of this
family identified among other things
multiple variants and genes related to
blood clotting so this process utilized
two carefully curated databases verimed
which correlates genetic variants
associated with disease and pharmgkb
which catalogs genetic variants
associated with drug responses now there
are many such databases available now
these were just the first two that were
established at the time of the study
back in 2011.
now a blinded in a blinded
bioinformatics analysis of these data
the investigators were able to correctly
predict the type and the dose of the
anticoagulant that john was already
taking so he and his doctor had settled
on clopidogrel after an extensive period
of trial and error to get the dose and
drug um correct for one that worked for
him
now imagine if john had been screened
for known variants before he even took
any medication
well that's essentially what happened
for his daughter so the study predicted
what medication she may need in the
future based on her genetic profile and
interestingly the medication is
different from that her dad is taking
mostly because remember everybody
inherits two alleles and inherited one
risk allele from her father and a
different risk allele from her mother
so anne was 17 at the time of the study
and now she's 29 years old and has no
health problems as of yet because she
was able to implement some simple
lifestyle changes and increase her
surveillance to help mitigate her risk
for cardiovascular complications
so this is just one example of how
genomics can impact human health and
disease risk assessment
the second example is within oncology so
the field of oncology is leading the way
in precision medicine and targeted
therapies because the identification of
variants as biomarkers or targets of
disease has led to new targeted
therapies for patients with cancer
now past treatments
have all been focused on tissue specific
mechanisms or systemic therapies so for
example the traditional chemotherapies
such as microtubule inhibitors platinum
therapies and cyclophosphamides
these are all cytotoxic drugs that kill
all rapidly dividing cells and so there
are also other cancers such as
hormone-responsive breast cancer or
prostate cancers
that have obvious hormone dependence so
the first line of therapy in these
tumors is a systemic hormone deprivation
and the problem with all of these
systemic based chemotherapies is that
they often have some really miserable
side effects for the patient
and so more recent focus has been on
variance and the targeted therapies
as time has gone by and we learned more
and more about the molecular basis of
cancers and so shown here is non-small
cell lung cancer and melanoma and we
know that each of these com each of
these common cancers is actually a
collection of more rare cancers so for
example many cancers or many variants
have been detected in non-small cell
lung cancer including driver mutations
and the genes for uh things like egfr
braf mec-1 akt and p10
and then within within each of these um
driver mutations
there's individual variants that add
further complexity so for example within
the egfr mutations in non-small cell
lung cancer there are at least seven
known individual variants and in
melanoma it's similar the common driver
mutations are in the b raft gene
um and these include six individual
variants so imagine if we had drugs that
were specific for each of these
individual variants and how cool would
that be right
well and that's where we are albeit in
the very very early stages
right now the majority of the drugs that
are seeking and receiving fda approval
in oncology are targeted therapies that
are designed to hit specific molecular
targets that are divine defined by a
genomic variant so these new drugs
interrupt cancer cell proliferation but
in theory they leave other non-cancer
cells more intact with the goal of less
intense side effects for the patient
there are also new immunotherapies that
capitalize on the patient's immune
system to fight types of cancer with
specific genetic signatures
and so now the challenge
is can we identify all the variants that
impact disease and develop therapies
that work best for each of those
different disease-causing variants so
the all of us research program will help
with that in the us and similar programs
are in place in other countries
and we also have to start to convince
big pharma to change their strategy and
begin to develop targeted therapies for
newly identified variants
instead of seeking that next billion
dollar blockbuster drug
now in the clinical setting we identify
dna variants in a variety of ways
we can look we can use a single gene
sequencing analysis to look for germline
mutations in particular genes such as
bracha one or two
we can do screenings for variants in the
genes that are metabolic enzymes such as
the cytochrome p450 enzymes that are
responsible for drug metabolism in the
liver and we can perform gene panels
such as oncotype dx or mammoprint with
that contain smaller number of genes to
identify variants and predict tumor
recurrence
in some particular tumor types
or we can do what we're doing at the lsu
hsc clinical precision medicine
laboratory which is focus on the next
generation sequencing based approaches
so this includes tso500 whole exome
sequencing and whole genome sequencing
so our initial approach for tso500 uh
will will support solid tumors and then
we'll expand into hematological
malignancies
and then we'll implement hereditary
cancer screening risk identification and
some non-invasive prenatal testing or
nipt
all of which runs on the same next
generation sequencing platform and so
this testing is one of the pillars of
support for our future bid for nci
cancer center designation in the region
and so this is the instrument we have
from illumina called the next c550dx
this instrument is currently in use for
genomic sequencing of sars cov2 for code
19
but we will be pivoting soon to run
tso500 which is a panel that contains
523 oncology related genes
and you can see some of those listed
here along with the different types of
cancer with which they are affiliated
this panel also provides an assessment
of microsatellite instability and
defects in mismatch repair
these support the use of checkpoint
inhibitor therapies
as well as overall tumor mutational
burden which is an indicator of
immunotherapy treatment success
so the way it works in our laboratory is
we have tests that are ordered by a
physician um
our pathology partners uh review the
sample and submit the tumor and normal
samples for sequencing in the lab we
process those samples perform library
generation and put them on the sequencer
and then the large amounts of raw data
that result from the next seek are run
through quality assurance quality
control and base calling algorithms to
convert those raw image data files into
a text file format you guys have already
heard about fastq
um and there are also the associated
fred quality scores that are associated
with each face
and then following this base calling the
sequencing reads are aligned with the
reference genome and resulting in a bam
file
map sequences are then used
to identify variants and result in a
variant call format or vcf
so we partner with puri and dx for this
service and their algorithms identify
and prioritize single nucleotide
variants based on multiple criteria
these include variant allele frequency
strand bias sequencing depth in the gene
region quality scores etc as well as it
draws from their extensive database of
patient outcomes from other nci
designated cancer centers nationwide to
recommend treatment strategies so the
identified variants are annotated
as to the gene and location that's the
avcf file and then they're often
manually curated to ensure accuracy
quality and adherence to the current
current nomenclature and naming
conventions
so all of this data is distilled into a
report that's integrated into the emr
the electronic medical record and it's
made available for tumor board review
and for clinical decision making
so those sample reports look like this
so it has patient information at the top
and then it has a listing of the
variants that are identified in the
analyze sample
so there's also information about the
responsiveness of this tumor with or a
tumor with this profile to certain drugs
and you can see that here in the middle
as well as the opportunities for
clinical trials that are associated with
this type of variant and so we can set
the distance parameters to limit
available clinical trials to within so
many miles of the patient um mostly for
convenience sake
and then down here at the bottom you can
see the results for tumor mutational
burden which is really the emerging
marker associated with greater
sensitivity of a tumor to
immunotherapies and also microsatellite
instability status which when high this
this example is low but when it's high
it predicts sensitivity to immune
checkpoint inhibitors
so all of this leads us to the precision
medicine ideal of delivering the right
drug to the right patient at the right
time and so right now we're sort of in
this top level here where we have
patients receiving a drug
and then there's a small proportion of
those patients who actually respond
what we'd like to do is get to this
stage at the bottom where we have a
different drug for different genetic
variants that are available within the
oncology and another space this doesn't
necessarily have to be only oncology
driven um even though oncology is
leading the way um but this is where we
want to go where we get the right drug
and the right patient at the right time
and so with that all i'd like to thank
you for your attention and this
opportunity and i'd be happy to answer
any questions
thank you so much dr crabtree that was
an amazing presentation thank you okay
we have a few questions for you
the first one is how much data is being
generated by your lab at lsu hsc
so is it just genomic data or is in smp
data or do they also generate other
types of data so right now the only data
being generated in our laboratory is
viral sequences for sars code v2
we are not currently running uh the
ts0500 we are not currently doing whole
genome or whole exome sequencing that is
our next
the next endeavor
mostly just because we kind of got
derailed to do sequencing for sars kobe
2 and we have yet to pivot
that makes sense okay our next question
is how many people are you planning to
get sequence data from in the state of
louisiana and also just in the south in
general
sequence data
for um
whole genome whole exome
or is this the question of how many
samples are we going to run
how many samples are you going okay so
once tso is up and running so this the
instrument that we have is a moderate
throughput
instrument there's one bigger
that we do not yet have but we can
always buy if we end up having more
samples to process
our laboratory is not going to only
support lsu it's going to support the
entire region and so at the moment we
have the capacity in our current
instrument to run
eight tumors normal pairs per week
um
but then you know as as need and demand
increases we can always scale that up
got it uh and then one final question
what originally inspired you to become
involved in genomics
so this is kind of a cool study so
very cool a story so i uh
i had a science teacher named jim martin
and he would die if he knew i was
telling the story
back when i was in high school we were
in basic biology
and he gave each of us a laminated piece
of paper that had either a circle on the
end or a triangle on the end
and some of us had the points and some
of us had the correlating v right and so
essentially what he handed out to the
whole class was nucleotides and he lined
us up in the hallway and some of us were
the parental strand and then others of
us came in and formed the replicating
strand
and so that was really my first
introduction
to
to dna and
anything having to do with dna
sequencing
and so he taught us dna replication in
the hallway the high school and and so
that was really you know that was many
many years ago but um that was really my
first introduction to to dna and it's
kind of stuck ever since then gene
therapy you know i'm i've got a huge
interest in not only dna sequencing and
genomics but but into you know gene
therapy and that translation
of what we can learn from genomics to
patient care
great that is a fun story thank you for
sharing
you would die
so we have one more question um you
already have a list of known somatic
variants for certain diseases
have you come across a patient where
there's a new unknown variant associated
with their disease i personally have not
um mostly because we have not had tso up
and running yet but we do have the
ability to detect those new variants and
we call them de novo variants um and as
those begin to show up in our population
we can you know we can track those in
the familial ways um and then also
seeing if there's a particular variant
that shows up within you know certain
geographic regions or you know that kind
of thing and i'm sure the all of us
program the more they um analyze those
hundred thousand sequences that they
just
made available um through their through
their interface um as they analyze those
sequences that's going to um most likely
identify new de novo variants that we
hadn't already defined
great thank you well thank you again for
the great talk uh it was a pleasure to
have you here with us thank you everyone
all
right
so up next we are going to hear from mr
mark allen so it is my pleasure to
welcome mr mark allen he is a google
cloud account manager for the national
institute of health he is focused on
extramural
researcher and net enablement
prior to joining google marked work at
microsoft aiding his higher education
clients to adopt the cloud
mark has a bs in business administration
from the california university of
pennsylvania and msit from carnegie
mellon university so please join me in
welcoming mr mark allen
oh can we
mark a co-host please
hey can you guys hear me okay
yes we can
excellent thank you very much um thanks
for the intro laura i really appreciate
it i also invited ashoki who is a
business development rep here at google
cloud
and she's going to share all the slides
i'm working from my phone and my ipad
today unfortunately so
i show you if you wouldn't mind sharing
all the slides please
uh sorry who's uh ashoki is it akshay
uh oh s
i o k e
and then our last name is ufo there you
go perfect
excellent all right i think we're good
thank you much thank you very much show
key um so as mentioned i'm i'm mark
allen uh i worked at microsoft for nine
years before joining google uh and again
very much helping my uh higher education
customers adopt the cloud i'm based out
of san francisco california but i did
work for microsoft uh two years in the
east coast outside of new york city
uh prior to joining microsoft i was in
the customer space i was actually in
education i was a director of i.t
uh and and you know worked on a lot of
infrastructure stuff i won't get all the
details of course so
i kind of still maintain that customer
perspective really
uh next slide please
uh so here's our quick agenda we're
going to talk a little bit briefly about
why google cloud i'm going to try my
best not to mention any any product
names i think i'm going to mention one
and then we're going to talk about nih
and the strides program of course why
you're here uh how to join the program
and then what happens after you enroll
right and then we'll switch to a q a
and uh and we'll go from there
so first off why google cloud so next
next slide please it's okay so when you
think of google you probably think of
the search engine right the very generic
white background beautifully colored
letters
and you type in your search and within
milliseconds you get your results right
uh the next slide but what you don't
think of is the infrastructure behind it
right there are thousands of servers
that are running the google.com search
engine as well as all of our
applications uh matter of fact we've
been google has been building you know
consumer based applications since 97
right uh so if you go to the next slide
you'll see kind of a great timeline and
a history of the the major products that
google has released uh we've been in the
consumer space since before 97
and each of these applications on here
has a billion users for each application
two of them actually have two billion
users and you'll note that all of them
are 100 powered by machine learning
right uh so you're gonna have access to
slide deck and if you look at the little
blue uh notes beneath each application
there is at least two of the the machine
learning powered uh features of those
applications right i guarantee if you
have children they're using youtube i
know my nieces religiously uh and so you
know we've definitely helped with
machine learning to do some better
thumbnails better recommendations right
always always looking at the algorithm
making sure that our consumers are kind
of getting the the needs that they have
next slide please
a few more little tidbits about google
right so google is the world's largest
purchaser of renewable energy in fact
all of our global operations have been
powered by 100 renewable energy since
2017. uh here you got a couple pictures
of the the big windmills of course the
the wind farm and then the solar panels
as well right so uh we're very committed
to sustainability and going green and so
if you partner with google you are
definitely making a green choice as well
next slide
one of the reasons i joined google is
their dedication to hybrid and
multi-cloud solutions uh other cloud
providers certainly have this i'm not
here to knock on them but
essentially you know their their
approach is more of a hardware
uh lock-in or vendor lock-in right uh
google's approach uh even outside of
hybrid multi-cloud is a software-based
approach right um so we have developed
you know google kubernetes and now that
is certainly a defective standard out in
the world right
um
what the only product i'll mention is
anthos right and this is built on that
kubernetes engine and and this is kind
of a big game changer it's a
software-based solution that allows you
to
essentially run google cloud services
on-premises or in other clouds even
right
so we have a lot of great flagship
products and maybe you say hey my data
is is on-premise and i need to keep it
on premise uh you can bring the cloud
down to you with with anthos right um so
we're very committed to hybrid
multi-cloud solutions and the approach
if you know uh
ideally one day everybody's in the cloud
uh you know but along the way we're to
have you know certainly a hybrid
approach as well as many cloud providers
involved
next slide
a couple slides real quick on security
our approach to security in two words is
trust nothing
and if you go to the next slide
essentially what i'm talking about here
is we don't consider
traffic any internet traffic
whether it's internal or external to be
different right there's no difference as
far as we're concerned so we build in
uh layered defense in depth right is we
essentially look for mitigations and
multiple defenses within each layer and
in between each layer right
and so with this approach we've
essentially been able to create a very
secure cloud computing area next slide
uh if you have any compliance needs we
certainly meet all or exceed all the
government requirements for security and
privacy protection we're happy to give
you some security attestation reports uh
you can just go to our cloud security
command center and and take a look at
all the reports yourself as well
but we have all the big ones of course
fedramp we have the high trust we have
hipaa uh there's a bunch of iso ones as
well so whatever your needs are chances
are we meet those needs uh and if we
don't we're certainly working willing to
work with you on getting those compliant
certifications
all right next slide and then slide that
so what a stride so take a brief second
to talk about the national states of
health so nih is comprised of 27
institutes centers and offices we just
call them ics so apologies if i use
acronyms uh but when i say ic i just
mean one of the ics uh regarding the nih
uh i got a couple examples up there uh
the presentation before me i think
mentioned the nci as well so i think
you're familiar with that one
i put a link for the reporter up here
the reporter is an nih tool that they
have built that allows anybody to kind
of see all of the grants that are out
there per institution or even per pi
principal investigator right so
you're welcome to use that reporter and
kind of see you know you can see how
much funding your institutions you know
received what grants your pi's are
working on all the good stuff there
essentially
what i didn't uh what i didn't actually
put on this slide is
regarding
how nih's funding is set up and it's
very very complex but at a very high
level
uh if you read their strategic report 80
percent of their funding goes to
external universities uh sorry
extramural institutions um out of that
eighty percent seventy percent uh is
roughly all higher education right
um so that's around 50
of their total budget their total budget
for 2022 was around 49 billion dollars
uh so nih is committed to extramural
research and allowing others to
kind of you know do the research that
makes sense from a biomedical standpoint
uh next slide okay so we're keeping on
this slide actually uh
so strides right let's talk about
strides uh strides is an acronym of
course it stands for the science of
technology research infrastructure for
discovery experimentation and
sustainability
essentially it's a program they built
because they see the value of the cloud
and they're really just trying to
accelerate biomedical discovery right
google was first to enter this
partnership in july of 2018 uh aws
signed on recently after that as well
and then i think microsoft azure just
signed up in july of 2021 right so all
the three major cloud providers are in
there um you know but we're a little
unique in that not only do they partner
with us first but our ai and ml
abilities as i kind of mentioned before
are are differentiated enough that we
have a very big uh say in kind of how
that ai is done right i won't talk about
alpha fold here but that's certainly one
of the the hot buzzwords when it comes
to machine learning right um and and
that's kind of true to just google's
testament of ai machine learning
next slide please
from a benefit standpoint when you sign
onto the strides program the the first
benefit most people realize right away
is those deep discounts on google cloud
uh now normally i put the pricing table
in here uh because we're being recorded
i we really liked it not to do that but
i can verbally say at least that the
there is 25 discount on compute and
storage the 25 discount on compute
applies to all compute resources
including gpus
so if you have high compute needs the
discounts are there and and they're
provided to you you know via google
cloud from nih again to get more
research for your dollar right and and
hopefully uh hopefully to uh
ex
uh accelerate that biomedical discovery
uh other big disc other big benefits we
always talk about are the access to
training there's a discount on training
programs as well we also have for some
free and no cost training options i'll
talk about this briefly at the end
you'll also get a direct relationship
with nih right we are happy to kind of
make connections to program officers
people within ics uh whoever makes sense
to kind of have a conversation to talk
more about the research the programs uh
and then if you're enrolling in strides
and you actually have some
uh you know architecture discussion
questions we can certainly make those
connections as well
and of course that last big benefit is
that faster time to insight again we're
always trying to get uh the results
quicker so you can spend more time on on
the science versus on the infrastructure
itself
uh one next slide and then so one big
thing i want to point out is there is no
upfront commitment to joining strides
there's no money you pay to get into the
program it essentially is provided at no
cost because you're going to use nih
dollars for your research in the cloud
and then next slide
so another
great um benefit is increased advocacy
right so everybody on this call has an
account team at google cloud for every
university every college you have an
account team at google cloud that
account team usually consists of an
account manager like myself you probably
have a customer engineer who's kind of a
more technical
person on that call or engage with you
and there's probably a few others that
are on your account team on the nh
account team as well right i'm one of
the account managers we have support we
have consulting we have customer
engineers and architects data scientists
it's a really large account team um
and if you if you click on the slide
broker show key so when you join the
program you essentially get you know the
advocacy from both your account team as
well as us right so we're here to help
any nih-funded researcher
get what they need to out of google
cloud essentially right obviously within
reason but my role as account manager is
to be an advocate for
nih as an account but also anybody i'm
working with right i'm focused on
extramurals so it's around 3000
institutions i'm working with
next slide
up and then there's a quick little red
blurb more advocacy than google and with
nih as well right
next slide
public data set so one of the big
another big feature of the strides
program itself is
trying to get access to you know open
data right trying to make sure that the
data that biomedical researchers need is
available in the cloud
i think on the presentation before this
i heard anvil sorry
all of us and so all of us is actually
working with the team there and we're
getting all of us on google cloud as
well right so there's a lot of great
public data sets we have available we
have some that are
publicly available but not in the in the
program itself but you can still access
them there's things like imaging data
commons there's sra toolkits uh and
we're always adding more data sets as
well right so i'm currently working with
a pi out of ucsf who manages a 400
terabyte database
and we're working with the program
manager for the public data assist
program to get it in the cloud right um
with the way we see it the more data
that's in the cloud the quicker your
research can get done you don't have to
spend time moving your data around
massaging it it's already there it's
already ready to go and you can just
kind of start your research
next slide
all right flexible options to join let's
dive into this right so
i showed you i'm going to have you uh
click when i say click if you don't mind
um this this slide builds out right so
if you don't mind click click once
and so this is you you are a researcher
out there uh and and you know maybe
you're getting nih funded dollars maybe
you're getting funds from other
organizations you know whatever it may
be
click again and so you are probably
reporting up to a department uh if you
click again
that department has other researchers
and click again
and then again that department's up into
a school or institutes and if you click
it one more time
uh you know that reports up to a
university
that might have more schools it might
have an academic med center right but
essentially there are nih funded
researchers all throughout this
organization and so what our goal is to
sign the strides agreement at the
highest level right we're happy to sign
individual researchers uh departments
schools institutes whatever it takes
right because sometimes that university
procurement process can take you know
five eight nine months right so when you
have nih funded dollars and you want to
kind of experience the benefits
especially the discounts right away
we're happy to work with you to get you
signed in as quickly as possible right
if you click one more time
the one thing that we really really like
to have too is kind of an i.t support as
well right so
we understand not every organization has
it support or maybe research computing
and so it doesn't need to be a
full-fledged i.t we just need somebody
that is kind of going to be that point
person for billing ids uh and and really
understanding the process right so we
work with that person or team of people
to make sure they understand the process
what information is needed to get an id
uh billing id and then and then kind of
you know giving out from there right um
so this is kind of like like the the
pyramid that we go to the pyramid of
what we're trying to get to right the
higher we sign the more benefits all the
nih researchers
next slide
so i'm going to talk about these options
to sign on very very quickly because
they can get into weeds very very
quickly as well so
we have three major options first option
is directed caresoft uh carosoft is the
federal distributor of the google cloud
service for nih right and for many of
our actual public sector customers if
you click once this is a very very
simple process
uh you would essentially engage with
carousel we would set up those
conversations and you can essentially
sign on very very easily
if you go to the next slide this is
where we have a little more flexibility
and this is where most of our education
customers kind of want to fall right
and so you'll notice i have the same
image kind of twice and so we'll talk
about it uh twice essentially so we have
two we have a few recently worked with
the two that most of our customers sign
through is onyx and burbon group
both of these resellers are a value-add
reseller and they they first there's no
further uh
margin right it's not like they're
cutting into the discounts at all
you sign on with them and it's still no
cost but both of them actually have a
very unique billing tool
and if you are that kind of i.t person
that is going to be doing all the
billing ids
that
those building tools that they provide
are just hugely helpful as far as being
able to kind of differentiate where the
money is going per grant and per project
right
um so if you are interested in joining
strides we will definitely loop in onyx
and burwood you can have a conversation
with them if you like not to go with a
reseller or just directed carousel
through option one
the billing is going to be kind of up to
you right making sure that you are able
to report on the billing is going to be
fall in your hands
and the reason for that for all of this
essentially is
all of these funds are federal funds
right which means they're they're
subject to congressional reporting
uh and nih is very big on this of course
uh and we all should be too it's our tax
dollars so um but essentially if it's
not reported well then there's
definitely a lot of questions right so
engaging with onyx and broadway your
best best way to go they have a very
great tool
on the right they'll notice the only
difference is internet2
right
you are welcome to sign on with internet
too you can be a member or a non-member
but if you if you sign the strides
agreement through internet 2 you also
get to realize not only the benefits of
the strides program but the benefits of
internet 2 as well and so i'll cover
those in about two more slides
if you click once there's another little
red blurb no increase in price with the
use of a reseller right next slide
please
now the last one's very very quick and
dirty essentially if you already have an
existing agreement with google cloud or
with carousoft we can leverage that
agreement as well right there's not many
customers that fall into this category
uh it's typically let's let's use a
reseller let's use you know make sure
you also get internet too
this is something you're also welcome to
explore if you want to
next slide please
this is just a quick summary i'm not
going to cover this in the interest of
time but you are welcome to read it and
you know ask any questions later if you
need to
next slide please
so internet 2 so
there's an internet to net plus gcp
agreement right this was pre-negotiated
with four universities uh to kind of
provide benefits to members and
non-members quite frankly um
for internet too and for google cloud
essentially uh so
it's essentially there's
that the biggest thing we always talk
about is if
you join through internet 2 not only
will your nih workloads get to 25
discount but any non-nih workload will
receive a 5 discount on compute and
storage as well right there's also a lot
of other benefits of course we invite
you to reach out to that email address
netplus at internet2 you work with a guy
named bob flynn
bob is from indiana university one of
the initial four universities that
helped
negotiate this contract and bob's
amazing so i can't talk about him enough
uh he's he's very knowledgeable uh he's
very customer focused uh and then he'll
set you straight so i invite you to
reach out to that email email address dr
bob and uh and he'll tell you all the
cool stuff
next slide please
all right here's just a quick list of uh
internet 2 net plus google cloud
subscribers right your college or
university may be signed on to netplus
but maybe through azure maybe 3ws uh
maybe you're a non-member of internet2
as well right so this is a quick list
and i put the link in the in the notes
you're welcome to kind of bridge that as
well
next slide
all right so after enrolling in strides
uh
we we engage with internet2 and we got
some feedback right uh we asked a lot of
questions you know to ask a lot of
questions i should say on kind of hey
you have access to the strides program
you're an nih researcher
you know why is there a disconnect why
are you not using the strides program
right and the biggest result we got back
was actually just communication they
just weren't aware they had access to it
and so we have kind of created a success
plan to make sure that going forward
when a university or college or med
center or even just department signs on
this is kind of a the key to success to
make sure that all the researchers there
know they have access to it and how to
get access to it so to start again we
have an it support process it's more
about the billing account id process it
doesn't need to be it can be research
computing it can be a pi or pi's
assistant we have a few of those
examples um just somebody that's kind of
there to say yep i know i need to get
the this type of information from a
researcher
uh and then i can i can send it to nih
and i will get my that my project id my
billing id right so
a very very simple process we just kind
of need that one person at least
the other major things we found is
having a website i think on this page it
says a public page it doesn't need to be
public we do have two examples from nyu
and university of wisconsin-madison
welcome to read those
but you could be on your internet as
well but some type of web page that for
researchers that kind of says here's the
nih strides program here's why it's
important to you and here's how to get
access to it right
after that website's completely
finalized uh an email needs to be kind
of sent some type of communication
whatever that may be
sent out to the research community at
that university saying hey you have
access to this check out the webpage you
have any questions here's some email
addresses or people to reach out to
whatever it might be
and then finally a launch event um this
used to just say webinar i've added
seminar because things are opening up
now and then hopefully we can get
on-site to customers more but
essentially having uh you know a large
audience of people that are that are
interested in nih funded research and
and interesting new cloud you know join
the webinar seminar kind of saying hey
here's all the questions here's all the
answers your questions here's the
program works uh google's happy to join
those and i just happen to join those
the resellers internet too they're all
happy to join we're here for you guys so
um after you guys sign up and we want to
get to that point of like hey let's make
sure we evangelize the strides program
we're here to help make that happen
next slide please
so another piece of feedback from that
internet 2 survey was around training
now i'm going to talk briefly at the end
about some free and no cost training
options but i also wanted to highlight
that we work with nih very very closely
and
we last year we helped develop custom
training right the title is introduction
to biomedical data science in google
cloud we delivered it seven times in
2021 to the intramural researchers
i think the first three times there's
you know kind of reiterations of let's
make sure we we change this or modify
this or speak about this more this this
thing less
but after those three initial uh
trainings the last four went off without
a hitch we had a lot of success and
we do always seek anonymous feedback and
so there's a quote there from a
researcher who joined one of those
sessions
there's 16 attendees per class there's a
sample agenda on the right uh if you're
interested in training uh whether it's
just custom training or other training
options feel free to reach out and we'll
put you in touch with your account
manager to talk through those
next slide
okay i am almost finished here so
this is an eyesore i apologize and this
is two
screenshots from a doc i have and so
you're going to get access to the pdf
with all these links at a very very high
level i'm going to talk about just a few
of them right the top left is the google
cloud free trial
so everybody is welcome to get 300 in
credits of google cloud services uh it
does require a credit card but i will
point out that it will not charge your
credit card
uh until you say so right and until
that's that 300 expired so what happens
is you put your credit card in you get
300
credits there's also a free tier
available where we have certain cloud
services that are always free you're
welcome to use those credits until
they're exhausted after they're
exhausted then you're prompted do you
want to use your credit card or not you
can say no
and that's it you won't get charged
it'll shut down your services and we can
all move on right so
i know there's always hesitation using
credit card but but google is very open
on this and very aware of of the fears
so
please don't be hesitant to to sign into
that program
i'm going to jump down to
google cloud research credits
if you have a research project that you
are working on
and maybe you applied for nih grant and
you didn't get it
but it's a cool research time topic
you're welcome to click on that link and
apply for reached credits from google i
think we do up to five thousand dollars
and so we'll help fund your project in
the cloud
uh the next two links are about learning
google cloud right there's a lot of
free online labs quests courses a lot of
great stuff in there about about free
training essentially i invite you to
check those out as well
the link below that is google cloud for
researchers so if you are a researcher
you're also welcome to get some credits
and some free training with that
below that is google cloud for students
again if you are a student you want to
you're trying to learn some more about
google cloud you're welcome to apply to
that program as well
uh the top right though is if you are a
faculty and you're saying hey i'm
actually going to teach a class on
uh you know biomedical research and
we're going to use google cloud that's
the program you would use where you
would get the credits then dish out to
your students right so we're very big on
free education programs and providing
credits to students and faculty as well
as researchers
there's a few more links in there i
think one of the ones i would definitely
want to highlight is
the
public sector cloud community it's the
third from the last we call it pubset
connect it's run by a woman named kate
johnson and it's
uh you know there's there's no sales
discussions allowed right it's it's it's
individual to individual and so
essentially other customers talking to
other customers about their experience
in the cloud their challenges their
successes it's a great community there's
a call i think every week
and a lot of great presenters on there
as well
um google cloud communities below that
is basically you can kind of engage with
product managers here at google on your
questions and then i put a certification
link there below as well
if you click once for miyashoki a nice
big red box should appear so
uh as much as i try to highlight some of
these discussion points there's a
session by alice cayman to help put most
of these programs together that was
delivered yesterday so i invite you to
check that out on the youtube uh she
goes into in-depth into most of these
programs and again if you have questions
for her to reach out
uh next slide
so the next slide is i think just a
quick call to action the call to action
is very simple it is basically if you
have any questions if you're interested
in learning about strides google cloud
google workspace if you have any
questions at all feel free to reach out
and if you go to the next slide we have
some email addresses up here for you
right so the top is me i am mark c allen
i had to use my middle initial layer
i showed you something called as well
like i mentioned she's a business
development rep uh if if you have kind
of likes or high level questions uh she
would probably be best to email she'd
like it back too much quicker than i can
but you're welcome to email me as well
right please don't think uh i don't want
your emails i do um the last email there
is the google cloud strides team and so
this is the entire account team for nih
it includes people from support
consulting we have architects and data
scientists on this email so if you kind
of have a broader question feel free to
email that alias and uh and we'll be
happy to answer your questions for you
if you have any doubts feel free to just
email me and i will reach the right
people and we'll get you squared away
and the next slide is just q a so i will
open the floor
for any q a
thank you mark for that very informative
talk so in the interest of time we are
actually going to have any questions
that you have for mark to please forward
to us and we can pass those along later
is that all right mark
perfect thank you very much sorry if i
went over i apologize and uh it's a lot
of fun
yes thank you again
thank you all right
all right
now i would like to introduce um dr gus
kasulis
dr casulis is a professor of virology
and biotechnology in the department of
pathobiological sciences
and the director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine
she is the director of the nih-funded
center in experimental infectious
disease research and the director of the
nih-funded louisiana biomedical research
network molecular and cell biology core
so please join me in welcoming dr gus
casulis
are you able to unmute your microphone
yeah now now i just muted that i
couldn't unmute it earlier it was
blocked
can you hear me now
yes we can hear you now okay great
okay um
thank you laura for the introduction um
i wanted to sort of update a little bit
uh what you said i'm also department
head in pathobiological sciences
and we are pleased here at the lsu
school of very medicine that we have two
additional centers
the lung biology center
that's led by dr um sumitabi gia silen
as well as a pre-clinical
cancer recovery
that's led by dr joseph francis
the molecular cause of both of those
centers as well as the previous center
infectious diseases
it's actually administered by
my division of biotechnology molecular
medicine with essential elements the
core facility gene lab that provides
next-gen sequencing and bio-formatic
analysis
internally as well as in collaboration
with pine biotech but i'm here to talk
to you today about the uh non-profit
organization which i represent as the
president um and laura can i share my
slides
yes you should be able to share those
okay
so you should be able to see i hope
my slides now
so the national association of idea
principal investigators is a
not-for-profit organization
representing all these centers
that are funded by the national
institute of health the national
institute of general medical sciences
that includes more than 170
centers for biomedical research
excellence
that are funded by the kobe mechanism
24
of the inbred mechanisms as well as
multiple clinical translational centers
and other programs that are run through
the manpower
division capacity division of energy ms
so
the purpose of nappy is really to
promote the idea programs again we're
not-for-profit
organization
that
is principally to foster interactions
and to promote with short sharing
and
the website is the as shown here and
nappy.org there's another very important
information
including resources and training
resources that we have made available
freely either through
participation of different programs
and also
through collaboration with pine biotech
and i really urge you to explore this
website and look at the opportunities
that we offer
in addition nebby
is
partnering with lsu
to manage the national
idea
conference that happens every two years
the next conference is called nisbri
it will be
the first week of october
and it will be virtual
and it would
allow a glimpse of all these 23 states
and puerto rico programs the cobre the
inbrees the ctrs the co-funded programs
as well as some of the specialized
programs
we expect over a thousand people to
participate on the virtual meeting
the contract has been awarded by nih to
lsu
and nappy is collaborating with lsu to
manage this national
meeting
the next meeting after that would be
2024
and 2026 in person in washington dc the
first meeting on 2022
will be virtual meeting
and
it will have a number of other resources
training
as well as participation of major
companies um
we hope google amazon ibm and others
so um the next slide this is the
leadership of nappy
i am the current president of nabi
and
these are the officers for the executive
committee we also do have a steering
committee
having four members representing the
different programs from each of the four
geographically
uh different uh uh
portions of the country uh
south
uh east west north
and
we meet periodically to
ascertain how to promote better the
interactions uh with an aids and also
with all our constituents
um
of course as i reiterated to reiterate
now the mission of nap is to provide
leadership and communication for the
development promotion and improvement of
biomedical research through the imbrie
kobri entrepreneurship hubs this is a
new
type of
program that has been developed to also
facilitate entrepreneurship within the
idea states and of course the ctr idea
programs the objectives is to focus
interact to foster interactions to
promote visual sharing to enhance the
visibility of their program to develop a
consensus priorities and to identify
disseminate best practices and to
identify opportunities and develop
strategies to achieve the common goals
of the idea program
one of the major emphasis of nih as well
as of the idea program especially
through the inbree mechanisms is really
the training
of
a pipeline of investigators starting
from undergraduate to graduate students
to postdocs to faculty in data science
and bioinformatics so therefore one of
the major goals of nebi is to share
resources and provide
avenues for training in data science and
bioinformatics uh through nepy as well
as through the individual components
that represent the idea program
so in terms of the history of the idea
program we started in
1993 the purpose was to broaden the
geographical distribution of united's
funding for biomedical research and
behavior research
it focuses on health related research
and
the
reasoning is to enhance the
competitiveness of investigators at
all institutions locating states which
the aggregate success rate for the
application age has been historically
being low if you look really at the
trajectory of this program it's actually
quite amazing that the idea program has
achieved
the
a number of different
important
thresholds including the graduation of
young investigators with r1 nationally
competitive applications at a younger
age and at the with increased
success rate even comparing all nih
programs across the board so um we are
really to promote science and create a
pipeline of investigators starting from
undergraduates all the way to faculty
and hopefully through tenure and
the promotional program grant funding
so this is the
this is the type of funding that has
been received so far in 2021 there were
396 million dollars allocated to the
idea as part of the overall budget the
goal of nappy is to facilitate in
collaboration with the epscor uh
foundation as for coalition uh up to one
percent of the nih budget to be targeted
to idea programs uh we're a little bit
below that at this point the projection
for 2022 is at 410 million dollars but
still under the projected or at least
the uh what do we wish which is uh one
percent of the total nih budget um mind
you for 23 states of puerto rico
practically half
of the states uh in uh in the country
this is the type of contributions
different programs highlighted only few
programs but you can see north dakota
more than half of the funding for all in
aids funding for that state comes from
the idea program in other states
solution a little bit more successful
it's a smaller portion but critically i
think this particular component here
facilitates a number of people that are
actually now nationally competitive are
able to compete and get traditional
categorical funding through competitive
awards
beyond at the national level
so it's a very critical component of
what nih is doing these are the
principal components of the idea funding
recovery programs the purpose of this
cobra is to graduate people with
independent funding hopefully r1 funding
over a 15-year period the inbury program
it's only one per state and that really
focuses on the pipeline from
undergraduates all the way to graduate
and faculty i has a number of primarily
undergraduate institutions and has a
critical component in teaching mentoring
and training in data science and
bioinformatics in fact one of the
principal course which is mandatory all
these programs is a data science
bioinformatics core right now that we
also have in our own program
we also have the clinica translational
research centers uh they're really sort
of uh
smaller uh clinical translational
centers the
ctsas as they're named and these are
really targeting the idea stage for
clinical translational research one
important component of the idea program
is co-funding people
that go for our 115s or s10 applications
may uh get a boost and get funded
probably within five percentile points
through co-funding between igms idea and
the categorical institute and of course
the new addition is the regional
technology transfer hubs sdtrs therefore
they're active right now there may be
additional ones coming up in the next
round of applications and the idea is to
really increase the number of sbirs sdtr
grants that are funded in the idea
states since they're not really
participating uh to a large extent in
this particular pool of funding that
comes from federal sources
um
part of the idea networks is also the
use of cloud computing that you just
heard the stride program
for google and amazon and there are
special locations and supplemental
funding for that
um there are promotion of statewide
regional networks that
are promoted through a variety of
different ways beyond just the cprs
and this uh
involves a specific co-funding
coordinator that has been appointed for
its nic categorical institute
uh the original uh hubs also have pilot
programs and they also teach
fundamentals for technology core
directors uh to promote um
entrepreneurship
um
there are also supplemental fundings
that came to uh increased connectivity
between bris and kobre ctrs and so on
we've been the recipients of multiple of
those supplemental funding and part of
the idea is to connect all these idea
programs together
through regional centers and promote
collaboration among all the programs
and then of course there were
specialized programs because of the
pandemic the copy 19 patient registry
cloud computing has already mentioned
and then there is nih wide research
initiatives that are also linked
to programs within igms and the idea
program
this is the map of the idea states
as you see
they're all over the country and
the focus is to also bring those states
up to become competitive for nice
funding as well as other federal funding
so
nappy
through its website
has a number of very important
activities
it funds idea
undergraduate traveling to washington dc
for the meeting as well for registration
into our virtual misery meeting in 2022
we have awards for undergraduate
graduate students that actually already
have allocated to our regional idea
meetings to happen in between the
national uh nisbury meeting and we were
happy to award up to three thousand
dollars to individual undergraduate
graduate students and assistant
professors in each of those regional
meetings
that already have occurred
we uh
can have access to a diy databases and
recessed expertise through the nepi
website which is actually increasingly
populated with new information and
ultimately we do provide discounts to
virtual courses in that data science and
mathematics
through variety programs but also
through collaboration with pine biotech
and through a
grant that we received from the tober
foundation that allows certain of these
scholarships as well as support for
certain seminars that we'll be uh
promoting in the national
miss brie meeting that will happen the
first week of october
uh part of the sponsored symposia was
the previous omics reset symposium that
happened uh the omics one august 21-22
we also have advertised and support uh
this omics symposium that
has been put together in collaboration
with find biotech that provides a thing
important information and all these
recorded sessions uh will be available
uh through the nappy uh website uh uh
that we have
so uh this is what uh i had to tell you
about uh nepi i would certainly
encourage you to um look at the nepi
website
um we are going into a major campaign to
organize this virtual meeting
originally it was supposed to be in
person in june however we only just
received the notice of award for nih for
the next three meetings so the next
meeting will be the first week of
october
i believe october 4 5 and 6. it will be
a virtual meeting and we hope that the
registration for this particular meeting
will open uh
hopefully within the next two to three
weeks
and i would urge all of you uh to
participate in this meeting because
you're going to see
the breadth of
of all the
research that is being
supported by the idea program
uh not only our embry programs but also
the kobri's the ctrs uh some of the
specific networks have been funded by an
sms for child health
and
cancer and beyond that so
i will point you to that website and
epic website for more information as it
becomes available so
thank you for participating is very
important uh activity that uh find
biotech in collaboration with others has
put together and i look forward uh to
attend some of the
next sessions
and answer any questions that you may
have
laura
okay thank you very much dr kasulis that
was a very informative talk
um we have one question for you how can
not be members participate in the
educational resource development nappy
is doing
yeah so basically um
through the website there is a forum for
any content that you have that you could
actually share if you're willing to
share it nappy will promote it we have
over a thousand people registered on our
automated emailing system that would
alert them of that resource
and
we are actually in the process of
mailing out to major providers which
includes google and others
to
link some of their content
through our nepi website and potentially
provide some discounts or support as it
has been done with nih so i would urge
you to contact
the nappy
webmaster and let us know you can let me
personally know
what you may be thinking and i would be
happy to share it with you or point you
to the right
material
great thank you
another question so can faculties at
universities that aren't involved in
nappy get involved
uh
yes actually the nappy website is really
uh free
accessible to all so all the content
is available and
we
welcome any
participation from non-ideal states
that could
share with us content or information or
resources
obviously we're trying to make this
information
um
uh for the most part free or heavily
discounted for our nepy members but
absolutely yes we welcome anybody to
through our navy website to communicate
with us and offer advice material
whatever that may be
thank you very much
well i don't think there are any more
questions for you so thank you very much
again for presenting okay thanks
all right
well now i would like to present our
next speaker
so dr luis vasquez quinones is an
assistant professor of biology and
molecular cell biology at anna g mendez
university
he is also the co-director of the
bioinformatics resource corps program
from pr inbree and leads the orientation
portion of puerto rico's community of
practice in bioinformatics
dr vazquez quinones was first exposed to
bioinformatics when he was an
undergraduate student through an
introductory computer science course
during the course he learned some
programming skills but it wasn't until
he was re-exposed to bioinformatics
through a graduate course that he became
interested in data analysis
later in his career dr vasquez quinones
was able to integrate aspects of
bioinformatics into academic courses and
research so that his students could be
exposed to bioinformatics similarly to
how he was
dr vasquez quinones is also involved in
teaching outreach programs and
encourages students to reach out to
experts to help them learn
apart from his teaching and research
responsibilities dr vasquez quinones is
also the co-director of the prn
bioinformatics research cohort and an
active member of the puerto rico
community of practice and bioinformatics
the goal of this community practice in
bioinformatics is to reconnect the
puerto rico institutions together to
create a community of active and open
research with a focus on data science
and bioinformatics
so with that please join me in welcoming
dr luis vasquez quinones
hello everyone
hello welcome can you see my
screen
yes we can
okay hello everyone today i am going to
talk to you about
the bioinformatics training
opportunities that puerto rico indre is
offering on during this grant cycle 2021
2025 the title for my presentation is
puerto rico in bioinformatics training
opportunities to the community of
practice model
the general outline for my presentation
is
where is puerto rico in relocated on the
world map
what is a community of practice
the stages for a community of practice
what we have been doing for the
implementation of the community of
practice with an update
uh by informatics community of
practicing training opportunities
uh and other training opportunities to
the puerto rico
network
benefits of the bioinformatics community
of practice acknowledgements and
answer questions
for those of you that do not know puerto
rico is located in the caribbean and
puerto rico in belongs to the southeast
region of the ingres program
a community of practice is a
knowledge-based social structure that
enables groups of people to share a
passion in our case bioinformatics
for a domain to interact regularly and
deepen their knowledge and expertise in
that domain
a community of practice is comprised of
three key elements the domain that is
the common interest in a field or area
of knowledge consists of key problems
exp experienced by members in our case
the domain is bioinformatics with the
goal of increasing bioinformatics and
computational skills among our members
the second element is the community that
should be our voluntary members that
share the interest in the domain
and actively participate in designing
activities and dialogues for the
fundamental goal of increasing knowledge
and solving problems through interaction
so in our case the community will be the
scientists around puerto rico
researchers on teaching faculty students
undergrads and graduate students as well
their element is the practice and are a
collection of methods techniques tools
information stories
resources etc that members use together
to advance the goals of the community of
practice
in our case our practice will be for
research and education
in this slide you can see that a
community of practice has five stages
potential coalescing maturing
stewardship and transformation
during the potential state faculty for
from predominantly undergraduate
institutions also known as puis in our
case
have a high academic workload among
other responsibilities that represents a
barrier to keeping up with changes in
the field of bioinformatics
in addition these institutions also lack
computational capabilities
when the coalescing stage on this model
the community of practice model will
bring together a community of scientists
and trainees from around the island to
facilitate collaboration at the research
and educational level
that will increase the number of
scientists using bioinformatics and to
prepare the next generation of
scientists
the third stage is mattering
in which activities directed to increase
bioinformatics and computational skills
in non-bioinformatics scientists will be
designed and developed in collaboration
with pr inbre bioinformatics resource
core also known as buick to offer
community workshops interventioning
courses or laboratories at requests of
the institutions
the fourth stage stewardship on this
community of practice level
is rich when satisfactory bioinformatic
proficiency has been reached among the
members
on the fifth stage that is
transformation this is the ultimate
stage of the community of practice when
the scientific community is integrated
and willing to collaborate beyond the
world of each institution at the
research and educational level
currently we are at stage number two and
three coalescing because we are bringing
together
every scientist around the island within
interest in this um initiative
and mastering because we already um
started our development we already
developed uh the initial workshops is in
language
and we are um designing more uh
more workshops to be offered
um is the purpose of puerto rico in red
to increase the interaction between
researchers teaching faculty and
students around the island
the community will play
an essential role to foster these
instructions to increase the
bioinformatics of skills
among our members
so starting with the training
opportunities
uh
the training and education support
support will get by me
uh design the lineus workshop in which
the members of the bioinformatics
community of practice
will have access to the computational
resources offered by the vocation
cluster of the high performance
computing facility at the university of
puerto rico
this uh the high compartment high
performance computing facility is laid
by dr umberto ortiz so
at the university of puerto rico and he
is supporting us
and his team by uh providing the
accounts for our members
the operating system of the vocaron is
linux and the participants will be
learning the most common
commands to be ready for future
worship
in this um figure you can see that we
have already identified
a total of 30 institutions around the
island
in the lower left corner of the slide
you can see the legend
uh and the colors of the stars uh
reflects the the progress that we
already achieved with each institution
uh the number next to some of the stars
uh indicates how many of the three
airliners workshop have already been
received
uh a total of 20 out of the 30
institutions have already accepted the
invitation
have already identified a leader for the
community of practice the local
community of practice
have already coordinated or are in the
process of coordinating
the initial meeting
to talk about the initiatives
uh or already received the the
orientation i started coordinating the
workshop or already received them
currently we are
still paying efforts by contacting the
the third of the institution that
haven't responded yet
in this slide you can see pictures of
the
trainings that have been going on around
the island uh in a virtual or in person
uh fashion
uh i have been visiting uh
the communities around the island and
this one is in the north part of the
island in the northwest center
uh this other one
is in the northeast part of the island
this one is in in the north and this one
is in the south
uh we have been providing three lineus
questions with enough time of
interaction with the participants to
answer their specific questions
but as well to explore their
the community interests so once when
they have completed the three uh part of
the workshops uh follow-up meetings are
scheduled uh to explore new workshops
based on their interest or coordinated
additional lines workshop for additional
faculty and students
in this slide you can see l
in this picture you can see a typical
slide to explain a command in an
step
easy
way
in which uh uh this increase the
execution of the participants
and all participants receive this detail
of presentations by a onedrive link
so those are presentations serves as
reference for future
uh
and the near future
additional worksheet
continuing with
the training opportunities the next one
will be for next generation sequencing
workshop
the oxford nanopormin ion will be used
as a portable sequencing device to train
our members in sample sequencing data
processing and assembly
the objective is to include new
laboratory experiences in biology
curricula to impact our students around
the island but also to include
these approaches for research the
lioness knowledge is important for this
kind of work
the next
training opportunity uh that we have
then
identified is relational databases
database constitutes an ideal framework
for representing and
analyzing large datasets in biology
a structured querying language is one of
the most common tools used in the field
of data science that you have heard a
lot during this
symposium
relational databases allow users to
formulate and answer questions about the
data our participants will learn an
efficient way to manipulate the lan
datasets
currently nowadays having our skills are
very important for biologists
so in that sense we are going to be
offering our workshop in which our
members will
have the opportunity to learn r to
analyze their data and generate thoughts
r is used widely in several disciplines
is free which allows scientists to
analyze their data without expanding in
commercial programs in addition
um
uh r has a lot of bioinformatics free
tools that are available to analyze data
for current uh biological and emerging
biological essays
another opportunity comes from the
metagenomic support led by dr philippe
pagody vitorino to the puerto rico in
the network this court will train
researchers of pilot projects that
include a metal genomic component such
as microbiome studies
the support will assist in the
implementation of projects data
production data analysis and manuscript
publication
in addition the support will be offering
a metagenomics a workshop to the members
of the community of practice later on
the semester or during the summer
another good opportunity for our members
will be uh comes under our arm and comes
from the professional certificate in
their assigned
led by professor carlos ortiz dr abiel
rochellima dr estoni
this
data science certificate is comprised of
four courses introduction to data
science
main applications in data science data
sign application with machine learning
and data science final project
the role of the community of practice
will be to promote this certificate
among our members so they can benefit
from this opportunity
uh in this slide you can see a picture
of the most recent participants that
have already completed the
certification
and currently uh more than 100 x68
participants have completed the
certification
from people around the island of puerto
rico
uh i think that three two or three
person from um el salvador
and two from the main usa
another opportunity uh that is available
for our members comes from the
computational biologists of court led by
professor anatoly cerny he collaborates
with puerto rico in researchers students
as and structural associates
on research projects relevant to
bioinformatics research
currently he is developing a java
desktop application called assistant of
metabolized selection
for gas chromatography mass spectrometry
research
we will be inviting professor anatoly
shorney so he can provide
training opportunities for the members
of our community so he will become an
instructor
as well as doctor
perichi guerra that will be invited to
become an instructor he is leading the
support in a statistic and he provides
statistical services
to predominantly predominantly
undergraduate institution researchers
during the production of scholarly work
and to those preparing grass proposal
this course works in collaboration with
the
computational biologists of course
to support our researchers
and in this slide i am summarizing the
benefits of the of belonging to the my
friends community of practice
uh
access to the high performance computing
facility located at the at the high
performance computing facility uh
through the vocabulary cluster our
members will be able to um request
accounts
and that's account those accounts can be
used for research purposes um education
like in courses or laboratories and for
training purposes
educational materials for courses and
labs will be shared with faculty members
that will incorporate these um
experiences as part of their of part of
their courses or laboratories
and from medicine computational training
um
scientists around the island and
institutions around the island will
benefit from the faculty development
program in bioinformatics for their
faculty
bioinformatics seminars seminars that
are coordinated
through puerto rico invere will be
available to our members so they can um
happened to those as well
uh the directors of puerto rico in
records will give orientation talks to
our members
so they can know and the services that
they provide here at the island uh so
they can consider those services when
they are writing uh research proposals
uh educational proposals or both
um the last one research and educational
networking the scientists around the
island will have a system in place in
which they can collaborate um ideas
uh efforts
in order for to increase uh
bioinformatics and with people they can
um collaborate
like um collaborate
uh
for
solving issues that other people are
facing
nowadays
i would like to acknowledge that this
project is supported by a wide number
p20 gm 103475
from the nigms of the nih
thanks to all my colleagues at the pr
inver uh here in puerto rico and thanks
to the organizers of this symposium for
inviting me
inviting me uh to give this um
presentation
thank you very much dr vasquez quinones
that was a wonderful presentation
we have a few questions for you
uh the first one is how did you get
involved with bioinformatics and pr and
brie
okay uh my path in bioinformatics i
started as an undergrad when i was
exposed to the programming course
then i got involved as a graduate
student in the first bioinformatics
course
uh taught at my institution
and then i reconnect with uh the people
that taught me bioinformatics at the
peaceful super computing center i'm my
past mentor in bioinformatics
and then one day i was at the medical
census campus talk talking to dr jose
rodriguez medina that is the pi
and
we were in the hall and he was asking so
many questions
and it was funny because i
told him my vision
to improve bioinformatics skills around
the island
and
i talked about the device dominion
device and a few weeks later i was
receiving the device
and then he invited me
to form part of the of the team that was
writing the renewal for puerto rico
inver and i was that
i started my path uh dealing with
bioinformatics and the nih brought me
the idea of the community of practice
so we can benefit here in puerto rico
around the island increasing the
bioinformatics
great thank you
uh another question
how many students do you aim to train in
the next year
uh well currently i have been teaching
the bioinformatics course
uh since i arrived here at uh
universidad donahue mendes so i have
been impacting more than 100
so
i think
that we will be impacting a lot of
students because i am
creating a critical mass but attending
first the professors
that are teaching the courses around the
island
so in the near future i think that
everyone will be um receiving training
in bioinformatics because my vision is
that we no longer have any students
mainly from biology
that exit a program without these kids
so i i have to say a lot of them
that's great to hear
okay i don't think we have any more
questions for you thank you again for
presenting that was a very wonderful
talk
all right
so now i would like to introduce our
next speaker
it is my pleasure to welcome dr nicole
garrison
dr garrison is currently an assistant
professor of biology at west liberty
university in west virginia and a member
of the wv embry bioinformatics corps
faculty
she earned a phd at auburn university
working on the phylogenomics
transcriptomics and systematics of
spiders her research utilizes a variety
of next generation sequencing
technologies and involves the
development of custom bioinformatic
pipelines for a wide range of biological
applications from conservation biology
to evolutionary biology and biomedical
research
the primary foci of her current position
are aiding researches in the
pre-processing analysis and
interpretation of their sequencing data
as well as educating undergraduate
students in bioinformatics methods and
programming
so please join me in welcoming dr nicole
garrison
thank you
get my slide up here
okay so hi thank you for having me uh i
am as you said a junior faculty and
assistant professor of biology at west
liberty university
um
i have kind of a hybrid position so i
work
with the genomics core but i also teach
courses um so general biology courses
and specifically bioinformatics courses
so i'm really there to kind of develop
this
expertise at this primarily
undergraduate institution
so this talk is just kind of about the
approach that i'm taking that we are
taking in west virginia to start
training our students and begin that
pipeline of bioinformatic expertise at
the undergraduate level
i think for a lot of us our exposure to
bioinformatics happens kind of late in
the game and so we're trying to shift
that timeline back a little bit earlier
and get some of these younger students
involved
um in learning bioinformatics
so west liberty university if you're not
familiar with it which you know i
wouldn't really expect you to be is a
very small school
in kind of a rural setting in west
virginia
uh so we have um the distinction of
being the first institute of higher
education in the state we actually
predate the formation of west virginia
little fun fact
we have only about 2 500 undergraduates
so it's a very small campus not a whole
lot of students there
many of the students that come to our
university are local to the area or the
tri-state area
a lot of them are non-traditional
students they're returning to education
after being away
and many of them are dependent on
scholarship support
so it is kind of
an economically depressed area in some
senses
a lot of our students may be first-time
or first-generation college students as
well
despite all of this we have developed a
really strong biology department at west
liberty we have a ton of undergraduate
research currently happening
and so we have students in the lab
generating data and with the advances in
sequencing we're generating more and
more big data sets
so there's this need this increasing
demand for bioinformatic expertise at
our university
we also have a developing postgraduate
program so we have mams programs and we
also have a professional physicians
assistant program so there's a lot of
biomedical
biomedically oriented students that are
attending the university at different
levels
we are part of the west virginia embry
network
so we're a partner institution we work
really closely with particularly
marshall university
especially the genomics corps and dr jim
denver
and west virginia university
we're the site of a major research
project among many other research
activities that are happening there dr
horzempa has a very well developed lab
that is looking at erythrocyte invasion
by uh francis ella tularensis
lots of microbiology fun sequencing
happening at west liberty
we do a lot of our sequencing most of
our sequencing at the genomics core
facility which is located at marshall
and so this is kind of the
other half of my duties is to be the
connection between the genomics core and
the west liberty faculty so when they
generate data when their students
generate data i'm there to kind of act
as the go between and help them analyze
and interpret what they have
so there are multiple sequencing
projects ongoing
many of them having to do with
francisella
but we are developing more and more
independent kind of research programs
that are utilizing this genomics core
facility
so like i said i am in this hybrid
bioinformatics support position
so
following along with these inbree goals
which i'm sure you've already heard
multiple times
we have similar goals in west virginia
we need to build expertise
and capacity for biomedical research
we want to develop those biomedical
research programs and increase
competitiveness for external funding
we want to generate student research
opportunities we already do a really
good job of that like i said
but particularly research opportunities
in bioinformatics is kind of where we're
heading in the future
and so we're trying to train this future
workforce that is equipped with the
tools to
do bioinformatics work or at the very
least communicate with
bioinformaticians that they may
collaborate with in the future
so
i feel like bioinformatics is the
missing link right now at west liberty
and probably at a lot of institutions
across the country
researchers
have very interesting questions they
generate a lot of data because it's much
cheaper to do that in a lot of senses
these days
but they face these bottlenecks and data
analysis that are really common they
also have difficulty interpreting
results that they get if they have
someone help them analyze it
they may not be able to fully interpret
what they what they are presented with
so there's just a lack of bioinformatic
expertise at the faculty level graduate
level and that all comes from this lack
of training at the undergraduate level
so that's what we're trying to correct
here
we have some really common challenges
that i'm sure you're all aware of
but there is just this lack of awareness
amongst the students the undergraduates
of bioinformatics if you ask
any given undergraduate at our
institution you know how would you
define bioinformatics they would
probably give you a blank stare
they don't have a great understanding of
what it is
or why it might be important or useful
to them
in their education
so we're really struggling just
initially with them understanding that
you know this is a thing and it could be
a useful thing for them in their future
research
there is a lot of training and resources
available free online
but i think that's part of the problem
that they face is that they don't know
where to begin
um so really guided training
with one-on-one interaction is really
important at this level i believe
and it's very hard for them to come by
they may find the training materials
that they that they find on their own
and access
on their own a little unapproachable so
they're not really sure how to get
started
they don't really have the exposure to
bioinformatic careers as an option
so a lot of them come in they think that
they're you know they're going to be
pre-med they're going to be pre-vet
pre-professional programs
or they're going to you know work in a
zoo we have a huge zoo science program
but they don't really have this concept
of bioinformatics as a career that they
could attain
and they also are deterred in a lot of
cases because they're biology students
it seems like they have an aversion to
anything really heavy in computer
science or statistics or they perceive
bioinformatics to be really heavy in
both of those fields
what they don't necessarily realize is
that there are many different ways to
come at bioinformatics you can be a
biologist who picks up some computer
skills
so you don't have to be a computer
genius to begin this journey
so some potential solutions that i've
been exploring at west liberty just
first of all demystifying bioinformatics
so present those career options that are
out there in this field
and do it as early as possible and as
often as possible so kind of working
this into conversations working this
into lesson plans in more general bio
courses i think will be very helpful for
us
people who are bioinformatic ambassadors
i consider myself to be one of these
are very important so having someone on
campus who has the expertise
and some experience and can talk to you
about how they found their way to
bioinformatics and what that actually
means on a day-to-day basis
in terms of the work that they do
and again just emphasizing that there
are
many different uh ways into this this
field
we also need to emphasize the role that
bioinformatics is playing in research
findings so you know again this emerging
increase in big data in all fields of
research is really important to
emphasize
that bioinformatics is going to play a
key role into the future
for analyzing that data and
understanding biological questions
and then i'm i'm going to try to empower
and engage these students so that means
providing training opportunities those
guided training opportunities at every
level really
in this talk i'm really focusing on the
undergraduates but i think this probably
should start even at lower levels i'll
talk briefly about some k-12 outreach
that we're doing
and so to develop this um this is a
really nice simple figure
that i pulled from a recent paper so you
need to identify your training needs
which is what we're working on doing
um curate materials again we're kind of
in this beginning stages of developing
our our content for these bioinformatic
training opportunities
and
all of these things go together into
what we teach the undergraduates we
collect feedback from them
and ideally we would publish these
findings so we're not quite to the
publish openly phase of this process at
west liberty but we're hoping to get
there
someday soon
we also because we have this foundation
in undergraduate research are able to
incorporate more bioinformatic analysis
into the students research so they have
generated their data
now they can sit down and analyze it
rather than just handing it off to
someone
and then getting back the finished
figures
so we're trying to work on getting them
to
figure out how to actually analyze their
data a little bit with us
and just in general emphasize that this
is problem solving you don't have to
have uh all this code memorized that's
not really how bioinformatics happens
but you need to know where to find the
tools and how to use them and be able to
think your way through these problems
that come up
so like i said i've done some k-12
recruitment of course with covid it's
been kind of limited so this is very
recent development
actually last weekend i did a small
recruitment event where i used these
ozobots
which you can these are little
programmable robots that follow color
codes
um so you can teach young kids how to
program in a really
intuitive sort of way so i had grades
three through five um young girls
working on programming their ozobots to
solve a problem or find its way through
a maze
and then
for the older kids i have actually gone
into the high school classrooms and i've
talked about next generation sequencing
introduced the concept of bioinformatics
and then we've done some really basic
mapping and variant calling on a very
small scale so just to kind of get their
feet wet get them thinking about when
they go to college you know this could
be an option for them
kind of
adding on to that coming from that
we want them to have an option once they
get to college so we are developing a
bioinformatics major at our institution
um i am developing it so right now it's
just me um and i am i'm teaching a few
different courses that are going to
ultimately be part of this major so the
first one is biological programming
which sounds a little scary gotta work
on that name i think a little bit
to make it more palatable to biology
students but this is just really basic
computing skills so you get introduced
to linux the command line
a lot of you know text based
bioinformatic file processing so lots of
fast queue fasta
file processing
just learning how to automate tasks
learning the basics of programming that
they probably haven't been exposed to at
all before so um it's a class for
complete beginners and it's kind of
amazing how much progress they can make
in just a single semester
i will also ultimately be teaching what
we're going to call bioinformatics one
and two
right now i'm teaching bioinformatics
one and we are doing that
through
the galaxy interface so this is a
completely online
server-based
interactive bioinformatic analysis
workflows
and i find that this is really
approachable for biology students who
want to use bioinformatic pipelines for
their research
but they are not so sure that they want
to go down the route of linux and
command line and super computing they
they just really have these small
projects that they're working on they
want to know
how do i run an rna-seq pipeline really
quickly without installing anything on
my computer or finding access to some
kind of
remote server so it's pretty accessible
and we've been doing some different
tutorials with them to kind of go
through some really basic bioinformatic
methods
and then we have a ton of affiliated
courses or what i'm terming affiliated
courses so things like phylogenetic
theory which i teach in the fall
applied microbiology where the students
actually get to sequence
microbiomes and then they will analyze
it with my help
genetics courses we're working more
bioinformatics more computing into the
basic core genetics that we teach at
west liberty
and then we have the opportunity for
these independent student research
projects as well
we're also
elsewhere on campus they are developing
a data science program
that's through the the math department
so i expect there will be a lot of
overlap between those two majors
so um we're going to enhance research
experiences by allowing them to actually
generate their own next generation
sequencing data we have an oxford nano
nanopore uh minion and we have just
secured an iseq so we will have alumina
short read and long read data for them
to analyze um so it's a really exciting
time for the bio department um they're
going to have
so much data and they're definitely
going to need to know how to analyze
this for their class projects
so that includes everything from
amplicon sequencing
some people interested in doing edna
we've had a tick microbiome
project done
i've used it for conservation genomics
so looking at relatedness of
organisms of conservation concern
and then of course we can do rna-seq as
well
we also offer summer training
opportunities
we have the shore program summer
undergraduate research experience
that's an ongoing program at west
liberty and i'm hoping to join in more
with that in the future and actually
training one-on-one students over the
summer to to do bioinformatic research
and then really specific to
bioinformatics we offer the
bioinformatics boot camp every summer
i say every summer last year was our
first year offering it and this year
will be our second
but this is a three-week event
it requires no previous experience we go
from
having no computational experience to
doing basic bioinformatic pipelines by
the end of this project
so
we start with an introduction to linux
and the command line
then we go in the next couple of weeks
into specific pipelines so we give them
a script that has the pipeline and then
we break this pipeline down into
digestible chunks for them so that by
the end of the week they have run the
entire thing and they can reproduce
those results if they wanted to so we do
this for a coven 19 variant analysis and
a mouse rna-seq analysis and the data
that we use is actually from
the genomics core it's been generated by
inbree researchers in west virginia
so here's kind of an example of
how the lecture might go we do a little
powerpoint introduction typically
and at the end of it we may have some
step-by-step directions for them to
follow and explore
and learn things about the the input
files and the analyses that they're
going to run
so it's
very one-on-one very guided
research they work in pairs typically
that just kind of happened naturally in
this first boot camp people sitting next
to each other kind of helping each other
out and then
jim and i would kind of circle around
and and come in when we needed to
to help them troubleshoot and get
through whatever problems they were
having
so i think this is the most important
aspect rather than the content of what
we're teaching that's pretty commonplace
and i think pretty standardized in a lot
of ways but
i think the interaction that we're
having the one-on-one the guided
help that they're getting is really
important to these students
so here's an example of um a path that
we
might follow a pipeline that we might
provide them so this is our
variant analysis on the sars coven 19
data
so
we would show them this at the beginning
and they kind of lose their minds
because it looks like gibberish and then
we walk through step by step you know
what is each of each of these commands
doing
what does this mean what happens if you
modify it in this way or that way
and then they get to see
from start to finish how this pipeline
will get executed
so we go from the raw data all the way
through to calling variants and then
looking at them
comparing them across
different samples assigned to different
students and they can compare their
variants to one another
so um this is currently just open to
west virginia embry undergraduates
so that's anybody enrolled currently in
a west virginia network institution
so it is kind of limited in terms of who
can participate at this point
and we are capping it at about 10
students
for now
um this is still kind of in the pilot
phase i would say um we're still
developing the content and the kind of
core material uh for this boot camp but
we plan on continuing doing this for
several years to come
the students at the end of this get to
do a poster presentation on
you know an insilico manipulation of one
of the pipelines
they get to kind of test out manipulate
some of the steps use a different
program see what the output looks like
change the parameters of a particular
program
and see how that affects their
downstream results and so that's what
they present together
at this
poster
presentation at the west virginia summer
symposium
so that will happen this year as well
it'll be at west virginia university
this year
so we have a lot of potential i think to
expand participation participation in
this event
again once we kind of have our core
material down our method figured out
we will hopefully be able to share
and publish some of these curricular
modules
so
we are planning on doing this but again
this is just kind of the initial phases
a really exciting time to be a part of
the development of this bioinformatic
expertise
so
if anyone is on here that is a member of
west virginia inbury
tell all of your students have them
apply
they can find us online
you can email me about it directly if
you'd like
it's a pretty good deal they get a
stipend they get housing and food paid
for
and they get to learn all of these
bioinformatic topics
and with that i think i will take
any questions that anyone has
great thank you very much nicole that
was an amazing presentation
we have questions for you okay great the
first one
yeah the first one is what is special
about people who return back to
education later in life
in terms of their ability to learn
bioinformatics and especially what
career options they end up choosing
so i'm not sure about the career options
part of that but i will say that the
non-traditional students that i've
worked with
to date
and again it's a small sample size it's
a small school but they tend to be much
more focused they have a much greater
appreciation
of
you know what bioinformatics is good for
what it could be used for kind of more
perspective i guess is what they come
back with
um so they are more open to kind of
exploring these methods and there seem
to be more interested than a lot of the
really young students that come you know
straight from high school
in the career opportunities especially
so you know when i say that you can work
you know for a hospital you could work
for a private company you work for
the federal
fish and wildlife service there are all
kinds of different positions opening up
for people with these types of skill
sets
so i think they see the value in that
yes definitely
so along similar lines to that um what
is the minimal set of skills um a
biology oriented student must have
um to kind of begin their journey into
bioinformatics
so i would say that
i kind of hesitate to frame it as the
minimal number of skills just because i
think that people with no experience are
more than capable
of picking up these skills very quickly
and i've seen it happen um i think
what's more important is not having um
the fear that's associated with kind of
the stigma of oh i'm not good at
computers or i'm not good at math
and they think that they need to be
like i said like rock star geniuses when
it comes to all of these different
fields when really what's most important
is they love biology and they're willing
to
learn and try
to learn the computer part of it and so
students who really don't like to fail
seem to have a lot of trouble with
bioinformatics because it's
mostly failure
you know you try something doesn't work
you troubleshoot and you figure out the
problem so it is a it's definitely a
skill and a muscle that not all of them
have developed
but i think it's definitely worthwhile
even for students who don't want to
pursue a career in bioinformatics just
for the problem-solving skills alone i
think it's very valuable
yes definitely
another question does such a small
undergraduate population have benefits
when it comes to bioinformatics research
i think it does and it's kind of the
same
same set of benefits that really
are in our favor when it comes to
research we get that one-on-one approach
when the students have a question
they just walk right into my office and
talk to me about it
so they have a lot of access to
expertise
that i think you might not experience at
a larger school where you're kind of
just one of many
students in a course
and you know when i teach about
informatics course i have
less than 10 people typically especially
at these early stages of developing the
coursework um
so i i get to work with them directly
and really adapt my teaching style
and the content of the course to them
and their interests
definitely
so another question which of the
programs that you've mentioned
seemed to the greatest learning impact
on young students
of the different courses
yes i think that's what was okay
um
i think the the
the biological programming
um has the potential to have a big
impact
because it teaches these basic
programming skills i think it's like a
foot in the door into computer science
that they may not have experienced
before
so they know pretty quickly i think
whether or not
they like it
and then that's kind of like their first
taste
that brings them
further along this career path toward
becoming a bioinformatician
great thank you and then one final
question have you had any of the your
boot camp projects results in
application
not yet
um but that would be fantastic
if we could get there one day it's such
a kind of
short program in the grand scheme of
things
we do have like the sure program is like
a nine week program and we have had
student publications result from that
so i think
it might need a little bit more time to
develop than just the three weeks but if
we had a student that was interested
they could always pick up with student
research at their institution
um or collaborate with west liberty
um into the future so
there's the potential there but it
hasn't happened yet
definitely thank you
okay
i think that is all thank you again very
much for coming and speaking with us
today dr garrison thank you
all right
now i think we are going to move on to
our panel discussion
so we have several speakers today um
that are principal investigators from
idea states
they are going to discuss today a bit
about the research projects at nappy
some expectations and outcomes
how researchers are using data to
embrace collaboration and answer
questions faster
and how initiatives like strides are
helping to democratize research funding
so i think i will
give it over to you
um
ellia if you are ready
yes uh thank you laura so again we have
here with us uh dr gus casullas he's the
president of nepi
uh mr jesus gomez who is the strategic
business executive for google cloud
uh dr nicole garrison she's the
assistant professor at west virginia
inbree uh dr louis quinones who is the
co-director of puerto rico from inbrie
and i don't see
[Music]
dr judy crabtree who was going to be
here as well but the main question is
as i understand
nepia as a network is trying to solve a
problem that is common across the
network uh in breeze and uh you know the
major challenge is
uh as we just heard from nicole and from
luis
how do you actually make this accessible
to a lot of students um how do you
combine bioinformatics and data science
training in non-bioinformatics and data
science training curriculum
how do you help
students
use bioinformatics and research projects
and then how do you actually move from
education to
careers you know what do they do after
this so maybe because you can start by
kind of sharing what is your vision how
do you address this uh common need
across the network
yeah sure elias so first of all i'm
happy to um
participate in this panel i'm also the
principal investigator of the louisiana
biomedical research network on lbrn
so in that capacity
i could speak also to that in addition
to nappy but i think um
you know one of the big challenges that
we all face is that um
as you correctly i think nicole
mentioned this fear
of computer science bioinformatics
how people get into it
we have a lot of people from biology
that would love to use tools and we have
computer scientists that don't
understand the biology so you know
bridging that gap between those two
disciplines uh becomes very important
and um frankly the only way i see that
obviously uh our 23 states and puerto
rico are doing
their own uh efforts within each state
there's a lot of resources a lot of
manpower
a lot of talent
that's devoted in each state we are
through nappy we haven't seen
maybe as much networking and commonality
allow resources to be shared by others
understand best practices what works
what doesn't work there may be some
specificity to its program but maybe
there are some common things that we
could focus on and what we hope through
napie is to make available
everything that everybody has that could
be shared freely could be made available
including their personal stories right
interviews uh what nicole just talked
about or our puerto rican colleague
mentioned
what works you know what what's the
personal story how
certain students have been approached
and and i think through
examples i think everybody else can
learn
uh to adopt some of these because some
of them may be specific to our own
states and institutions some of them may
be common but i think what nep is trying
to achieve is becoming a medium of
communicating
across the board of all these stories
and successes and see what could be
common um my own
you know how do you transform things
right uh
within lsu at least
we have sort of decided
that the only way to do this
is to really
promote
new
degrees
you know try to get an undergraduate
degree
in
data science and bioinformatics uh
something that
commits people into taking
specific courses and graduating specific
credentials uh we've tried the
certificate issue the training issue
but it's always within primarily the
graduate institutions and my colleagues
could
you know comment on this
it's always typically very hard to get a
student to participate in something
that's extracurricular or certificate
because they really the primary interest
is to graduate and get a degree in
something so unless you have a
degree program
that really focuses you know on data
science and and overall and perhaps by
phobatics specifically or how data
science plays into bioinformatics or the
other way around you know you wouldn't
have probably the impact um
so one of the ideas here at louisiana is
to
try to
promote with epuis
the creation of um
bachelors of science either as a uh uh
major or a minor uh depending on what
the universities is and then at that
level throughout louisiana inbrief lbrn
try to help them
teach that maybe through free content
through things that we could provide
other through
you know
freely available tools through
collaboration with final bad tech or
whatever we can
it's a difficult issue because
as you know probably most of you
changing curriculum from you know
promoting a new course it's it's a very
slow process at least here in louisiana
but uh um
we at lsu are trying now to create a
an undergraduate degree and hopefully a
master's degree there's a master's
degree already offered the new orleans
he hasn't really
[Music]
been launched yet we hope that make it
available
across the institutions in louisiana but
unless we really somehow put this into
the undergraduate curriculum at least as
a minor i don't think when i had the
impact uh you know and i'll stop there
and let my colleagues chime in
yeah uh luis i know that you've thought
about this uh yourself as well uh what
is your thought about this
i agree with dr casulas that we have to
share our common efforts
um to the
inbre webpages and to the nippy web
pages
so everyone can have access around uh
around the nation
so um if i can provide something that
can be useful
to louisiana or to virginia
it will be um it will be a great
pleasure
so um i prefer the stuff not just for me
i i want to share it with everyone
around the island and that is what i'm
doing right now and starting towards
that path to share everyone everything
that i got
with everyone but in that sense i have
to give the training so i am creating
right now a critical mass
with um people with the interest in
bioinformatics so they can start
teaching this stuff
in their courses so
people that wants to belong to the
community of practice is is a voluntary
step
but people don't know want to
participate on this initiative will
receive the impact and the training
because teaching faculty are going to
include this stuff in their courses so
across um biology they will teach this
stuff and
no
students will escape at least receiving
some kind of knowledge and training
so they will be prepared to face
i mean the requirements after they exit
our programs
nicole did you want to add to that
yeah i mean just to kind of
re-emphasize i
that's true
we we should be sharing um i think that
part of the problem is
not that there aren't resources but that
they're not organized in a way that
students can really access and so it is
important to get the faculty to
incorporate these lessons into their
curriculum
so one thing i've been trying to do
and people are very willing to let me do
this is do guest lectures
for a particular topic that is more
bioinformatically oriented
even if it's very basic just introducing
the students to me as a professor and to
the topic
seems to be very helpful and then they
start asking questions about like where
can i learn more of this if i take this
class will i get more of this kind of
stuff
because they just really don't even
realize what bioinformatics is
so i think that really does help to get
other professors in non-bioinformatic
courses teaching some of this type of
material
so so with us we have jesus who
hasn't the chance to introduce himself
yet so i hope that he does this now
but also you know i hope this is you can
put aside kind of your professional role
for a second as a you know a person who
has maybe a product a solution uh and
think of this as you know uh this is
this program this idea program um
targets a very specific audience that
has unique needs um and special kinds of
uh objectives
so just as a company you know as someone
that has
that industry perspective um how do you
view this perspective maybe starting
from an introduction of who you are and
what you're you know here to represent
and then into that problem that we're
discussing
yeah sure um can you hear me
yes okay perfect um my name is jesus
gomez i am part of the strategy and
innovation group
uh within google and i am responsible
for the solutions in education and
academic research
have been in google over
five years almost six and have worked
with many research groups on
bioinformatics across universities
biobanks
uh the broad institute etc
um i have been also engaged on the
strides program we were the foundational
member
first participated uh member of of the
strike program so
one of the things that we keep hearing
from the bioinformatics that is very
aligned to your comments is
when you ask researchers
for example this is just an example how
much time
do they spend in trying to reproduce
results
uh sometimes they say that 30
of that time it's just trying to
reproduce results so imagine that you
have a grant
where
uh
you have to apply
personal medicine pipeline and you work
with another institution that
institution has to provide results you
have to validate that result
you are spending you get that pipeline
from then you spend 30 percent of your
time maybe even 30 of your grant in
trying to reproduce that result
and that's a challenge right
and so one of the things that we are
doing from the technology perspective is
we're doing two things working with nih
and the and and the rest of partners
here one is
technology development is how
much you can abstract researchers from
the complexity of technology so that
they can focus on the science as much as
possible okay so if you run a pipeline
in a university
and you're running another university
tomorrow you should get the same result
easily
that's one of the things that we're
doing the other thing that we are doing
is we are working with the strides
to create personalized training
okay where we say like okay this is for
bioinformatics this is for medical
imaging this is for
interoperability of healthcare data and
that's to your point that could be
this type of training that is
created between the industry and
academic can be great to be incorporated
in the curriculum in the new programs
that you are launching in university
type of transversal skills you know
there are some basic transversal skills
that will apply to
everyone those are training that are
funded by nih that you can leverage nih
is being allocated that budget they send
people to your university to train on
that
to use this tool to know how to use this
tool and then you on the top
you add your own curriculum content your
science
knowledge right and i think if we can do
that
we can help the community
to actually get much more
out of the grant
and much faster right i think
we are at that point where we are at the
intersection of technology and science
and sometimes we have the problem that
we
are making too difficult
for great great scientists to use
technologies you know
they don't have to become experiencing
technology they have to use the tools
and our job is how easily you can
make them to use this tool so that they
can focus on science
thank you but you know i think for all
of us uh that brings us to the next
question the question is funding right
so
a lot of
the efforts that are being described
here funded through nih grants you know
the center grants etc so uh gus you know
as somebody who's managed and received
millions of dollars in grant funding um
how do you see a more effective use of
that funding to incorporate such
training you know introduction to
different tools you know these are tools
that perhaps are not very cheap like
google cloud you know how do you see
that just from a funding perspective
well um
obviously
uh
the funding that's provided by nih or
other resources is fairly limited um
and typically is driven by large
programs that are funded on a
competitive basis
that unfortunately for us
uh sort of
excludes or doesn't focus on the idea
states and
one of the basic principles of nhgms at
this point
is that in order to have the country be
competitive
all states have to participate and be
elevated so i think it's a
responsibility not only of the federal
government but also companies like
google amazon ibm
to really focus and provide resources to
those 24 states because that's basically
where the perhaps even the biggest
impact could be achieved in terms of you
know manpower development
so
i would definitely
try to
attract the
institutional
private
public partnerships
to create uh an environment where it's
conducive to
be transformative
and you know i would turn the table to
uh uh our google representative jesus
and ask him the question if google was
to
um
think
of an undergraduate curriculum
that focuses on data science and
bioinformatics
you know what would it be
because you know the perspective is
different right you know in in the
university setting
we're teaching biology we're teaching
you know a lot of molecular biology and
sort of by the way
you first asked the question and then
you go about finding
how to answer
the question and one of the approaches
could be to use a bi-formatic tool
a lot of the other approaches is more
wet lab-based that a lot of people
concentrate but we're at the point that
the reverse made happening where
basically through systems biology a lot
of the questions could be posed there
are totally different questions that you
would ask from the biology perspective
so and i think sitting
in companies like google or amazon and
so on
i suspect their perspective is very
different so i don't know uh jesus
whether um
google has been thinking what would it
be the ideal curriculum
for a an undergraduate degree
in data science slash bioinformatics
that's a great question so
and um this is something that we keep
refining based on things that we
have from you right because you are the
ones that actually
knows all the challenges and how we can
overcome there are two things that we
are trying to do as an example in our
side
the first thing is
for a student for example we give
all the consumption is free
any student
globally
can access our tool for a
teaching and learning practice at the
school at no cost
okay that's the first thing that we do
like
everyone that is curious to use this
tool
should be able to use it even if they
cannot afford it
and that's we have our credit program
at the same time
we have created free training that is
available in internet that you can
incorporate in your program for example
joe hawking's medicine school is using
our free training as part of the
curriculum you could include that as
well
with basic skills that we think
are very important for the
undergraduate
students so that they can start asking
the right question about the data
okay and i will give you an example
all the
nih reference data sets are
on cloud through a stride
any student can access gcga
dva gen 3 data
the public data set
and can run analysis with these tools at
no cost and one of the thing that you
can check for example is getting people
that has
a variant is specific genomic and
compare with
the reference data set on the average
people and you can start seeing the
difference then you can pick on certain
genomes start seeing the difference so
what we are trying to do is like
how easy we can do
to encourage that curiosity of the
student right
then there is
one gap that is the most difficult one
is that yeah we can create that content
you can give access to the technology
but behind that context is the science
knowledge and this is something that we
will never be able to re to to to
um replace this is where you need your
programs right you need to make sure
that you can connect the students
with these tools
and you help them to reason and to find
this answer by themselves right so i
think
in our case what we are trying to do is
just
helping your students to be able to
answer
bigger questions much faster
okay
but then
that is the challenge of why you need a
program right i i think is is not a
challenge it's a reality you need a
science program to be able to ask the
right questions
yeah i would let my colleagues also
chime in but
you know and you don't have to answer
this right now but i'll post this
question you know with google
and your under your leadership
uh would be willing to partner with
nappy
and the idea program in creating the
idea curriculum
uh
yes
actually yes this is something that we
can do
um
we have people in our team that sit with
your professor
and your professors say i'm teaching
this and this and say okay so in this
section
this tutorial is relevant
and it helps you to map the menu to what
you are teaching
and that's something that we can do for
you okay so
we
there is a challenge we all need this
type of skills
and to your point we'll need to make
sure that this gets out of all the
institutions
you know i'm telling you i got my degree
in spain
in spring nobody has access to large
data centers
nobody has access to tools
i had a challenge
right now we have the possibility to
get rid of that challenge to everyone so
everyone has the same access to the same
tools
and this is something that we take it
really seriously
and we have resources for that so if you
are looking into incorporated is a kind
of tool in your program that is exactly
what we have created these tools and we
are happy to collaborate with you
because for us to be better as a society
we need to develop skills in all type of
researchers everywhere
yeah
thank you
we're going to address you for the
newspring meeting in october
[Laughter]
so maybe just to give also an
opportunity to lose and nicole after
this i mean what do you think is the
role of nepy i know that nepea exists in
part to kind of connect all of these
different efforts not only just to
connect them but also to see funding
right so um i mean
nicole luis
who wants to add to this discussion
about you know funding challenges so i
need to correct you um if i may we are
not
not-for-profit institutions so we don't
have lobbying authority but you know we
are promoting networking to make people
competitive
right exactly yeah in that sense
do you want to go first dr garrison or
do i go first
go for it
okay
i think that i have seen navy in action
during the
last year southeast um
regional conference
and um
they brought a lot of information share
a lot of information with us
and spread the word among the
participants so i think that maybe
performs uh
a vital role uh in the inver programs
and is is a way to unite on all of us
um
to increase the diversity and receive
more information of the opportunities
that are out there for us
so i think that
um the collaboration with navy and
google will be a hit
that would be fantastic i mean uh
we would love to do it um we even have
just to give you an idea we even have
worked with nsf and nih to create a
separate budget just for minority
institutions
okay
um and
[Music]
just to give you an idea of how we help
we help into into a two unfunded
researchers
two students i already say right
we help you to incorporate in the
curriculum they have free access
to the tools
even for post-graduates and principal
investigators
we have programs that give them credit
so that they can use this tool to come
up with very competitive grant proposals
for free at no cost
okay
and once they receive
the grant
we uh we have just launched the last
year
the possibility that is a flat fee
so that you can use this tool
whether you run one time the simulation
and you're running one million times
you will never
exceed your budget
this is something that we are doing
because we understand
that you have to be able to attract
good researchers and these good
researchers need to understand that if
they join your university they can win
grants
and for that we have to
bring this type of tools and programs so
we continually listen so we would love
to partner with you
apply the existing program that we have
and
if we have to tweak it for some reason
let's tweak it because
if it's good for the community
that's our mission right
that's great yep
nicole did you want to add anything to
that or
i'm going to be honest i don't know that
i have much to add i'm actually learning
a lot about the connections between all
of these different programs
coming from
being outside of the inbree system i'm
still learning
how everybody is connected and how we're
working together so
i think it seems like the connections
are
very valuable and the knowledge of how
those all work together all these
different programs and how google might
contribute is important for someone in
my position who is the connection
between the students and these bigger
programs because inbrie and nepy and
like these don't mean anything to our
students
they are concerned with how am i going
to learn this skill and how am i going
to pass this class
but if we can show them hey here are the
resources they don't really care where
it comes from
as long as they know how to access it
and what it's used for i think
that would be beneficial to them so
i'm going to take what i learn here and
and try and make more connections myself
we have been monitoring a community
student
in the last two years this
um
for example healthcare hackathons
has been
uh
the the engagement level of all the
users has been impressive and we have
been monitoring on the background
and we are member of of the hackathon
event and we see that
companies like pfizer gsk
are being part of those hackathons as
well and and you will be surprised on
how
once you create with a small effort that
community that community is
self-organized many times you know where
you were mentioning before
i think that the
the challenge is
as a group you have to decide what is
the right
organization so that people can find
things easily
but once you create that people start
sharing pipeline best practices
you know um there are for example
companies that say like hey i need i
have this problem
this is the topic of the hackathon
and there are
groups from students from many programs
that are heavily engaging because it's
also the possibility to
get visibility and get a good job
and and
i would say don't underestimate the
power of the community
because it's really important and and
you know there are a lot of people that
volunteer and do a good job managing
managing that
and you know that's actually a great
point uh and we have been taking in
nappy to actually be able to do what i
call active participation as opposed to
passive um so we need to think about
hackathons or health
related things that would be across the
board you know because you know we could
list the information and it's sort of in
a passive way somebody can go in there
and look at it but to actually engage
and and encourage
young uh you know students uh
and and really engage them in a
meaningful way you need something active
something that they can really work on
and the question is what is this
maybe a hackathon would be type of
activity could be something else
a problem posted and frankly personally
i see the involvement
of industry as a major component to that
uh not only for getting philanthropic
funding that the thing is needed but
even beyond that to connect
really the academic world with the
industrial world because ultimately our
graduates would be you know your
employees all in the long run and
elsewhere and they will contribute uh
you know in the in terms of economic
development in multiple sectors so
that's what we're trying to do with
nippy we kind of restarted built a new
website we're trying to
get some automated systems in
it will take some time to get to that
level hopefully at the nisbri
meeting in october we'll be able to
launch some of these new activities and
invite participants um it would be
a process right
and at some point i'd love to see a uh
an undergraduate degree here in
louisiana taught in
20 undergraduate institutions
with listed in all their curricula but
really taught by multiple faculty that
are really dispersed
you know within the state that could be
replicated in west virginia could be
replicated somewhere else and who knows
maybe at some point it would be uh an
idea undergraduate degree you know
that's actually uniform across the
network uh but i mean that's basically
the
long-term vision
uh and i think
and i've seen this because i've been for
many years in academia
you see some young minds that get
exposed and they blossom and they become
extremely good
but you have to provide an opportunity
because if they don't see it they don't
get to interact they don't get the right
mentorship early on they actually lost
they end up in some other field you know
that that really they could have done
much better elsewhere so really
mentoring and reaching as early as
possible becomes very important
i just want to add to that we had
another speaker earlier today from the
pistola alliance
the pistol alliance brings together all
the major pharmaceutical companies
and they have somehow figured out a way
to partner on pre-competitive challenges
that all of them face
and i think that this is somewhat
similar to what we're trying to you know
discuss here because
um everybody has their interests
everybody's got their objectives but in
in some areas like training and like you
know encouraging students to pursue
certain topics this is a field where
everybody can agree to work together and
find a meaningful way to get that and i
think the hackathon idea actually is
really great
um
i'll use this opportunity to say that
uh you mentioned that the mystery
meeting is in october right guys right
this meeting information will be posted
on the nebby website very soon
and once it is and we'll of course send
it out to everybody who's participated
in this meeting as well
maybe this is the time to start planning
because um you know hackathons even
though they seem like just the time to
get together and do something you know
in reality they take a lot of planning
for people to be prepared identifying
topics all of these things
so
this is definitely a great idea
because you wanted to add something to
that yeah um i have an idea for that um
let's get for example the state of
louisiana right you talk to your hhs
department and they settle this senate
and you ask the like what is more
important for you
they're going to tell you maybe tobacco
research
maybe cancer research
we can do that the topic of the
hackathon okay we get a
public data set
of data luciana research
and we ask a question to the
participants and then all the schools
agree
that the students participating are
going to go into their
contest and you are going to give them a
grade and an assignment based on the
position on the hackathon
i commit to give the credit so that
everyone can run the tool for free
and we will have somebody to we will
share training on the tools in advance
and we can even
try to have somebody on site to help
them
really fantastic ideas
happening yeah estate is happy as
schools start collaborating students are
engaged
we give it a try let's see what happened
yeah and we can replicate that later and
we could work with elia and see how what
we could fit something and that
right now in uh louisiana cancer is
number one target obviously because
there's a lot of effort and we if you
look at heat maps you know of course if
you look at even at uh
across the board on idea states you know
cancer obesity
diabetes
poverty these are common you know
difficulties
so
cancer is number one interesting enough
because we're now cannabis
producers they have cannabis related
drugs
and therapeutics are also
a target uh for across the state but i'm
not sure what kind of a topic could be
mined
out of that i've been told that 180 180
drugs
chemicals that actually use all sorts of
purposes and the question is
how could it be applied and what kind of
you know
data mining it really is available and
needed after that but
just parenthetically i'm mentioning
these two targets
of course we are
big on infectious diseases
we have
in essence three primate centers
the tulane national primary center i'm
chairing the external advisory committee
there
we have the uh
chimp sanctuary in shreveport and the
new iberia private center
and so infectious diseases including um
obviously kobe 19 and everything else um
from west nile to dengue to chinga kunya
and other viruses also become very
important but you know there are also
some interesting topics i think cancer
may be an
overall topic that really will
re-vibrate across all our idea states
and that's a big one as you know
president biden
is pushing rph which is the program the
federal program let me add 5 billion to
nih that would be targeted for cancer
research
the state of louisiana has set as
priority 1 cancer research our new
president tate that came from usc
uh south carolina has cancer's priority
number one interesting now data science
and mathematics is a priority number two
for lsu right now so
i'm pleased to actually see that uh you
know directed from the president um so
yeah that would be fantastic so we can
work on that and we could revisit this
issue with uh you know with google and
you know pine bloodtech and see what can
be done
so briefly before everyone else leaves
because we're kind of running over time
i did want to mention laura here
who has been doing a wonderful job
throughout the symposium to coordinate
everybody's talks and introduce everyone
she's going to be around to uh be
involved in this uh project so
uh hopefully over the the course of the
next few months i will be able to be in
contact with all of the inbree programs
related to bioinformatics data science
we've got the contacts at google
who have been uh participating here and
presenting their tools and we'll try to
really involve as many people as
possible and maybe that's that's one of
the first things like you mentioned you
know what is that major topic that
everybody can agree on
that students will be interested in
companies will be interested in
faculty will be interested in
you know maybe in terms of funding
priorities also you know what is the top
funding priority to to give them a
motivation
and i think on a heck of a thing even
nih could be interested or through
supplemental funding uh especially you
know google anybody else would be
interested so um if we could do
something in the context of nisbri it
would be great because you know
normally we get up to a thousand
participants because this is virtual
it's possible that we go to 1500 or
higher on the first week of october
there will be a lot of people including
uh
you know administrative uh
political and other entities uh
listening in so i think this is the time
where a network could really push
forward uh for the next uh sort of
transformational steps uh because we
kind of um if i may we kind of wobble
around we're doing different things
we're doing a great job locally
but we don't have uh
orders of magnitude right we haven't
really
harnessed the power of those 23 states
in puerto rico you know working together
we do represent half of the country
maybe even more than half of the
population and a lot of resources so
people have to listen to us and we need
all the assistance that we we uh we
deserve and that to really be able to
fulfill
um you know is
participating you know in our success as
we have demonstrated really by
graduating nationally competitive
investigators uh that come from the idea
state uh i only gonna leave you the last
note of from the point of view nepe
the idea states that the net exporters
are talent to everybody else right so
our undergrad students graduated in
sports tax and faculty
get extremely successful and
unfortunately for us a lot of them moved
to you know mit harvard uh
texas and elsewhere which is i think a
success but ultimately i think we need
to create
circumstances we can develop these
resources
where they originate
all right well thank you everyone again
for participating we have a plan of
action uh great contribution from
everyone who joined and from all the
speakers so thank you again uh we will
be following up and being in touch again
uh laura i wanted her to be on here and
for everyone to connect the dots and and
really be in touch so thank you again
uh jesus for joining and supporting this
idea uh really uh good to have you with
us
and thank you for having us and
thank you for what you do for your
community it's awesome and thank you eli
laura you've done a great job that's
wonderful to actually listening on and
off throughout these couple days great
job
thank you thank you for coming and
speaking as well to all of you
all right thank you everyone and thank
you luis uh again for joining and for
sharing today and nicole garrison uh
thank you
and gus it's always a pleasure to see
and hear your insights about all this
everyone
all right take care